WILL COME TO ORDER GOOD MORNING
MEMBERS IN RESPONSE TO THE COPA
NINETEEN EMERGENCY AND TO
PROTECT THE PUBLIC LEGISLATORS
AND EMPLOYEES WE MUST LIMIT
NONESSENTIAL GATHERINGS AND IT
HERE TO SOCIAL DISTANCING AND
FACE COVERING GUIDELINES AND
COMPLIANCE WITH THOSE ORDERS
THE SENATE HAS MADE NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS. TO NORMAL
PRACTICES IN ORDER TO ENSURE
THAT THE PUBLIC CONTINUES TO
HAVE ACCESS TO THE LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS TO ALLOW THE PUBLIC
ACCESS WE HAVE ADMITTED MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC TO TWO HEARING
ROOMS TO THE EXTENT THAT SOCIAL
DISTANCING REQUIREMENTS ALLOW
AND WILL BE USING A
TELECONFERENCE ORVIS. FOR THOSE
INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH TO TESTIFY
TODAY FOR ALL INDIVIDUALS WHO
WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY FOR
PUBLIC COMMENT THE PARTICIPANT
TOLL FREE NUMBER AND ACCESS
CODE IS POSTED ON OUR COMMITTEE
WEBSITE IT WILL BE DISPLAYED ON
THE SCREEN AND I WILL ANNOUNCE
IT NOW. TODAY'S PARTICIPANT
NUMBER IS. 1-877-336-4437 AGAIN
THAT'S. EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN THREE
THREE SIX FOUR FOUR THREE
SEVEN. ACCESS CODE. EIGHT TWO
SIX EIGHT FOUR TWO EIGHT. FOR
DETAILED INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW
THE CONFERENCE SYSTEM WORKS
PLEASE REFER TO THE SENATE
COMMITTEE WEBSITE. WHEN WE
MOVED TO PUBLIC COMMENT YOU
WILL BE PROMPTED BY A MODERATOR
TO DIAL ONE THEN ZERO FOR
SUPPORT AND OPPOSITION. PRESS
THIS ONLY ONE TIME AND WAIT
PATIENTLY FOR AN OPERATOR TO
ASSIGN YOU A LINE NUMBER. THIS
CAN BE A SHORT WAIT ONCE YOU
RECEIVE YOUR LINE NUMBER YOU
WILL WAIT IN THE QUEUE FOR THE
MODERATOR TO CALL YOUR LINE
NUMBER AT THE TIME. AT THAT
TIME YOU WILL BE ON MUTED AND
YOU ARE NOW READY TO ADDRESS
THE COMMITTEE. PLEASE NOTE THAT
IN IN ORDER FOR US TO HEAR YOU
CLEARLY AND TO AVOID ACOUSTIC
FEEDBACK. YOU MUST MEET THE
DEVICE YOU'RE WATCHING. THE
HEARING ON PRIOR TO GIVING
TESTIMONY OVER THE PHONE IT'S
IMPORTANT THAT WE HEAR FROM YOU
AND WE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE. I WILL SUBMIT TO
MAINTAIN DECORUM DURING THE
HEARING AS IS CUSTOMARY IN ANY
INDIVIDUAL WHO IS DISRUPTED MAY
BE REMOVED FROM THE REMOTE
MEETING SERVICE FOR HAVE THEIR
CUT. CONNECTIONS NEEDED. FOR
EACH BILL WE PROVIDE AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR TWO PRIMARY
WITNESSES FOR SUPPORT AND
OPPOSITION. ANY OTHER PUBLIC
TESTIMONY WILL BE LIMITED TO
IDENTIFYING YOURELF YOU'RE
ORGANIZED THE STATION AND
WHETHER YOU SUPPORT OR OPPOSE
THE BILL ONLY. WELL EVERY
EFFORT HAS BEEN MADE TO
STREAMLINE THE HEARING PROCESS
AND CONDUCT OUR HEARINGS IN AS
CLOSE AS THE MATTER. IS THE
MATTER AS IS CUSTOARY THERE
MAY BE SOME LAG TIMES FOR
PARTICIPANTS WHO ARE ADJUSTING
TO THE NEW USE OF ONLINE TOOLS
AND TECHNOLOGIES. THAT'S ALL
PLEASE BE RESPECTFUL AND
PATIENT. MEMBERS WE HAVE A
LARGE AGENDA TODAY WE ACTUALLY
HAVE TEN BILLS ONE THAT ONE
BILL THAT WILL BE HELD THREE ON
CONSENT. AND SO WE NEED TO
FINISH AS CLOSE AS POSSIBLE TO
NOON- NOW LET'S GET STARTED
WITH THE BUSINESS OF THE
COMMITTEE BY ESTABLISHING A
QUORUM. CONSULTANT CAN YOU
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. TERROR
GONZALEZ. HERE IN DALLAS HERE
BATES H. HERE HELEN. SUCH A
LETTER. BETTER BETTER HERE.
CORTESE CORTESE HERE DELHI
DELHI HERE. DOT WHERE.
BELINDA'S MAN. MANY IN NEW IN
HERE YEAH IT WILL BE A PRESENT.
SKINNER NUMBER. WHAT KASKY WHAT
KASKY HERE BOOK. YEAH OF COURSE
WE DO HAVE A QUORUM THAT'S
WONDERFUL THANK YOU MISTER
CONSULTANT- SO FIRST
ANNOUNCEMENT AS MENTIONED
EIGHTY THREE SIXTY THREE BY
MEDINA HAS BEEN PUT OVER WE
WILL BE HEARING THAT BILL TODAY
AND WE HAVE A SHORT CONSENT
CALENDAR THERE ARE BUILT THESE
THE FOLLOWING BILLS ON CONSENT-
S. C. R. THIRTY NINE BY ALAN A.
B. THREE FORTY NINE BY HOLDEN'S
AC OR EIGHTY EIGHT BY
O'DONNELL- DOES ANYONE HAVE ANY
OBJECTION TO ANY BUILDING ON
THE CONSENT CALENDAR. HEARING
NONE IS THERE A MOTION FOR THE
CONSENT CALENDAR. MOVED BY
SENATOR PACKARD THANK YOU. WILL
HAVE TO CONSENT CALENDARS AFTER
THAT- SO THE FIRST IS FOR. S.
C. R. THIRTY NINE BY SENATOR
ALAN. AND THE SECOND WILL BE
FOR A. B. THREE FORTY NINE AND
EASIER EIGHTY EIGHT. CONSULTANT
CAN YOU PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ON
THE FIRST CONSENT CALENDAR
PLEASE. ON CONSENT CALENDAR
NUMBER ONE. GONZALES HI
CONSEILLERS I IT'S BATES HI
HELEN. ARCHULETA BECKER. BECKER
I CORTESE CORTESE I. DALI DALI
HI DOT. ENQUIRE MELINDA'S MAN
MAN HI. NEWMAN HI RUBIO. RUBIO
HI SKINNER. NUMBER BY CAL SKI
HI KATHY I WILL. NINE AM WILL
HAVE TO TAKE THE SECOND ONE
RIGHT. OKAY THANK YOU THAT I
WILL LEAVE THAT CONSENT
CALENDAR THE FIRST ONE ON CALL
THE SECOND ONE AGAIN WILL BE
FOR EIGHTY THREE FORTY NINE
HOLDEN AND EASIER EIGHTY EIGHT
WE'LL TAKE THAT ONE. VERY
QUICKLY AND THEN WE'LL MOVE ON
TO OUR AGENDA. I CONSENT
CALENDAR NUMBER TO. CONSULT US
FIVE DOLLARS HI BATES. BATES HI
ALAN BUT YOUR LETTER. BECKER
BECKER HI DAISY CORTESE I THE
ONLY. DAWALY I'VE DONE. WHERE
LET'S MAN. NEWMAN NEWMAN I YEP
RUBIO I SCANNER. AMBERG BY
KELSEY KELSEY I WILL HE- EIGHT
VOTES OKAY WE'LL LEAVE THAT
CONSENT CALENDAR ON HOLD ON
CALL AND SORRY AS WELL AND NOW
WILL TAKE UP THE BILLS
ACCORDING TO THE AUTHOR THAT IS
HERE SO WE HAVE- ASSEMBLYMEMBER
HOLDEN WHO'S BEEN WAITING
PATIENTLY AND HE WILL GO AND
PRESENT HIS BILL AB SIX FORTY
ONE WELCOME ASSEMBLYMEMBER
HOLDEN. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS. FIRST I'D LIKE TO
START BY AGREEING TO THE
AMENDMENT AS DISCUSSED IN
SENATE ENERGY LAST WEEK. AND TO
THOSE PROPOSED IN YOUR
COMMITTEE TODAY. THESE
AMENDMENTS FURTHER CLARIFIED
THAT THE BILL DOES NOT MANDATE
PO USED TO MAINTAIN PUBLICLY
BUT PUBLIC CHARGERS THEY DON'T
pCHARGES THEY MUST MAKE
AVAILABLE AND MAKE A MINOR
TECHNICAL CORRECTIONS TO THE
BILL. I'D LIKE TO THINK THE
CHEERS AND THE COMMITTEE STAFF
AGAIN FOR THEIR WORK AND
DEDICATION TO IMPROVING THE
SPILL. AS WE HAVE SEEN DEMAND
FOR ELECTRIC VEHICLES IS
GROWING. WE HAVE SET STATEWIDE
GOAL OF EIGHT MILLION EV'S BY
TWENTY THIRD. IN ORDER TO
SUPPORT OUR DRIVERS WILL NEED
OVER ONE POINT TWO MILLION
SHARED AND PRIVATE CHARGES TO
ALL COME ONLINE. BUILD OUT OF
THE V. CHARGERS IS OCCURRING IN
MANY AREAS BUT WE ARE RELYING
HEAVILY ON THE STATE'S ELECTRIC
UTILITY OR I WILL USE. TO FILL
THIS NEED. YOU MUST BE SURE
THAT PEER USER FILLING THE GAP
IN THEIR TERRITORIES AS WELL AS
A SERVER A THIRD OF OUR STATE'S
ELECTRIC CUSTOMERS. THIS WILL
WILL DO JUST THAT BY REQUIRING
ALL PEOPLE USE TO ENSURE PUBLIC
CHARGING IS AVAILABLE IN THEIR
TERRITORIES. AND IT GIVES THEM
FULL LATITUDE ON HOW THEY MAKE
THAT HAPPEN INCLUDING CHARGING
CUSTOMERS FOR THE SERVICE OR
WORKING WITH PRIVATE INDUSTRY
TO FILL THE NEED. BECAUSE OF
THE AMENDMENTS THERE IS NO
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILLAND IT
IS MY REQUEST OF THE MEMBERS
WHEN I VOTE ON EIGHTY. SIX
FORTY ONE. THANK YOU
ASSEMBLYMEMBER AND WE HAVE- THE
BILL MOVED BY SENATOR MCCASKEY
I'M AT THIS TIME WE'LL TAKE
YOUR LEAD WITNESS AND SUPPORT
WE HAVE SCOTT WATCHED FROM THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
ELECTRICAL WORKERS HE'S HERE IN
PERSON MR WATCH THE RED HEAD.
GOOD MORNING- MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS GOT WHICH SHOULD BE AT
THE STATE ASSOCIATION OF
ELECTRICAL WORKERS. AS YOU KNOW
40% OF THE STATE'S GHG
EMISSIONS COMES FROM THE
TRANSPORTATION SECTOR- THIS
LEGISLATURE HAS DONE AN
ADMIRABLE JOB OF DIRECTING THE
INVESTOR OWNED UTILITIES. TO
INVEST IN BUILDING. EVE YOU
CHARGING STATIONS
INFRASTRUCTURE ACROSS OUR
ENTIRE SERVICE TERRITORY
UNFORTUNATELY. THAT IS NOT THE
CASE WITH MANY OF THE PUBLICLY
OWNED UTILITIES. AND THE
PRIVATE SECTOR PARTICULARLY
IGNORES COMMUNITIES THAT ARE
ECONOMICALLY DISADVANTAGED IN
AND ARE PREDOMINANTLY LOW
INCOME. SO IN ORDER TO ENSURE
THAT WE DO NOT HAVE COMMUNITIES
LEFT BEHIND. WE BELIEVE THAT
EIGHTY SIX FORTY ONE IS
ESSENTIAL TO ENSURE THAT ALL
CALIFORNIANS HAVE ACCESS TO
CLEAN ENERGY VEHICLES SO WE
WOULD URGE YOU KNOW I'VE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU MR WELCH- SO WE
WILL GO TO THE TELECONFERENCE
LINE MODERATOR IF YOU HAVE
ANYONE ON THE LINE PLEASE IN.
SUPPORT OF EIGHTY SIX FORTY
ONE. HE THANK YOU MADAM. AND
LADIES AND GENTLMEN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF
EIGHTY SIX FORTY ONE YOU MAY
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF EIGHTY SIX
FORTY ONE YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO. WE HAVE NO ONE IN
THE QUEUE IN SUPPORT OF EIGHTY
SIX FORTY ONE OKAY THANK YOU
MODERATOR I WILL GO TO THE
GALLERY ANYONE IN SUPPORT OF
EIGHTY SIX FORTY ONE C. NONE
WILL GO TO ROOM ONE TWELVE. C.
NINE WILL GO BACK TO YOU-
MODERATOR IF THERE'S ANYONE
ELSE IN THERE ARE NO- I'M SORRY
WE JUST CONCLUDED SUPPORT SO
WE'LL GO TO THE OPPOSITION AT
THIS TIME. THERE IS NO LEAD
OPPOSITION- TESTIMONY SO WE'LL
GO TO THE LINES IF THERE'S
ANYONE IN OPPOSITION MODERATOR.
TO AB SIX FORTY ONE PLEASE.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF
EIGHTY SIX FORTY ONE YOU MAY
PRESS ONE AND ZERO AT THIS TIME.
QUICK AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION EIGHTY SIX
FORTY ONE YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND
THEN THERE. WE HAVE NO ONE IN
THE QUEUE AT THIS TIME THANK
YOU MODERATOR WILL GO TO THE
GALLERY ANYONE IN OPPOSITION.
THE C. NINE WILL GO TO ROOM ONE
TWELVE C. NINE NO ONE ELSE IN
OPPOSITION WE CONCLUDE BOTH
SUPPORT AND OPPOSITION WE'LL
TAKE IT BACK TO MEMBERS FOR ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. K. C.
NINE AND ASSEMBLY MEMBER
HOLDING THANK YOU FOR TAKING
THE AMENDMENTS- AND THIS IS
CERTAINLY ANOTHER OPPORTUNITY
TO FILL THE GAP FOR THIS- NEED
FOR L. ELECTRIFICATION AND
PLANNING FOR THAT. WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE. PERSONAL FINANCE
FOR RIVALS. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH- WE HAVE CONCLUDED THIS SO
CAN WE GO AHEAD AND- TAKE A
MOTION ON EIGHTY SIX FORTY ONE
PLEASE. OKAY SENATOR RUBIO I'M
SORRY SENATOR MCCASKEY ALREADY
DID CENTER CASTS HIS MOVE THE
BILL. MR CONSULTANT CAN YOU
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
AND REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE
ON APPROPRIATIONS. CONSULTS HI
CONSULTAS HI BATES. ALAN
ARCHULETA. BECKER BETTER HIGH
CORTESE CORTESE HI DOLLY. DOT
WE'RE GLAD. PEOPLE IN THIS. MAN
NEWMAN NEWMAN I REVEAL BILL HI
SKINNER. NUMBER BY CASCADE WHAT
CASKEY I WILL. SIX ZERO OKAY
SIX ZERO SEVEN NUMBER WILL LEAD
THE CALL THE LONG CALL THANK
YOU THANK. OKAY I SEE OUR NEXT
AUTHOR- MY COLLEAGUE IN THE
ASSEMBLY ASSEMBLYWOMAN FRIEDMAN.
WHO HAS TO BUILD UP TODAY. N.
OR TWO FORTY THREE FOR. OKAY
THAT'S OKAY OKAY WONDERFUL
WE'RE GONNA GO AHEAD AND TAKE
UP A FILE ITEM NUMBER THREE
THAT IS AT FORTY THREE- AND OUR
CHIEF CONSULTANT WILL BE
PASSING OUT THE AMENDMENTS THAT
WERE ACCEPTED- SO ASSEMBLYWOMAN
IF YOU'D LIKE TO GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU THE CHAIR CHAIRWOMAN
GONZALEZ AND MEMBERS OF FIRST
I'D LIKE TO THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR AND YOUR STAFF FOR YOUR
WORK ON THIS BILL IN YOUR
ASSISTANCE AND HELP- WE ARE
GOING TO BE RUDE ACCEPTING THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS AS
OTLINED ON PAGES SIX AND SEVEN
INCLUDING REMOVING THE SECTION
RELATING TO SCHOOL ZONES. I
ALSO WANT TO THANK OUR TRIPLE A
FOR WORKING WITH OUR OFFICE
SINCE MARCH ON TIGHTENING THE
DEFINITIONS IN THE BILL TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE DON'T HAVE ANY
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES. THE
GOAL OF THIS BILL IS SIMPLY TO
HELP CITIES HAVE MORE
FLEXIBILITY WHEN THEY SET SPEEDLIMITS IN ORDER TO SAVE LIVES
AND A CENTER TRAFFIC SAFETY
RATHER THAN SPEED AS THE
PRIMARY GOAL OF OUR SPEED
LIMITS AND OF OUR ROADS. SO HOW
DID THIS COME ABOUT SO I
REPLIED WE USED TO BE ON THE
CITY COUNCIL THE CITY OF
GLENDALE WHICH IS A CITY THAT
LIKE MANY OF OUR CITIES IN THE
STATE HAS A TRAFFIC SAFETY
PROBLEM WE HAVE AN UNUSUALLY
HIGH AMOUNT OF PEDESTRIAN
DEATHS EVERY SINGLE YEAR AND
THE CITY HAS MADE TRAFFIC
SAFETY A HIGH PRIORITY IN THE
CITY FOR A NUMBER OF YEARS.
INSTITUTING TRAFFIC CALMING
MEASURES WORKING WITH THE
PUBLIC DOING EDUCATION BUT ONE
THING IS REALLY FRUSTRATED OR
CITY WHICH IS BEING CONSTANTLY
FORCED TO RAISE SPEED LIMITS TO
ACCOMMODATE SPEEDING DRIVERS
EVEN AS WE'RE TRYING TO
PRIORITIZE ROAD SAFETY. AND
THIS IS BECAUSE CALIFORNIA
USES- A SYSTEM CALLED THE
EIGHTY FIFTH PERCENTILE THAT
FORCES CITIES TO THAT IN ORDER
TO ENFORCE SPEED LIMITS THEY
MUST HAVE THE SPEED LIMITS
WITHIN THE EIGHTY FIFTH
PERCENTILE OF HOW FAST DRIVERS
ARE GOING. NOW IN THE AGE OF
BOTH ONLINE- TELEPHONE APPS
LIKE WAZE AND GOOGLE MAPS YOU
HAVE A LOT OF PEOPLE DRIVING
THROUGH. NEIGHBORHOODS THAT
THEY'RE UNFAMILIAR WITH. TRYING
TO GET TO AND WORK OFTEN SEE.
THROUGH THE NEIGHBORHOOD. WE
ALSO HAVE A SITUATION WHERE
CARS BECAUSE OF THE DESIGN
IMPROVEMENTS OVER THE YEARS.
MAKE IT EASIER FOR PEOPLE TO
SPEAK WITHOUT FEELING LIKE
THEY'RE GOING FAST YOU CAN GO
VERY VERY FAST IN TODAY'S
MODERN CARS AND HAVE ALMOST NO
ROAD NOISE NO SENSE OF MOTION
AND THIS ALSO ENCOURAGES PEOPLE
FRANKLY TO SPEED. SO THE EIGHTY
FIFTH PERCENTILE IT'S BEEN
SOMETHING THAT'S VERY
FRUSTRATING FOR ALL OF OUR
CITIES WHICH IS WHY WE HAVE A
HUGE. ROLL CALL OF CITIES WHO
ARE SUPPORTING THIS BILL AND A
TRAFFIC SAFETY GROUPS THAT ARE
SUPPORTING THIS BILL. BECAUSE
EVERY FEW MILES AN HOUR FASTER
THAN A CAR GOES ALMOST
EXPONENTIALLY INCREASES THE
CHANCE OF SERIOUS INJURY OR
DEATH FOR PEDESTRIAN WHO'S HIT
BY THAT CAR. QUITE SIMPLY SPEED
KILLS AND OUR CITIES NEED
BETTER TOOLS SO THIS BILL. ARE
WE OF MANY PEOPLE IN THE PAST
IN THIS LEGISLATURE INTRODUCED
BILLS TRYING TO DEAL WITH THE
EIGHTY FIFTH PERCENTILE IN BIG
REWRITE RARELY EVER SUCCEEDED.
WE DID THE SAME THING TWO YEARS
AGO AND TRIED TO DO A BILL
REFORMING THE EIGHTY FIFTH
PERCENTILE. THE FORMER CHAIR OF
THIS COMMITTEE- IN THE ASSEMBLY
SIDE- ASKED US INSTEAD OF
INTRODUCING THE BILL TO FORM A
TASK FORCE TO BRING ALL THE
STAKEHOLDERS TOGETHER FOR THE
FIRST TIME. TO DISCUSS THE
EIGHTY FIFTH PERCENTILE AND HOW
SPEED LIMITS RELATE TO TRAFFIC
SAFETY. SO FOR THE AND IT WAS A
REALLY WISE THING TO DO BECAUSE
FOR THE FIRST TIME WE HAD A
GROUP MADE UP OF FORMER
OPPONENTS OF CHANGING THE
POLICY. OF LAW ENFORCEMENT OF
ROAD SAFETY ADVOCATES. OF JUST
A WHOLE EVERY SINGLE TYPE OF
STAKEHOLDER WAS INVOLVED IN
THIS WORKING RIBBON THEY WORK
FOR AN ENTIRE YEAR LOOKING AT
ALL OF THE DATA FROM AROUND THE
COUNTRY ON SPEED LIMIT SETTING.
ON ROAD SAFETY. AND CAME UP
WITH A LIST OF RECOMMENDATIONS.
THAT ALSO ADDRESS PEOPLE'S
CONCERNS. AND THIS BILL IS THE
RESULT OF THAT VERY HARD WORK
FROM MANY STAKEHOLDERS FROM
ACROSS THE STATE FROM RURAL
AREAS TO URBAN AREAS. ONLY FROM
JOB VERY REPRESENTATIVE SAMPLE
OF STAKE HOLDERS INCLUDING
TRIPLE WAY. WHO WAS A
WONDERFUL- ADVOCATE TO WORK
WITH. THIS SO THIS BILL REALLY
DOES WORK TO GIVE CITIES THE
TOOLS IN THE RIGHT LOCATIONS
UNDER CERTAIN CIRCUMSTANCES. TO
NOT BE FORCED TO CONTINUALLY
RAISE SPEED LIMITS AND IN SOME
CIRCUMSTANCES TO BE ABLE TO
LOWER SPEED LIMITS BASED ON
THINGS LIKE ACCIDENT DATA. AND
VULNERABLE POPULATIONS IT'S A
MODEST REFORM BUT ONE THAT'S
VERY VERY MEANINGFUL. AND I
LOOK FORWARD TO HEARING A
DISCUSSION AND I WOULD URGE AND
I'VE- TODAY THANK YOU. THANK
YOU ASSEMBLYWOMAN. OKAY IN
SUPPORT YOU HAVE A- TWO PEOPLE
THAT ARE LEAD TESTIMONY OF
WITNESSES- YOU'VE GT TO
DARNELL GROUPS BE. HARDER NOW
KRISPY TRANSFORMING THE
COASTLINE MODERATOR CAN YOU
ENSURE THAT MR CHRISTIE IS ON
THE LINE. GOOD MORNING- NAME
ETERNAL GREAT BE EXPECTED
DIRECTOR TRANSFORM. CAN ACCOUNT
FOR NEARLY A THIRD OF ALL
PRACTICALITY. EIGHTY FORTY
THREE OF THE COMMENTS AND RULE
THAT WILL ALLOW TRAFFIC
ENGINEER COULD DRESS HI INJURY
AND CRASH COURT OR BY LOWERING
THE SPEED LIMIT. IT ALSO KEEP
ANYTHING FROM BEING REQUIRED TO
INCREASE THE LIMIT IN HIGH
SPEED AND HIGH END RECORD OR- A
TARGETED APPROACH AGAINST CITY
THE FLEXIBILITY THEY NEED TO
ADDRESS THEIR MOST DANGEROUS
QUARTERS. COUNTRY DISCONNECTING
THIS BE LIMITED JUDGMENTS ARE
NOT ARBITRARY THEIR RESPONSE TO
THE HIGH NUMBER. OF TRAFFIC
FATALITIES AND INJURIES. WHERE
YOU CAN BE LIMITED BY JUST BY
HEALTHY HOUR. REDO INJURY
BETWEEN EIGHT AND FIFTEEN. WELL
TRY TO CALL ME IS IMPORTANT
PART OF A COMPREHENSIVE
APPROACH TO KEEPING OUR STREETS
SAFE. THAT TAKES TIME AND MONEY
CURRENT LAW COURSES THAT YOU
CAN CHOOSE BETWEEN STREET FEST
YOU FAST AND A STREET THAT IS
UNENFORCEABLE. THIS IS WHY WE
KNOW THAT THIS IS A BOTH. A
MEASURE OF COURAGE AND FAITH.
BECAUSE EVEN THOUGH THE
ECONOMIC TRAVEL WE'RE DOWN
THIRTEEN POINT 2% NATIONWIDE.
WITHOUT TRAFFIC SO IT GO UP
THERE AND THE LARGEST INCREASES
WERE IN THE BLACK COMMUNITY.
WHERE THERE WERE 23% COMPARED
TO SEVEN POINT 2% OVERALL.
UNDER TWENTY NINETEEN GAINERS
BY THE DINING COURT SMART WITH
AMERICA FOUND THAT BLACK PEOPLE
ARE ALMOST 50% MORE LIKELY THAN
WHITE PEOPLE TO BE STRUCK AND
KILLED BY DRIVER WHILE WALKING
AND DISPARITY FOR INDIGENOUS
PEOPLE LOOK UP TO THREE TIMES
THAT HIGH. WHAT WE CAN STUDY
FOUND THIRTY FIVE PERCENT. OF
THE NATION'S MOST DANGEROUS
ROADWAYS PEDESTRIAN BORDER LOW
INCOME NEIGHBORHOODS. WHEN UCLA
STUDY SHOWED THAT BLACK PEOPLE
FACE DISPROPORTIONATE SAFETY
OUTCOMES AND ALL TRANSPORTATION
MODES PROFESSIONAL WALKING.
BLACKENED COLLISION VICTIMS ARE
MOST LIKELY TO HAVE BEEN KILLED
AND LEAST LIKELY TO SURVIVE
WITH NO INJURIES. CONVICTIONS
THE OTHER RACIAL GROUPS IT
REQUIRES SUPPORT THIS
COMMONSENSE PUBLIC SAFETY
MEASURE OPPOSED TO ENHANCE THE
LOCAL COMMUNITY. AND WE BRING
SAFETY TO ALL OF US THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MR CRISPY OUR NEXT WE
HAVE SELENA REYNOLDS FROM THE
LA DEPARTMENT OF TRANSPORTATION
SHE ALSO WAS ON THE CO HOST
LINE MS REYNOLDS. GOOD MORNING
CHAIRMAN GONZALEZ MEMBERS THE
LEADE REYNOLDS GENERAL MANAGER
OF THE LOS ANGELES DEPARTMENT
OF TRANSPORTATION SPEAKING IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF EIGHTY FORTY
THREE. DRIVERS KILLED NEARLY
FOUR THOUSAND CALIFORNIANS
CRASHES EVERY YEAR THREE TIMES
THAT AMOUNT OR SEVERELY INJURED
AND THE GOOD DISPROPORTIONATELY
AFFECT THE MOST VULNERABLE
AMONG. CHILDREN OLDER ADULTS
AND PEOPLE WALKING IN LOW
INCOME COMMUNITIES OF COLOR FOR
EXAMPLE IN LOS ANGELES DURING
THE PANDEMIC TRAFFIC GOING TO
GREECE AND SEVERE CRASHES WENT
DOWN EXCEPT IN THE
PREDOMINANTLY BLACK AND BROWN
COMMUNITY OF SOUTH LA. WHAT WAS
NOT TRAFFIC VIOLENCE GROW BY
TWENTY THREE PERCENT. KILLED
AND ROBBED OF THE QUALITY OF
LIFE. B. DETERMINES THE
SEVERITY OF THE CRASH TO FIVE
MILES AN HOUR CAN MEAN THE
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN LIFE AND
DEATH. THE CALIFORNIA WE DON'T
LET PEOPLE TEXT AND DRIVE
BECAUSE THE TRACTOR DRIVING
SKILLS. WE DON'T ALLOW.
DRINKING AND DRIVING BECAUSE
DRUNK DRIVING. WE SAY WE DON'T
LET THE TO BE. PUT UNDER
CURRENT LAW IF ENOUGH DRIVERS.
EXCEEDS LIMITS WE INCREASE
THEM. IT DOES NOT MAKE SENSE
SPEED LIMITS MUST BE SET TO
BRING DRIVER BEHAVIOR IN LINE
WITH THE PEOPLE. ROADWAY
CONDITIONS AND THE LAW. CURRENT
LAN IS FORCED ME TO RAISE THE
LIMIT ON NEARLY TWO HUNDRED
MILES OF STREETS OVER THE LAST
FIVE YEARS. JUST LAST WEEK I
HAD TO RAISE THE SPEED LIMIT
WHERE A MOTHER OF TWO WITH
KILLED BY SPEEDING DRIVER.
AFTER THE STREET BECAME
UNENFORCEABLE AND DRIVERS
CONTINUED SPEEDING RECKLESSLY
UNITY. THE STATUS QUO IS NOT
STAGNANT IT GIVES LICENSE TO
LIFE THREATENING BEHAVIOR. THE
CITY OF LOS ANGELES AIMS TO
SORT OF BE THE SAVE LIVES
MURDERED HEARING SOLUTIONS.
IT'LL TAKE TIME AND MONEY TO
BUILD. AS WE WORK TO IMPROVE
OUR. SEVENTY FIVE HUNDRED MILE
STREETS AND ALLEYS. SPEED
LIMITS WILL CONTAIN TO RISE.
AND MORE PEOPLE WILL. IF WE
DON'T ACT NOW. AT FORTY THREE
WITH AN END TO SENSELESS SPEED
LIMIT INCREASES IT PROTECTS OUR
MOST VULNERABLE. GIVE CITIES A
BETTER WAY TO SET SAFETY LIMITS
ARGUABLY STREETS AROUND SCHOOLS
AND SENIOR CNTERS. AND
COMMERCIAL AREAS WHERE MORE
PEOPLE WALKING CONGREGATE. AB
FORTY THREE WILL SAVE LIVES AND
I URGE YOU YES. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTRIALS SO WE'VE
CONCLUDED THE LEAD WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT A MODERATOR TO HAVE
ANYONE ELSE ON THE LINE IN
SUPPORT. OF AB. FORTY THREE. I
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF AB FORTY
THREE YOU MAY PRESS ONE. AND
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND WE
DO CURRENTLY HAVE A- FIFTEEN IN
THE COMMENT QUEUE AND THAT
NUMBER IS RISING OKAY NINE
FORTY FIVE THANK YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS BOY
WERE TOP ON BEHALF OF THE CITY
OF SAN DIEGO AND SUPPORT. THANK
YOU NEXT COMMENT PLEASE NINE
FORTY NINE. ONE FORTY NINE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS NIKITA KARATE WITH THE
NATURAL RESOURCES DEFENSE
COUNCIL CALLING IN TO PORT
EIGHTY FORTY. THANK YOU. NINE
SEVENTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
WHEN I THINK ABOUT CHRISTIANITY
ON BEHALF OF THE CITY OF SAN
JOSE AND OAKLAND CALIFORNIA
FIFTY ASIAN GOVERNMENTS AND
TRUMP SUPPORT AT EIGHTY FORTY
THREE THANK YOU. NINE SEVENTY
TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING ROSS
BARKLEY IMPACT THE CITY OF
SACRAMENTO OPEN SUPPORT. NINE
FIFTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
CHARACTER BEHALF OF THE CITY OF
GLENDALE AND SUPPORT. NINE
SEVENTY FOUR YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
JUST HIRED THE SILICON VALLEY
LEADERSHIP GROUP IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU. NINE SEVENTY THREE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING MEDICARE
MEMBERS AGAIN CAN ACTUALLY ON
BEHALF OF THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY METROPOLITAN
TRANSPORTATION AUTHORITY THANK
YOU FOR. NINE NINETEEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS JOSH
SHOP FOR THE CITY AND COUNTY OF
SAN FRANCISCO AND SAN FRANCISCO
MAYOR LONDON BREED IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU. NINE SIXTY
NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING SURE
MEMBERS OF BLACKBURN CALLING ON
BEHALF OF THE STANDING
ASSOCIATION OF GOVERNMENT
BANNED I CAN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
ONE THIRTY ONE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING SURE MEMBERS CHRISLEY
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
STATE ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES
AND SUPPORT. NINE FIFTY THREE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THE MORNING SURE MEMBERS
HOTEL BROUGHT ON BEHALF OF
STUDENTS OAKLAND BERKELEY AND
FREMONT TRANSPORT. NINE
THIRTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MICHAEL SNYDER
OF LA BASED READING FOR ALL
INSTRUCT THE PORT OF AB FORTY
THREE. YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. WE. I'M SORRY COULD
UNDERMINE SEVENTY EIGHT MAY
HAVE TO GO AHEAD AND BE. FINE
YEAH BECAUSE WE'RE BORN ARMOR
WITH KATE GO CALLING IN
STOCKPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NINE SEVENTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING LOSING ONE FOR MOUNTAIN
DEW COALITION FOR SUSTAINABLE
PLANNING OR NBC S. PEACEKEEPING
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
NINE FIFTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
TERROR MEMBERS ARE BACK ALONG
WITH THE METROPOLITAN
TRANSPORTATION COMMISSION AND
THE ASSOCIATION OF BAY AREA
GOVERNMENTS AND STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU. NINE FIFTY SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. RECALLING FROM SEVEN TO
GO ON A NUMBER OF WALKING UP
AND GO I'M A BIT OF- A SERIOUS
INJURY WHICH I. NEED TO DO IS
JUST. SOMETHING BETTER WE'RE
JUST TALKING NAME AN
ORGANIZATION AT THIS TIME. AND
WHETHER YOU SUPPORT THE BILL OR
NOT. LET'S GO SUPPORT. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH WE APPRECIATE
THAT THANK YOU NEXT COMMENT
PLEASE. NINE FIFTY FOUR YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING JONATHAN MAPS
CALIFORNIA SENIOR POLICY
MANAGER FOR THE SAME PRICE
PARTNERSHIP SPEAKING IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THE B. TWENTY THREE.
NINE TWENTY FOUR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. COLMAR
YOU'RE ON BEHALF THE STREETS
ARE FOR EVERYONE CONCERNED.
TWENTY THREE. NINE TWENTY YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
DR HAGER SMALL BUSINESS OWNER
AND FOUNDER OF THE COMMUNICATE
JUSTICE INITIATIVES IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THE V. FORTY THREE.
NINE THIRTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINE
THIRTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THIS IS
BRIAN HOBSON FROM WALK-
REPRESENTING WALKS IN FRANCISCO
IN STRONG SUPPORT. NINE SEVENTY
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. SO HOW DO YOU LIVE
CALIFORNIA WALKS IN STRONG
SUPPORT. ONE TWENTY EIGHT YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THIS IS ALLEY GALLERY- FROM THE
PANELISTS FOR STATE STREET CORP
COMPLETES GO CALLING IN MY
STRONG SUPPORT AT FORTY THREE.
NINE TWENTY NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING THIS IS MARK WATCH
REPRESENTING THE SAN FRANCISCO
COUNTY TRANSPORTATION AUTHORITY
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS
MEASURE THANK YOU. MY TWENTY
SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO HI MATTHEW THOMAS
FROM ACTIVE SINGER GRILL BALLY
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THE P.
FORTY THREE. NINE EIGHTY YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS JULIE
NECK OPEN FINAL SURVIVOR OF THE
TRAFFIC CRASH AND I STRONGLY
SUPPORT AT FORTY THREE. NINE
EIGHTY ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
HALF OF SIERRA CLUB CALIFORNIA
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU. NINE
FOURTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
JEANETTE LEBLANC FROM SAN JOSE
AND BAY AREA FAMILY TREAT MY
EIGHTEEN YEAR OLD SOME OF THE
PEDESTRIAN KILLED BY SPEEDING
DRIVER I STRONGLY SUPPORT AT
FORTY THREE. WE HAVE NO FURTHER
COMMENT THANK YOU THANK YOU
MODERATOR WE APPRECIATE THE
TESTIMONY- EVERYONE HAS CALLED
IN- FOUR TO EIGHTY FORTY THREE.
C. NINE- WE'LL GO TO ROOM ONE
TWELVE C. NINE. SO NOW WE'LL
TAKE IT TO THE OPPOSITION I
UNDERSTAND THAT THERE'S ONE
LEAD WITNESS IN OPPOSITION J.
BIEBER SAFE STREETS LOS
ANGELES- WHO IS ON THE COAST
LINE MODERATOR CAN YOU ENSURE
MR BEEPERS ON THE LINE. WHAT
VEHICLE. I'M ON THE LINE. GREEK
GO RIGHT AHEAD THANK YOU MISTER
BEAVER. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE JV FOR
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR STEVE FOR ST
LA REPRESENTING THE INTERESTS
OF. CALIFORNIA'S TWENTY SEVEN
MILLION LICENSED DRIVERS I AM
ALSO SERVED AS A MEMBER OF THE
ZERO FATALITIES TASK FORCE.
MAYBE FORTY THREE WHILE WELL
INTENDED SUFFERS FROM A
FUNDAMENTAL ERROR OF COMPLETING
LOWER SPEED LIMITS WITH LOWER
SPEED. THE CASE OF EXPERIENCE
IN RESEARCH INCLUDING STUDIES
FROM THE FEDERAL HIGHWAY
ADMINISTRATION SHOW. THAT
LOWERING OR RAISING SPEED
LIMITS HAS LITTLE TO NO EFFECT
ON DRIVERS SPEEDS. EVEN THE
REPORT BY THE EUROPEAN
TALLAHASSEE FORCE CONCEDES THAT
THE MOTION EXPECTED ABOUT A ONE
TO TWO MILE PER HOUR CHANGING
SPEEDS. AND EVEN THAT
OVERSTATES THE EFFECT DARBUS
BEACH MATCH THE WAY THE
GOVERNMENT BUILT THE ROADWAY
NOT THE NUMBER ON THE SIGN.
SPEED LIMIT SET MORE THAN FIVE
MILES AN HOUR DIFFERENCE FROM
THIS DESIGN SPEED AS MEASURED
BY SPEED SURVEY CAN BE
DANGEROUS CAUSING INCREASE
SPEED VARIATION WHICH LEADS TO
INCREASED COLLISIONS. FURTHER
FORCING DRIVERS TO HYPER FOCUS
ON MAINTAINING AN UNCOMFORTABLE
SPEED NOT ALIGNED WITH THE
ROADWAY GEOMETRY BECAUSE
INCREASED DRIVER'S DISTRACTION
AND MORE DANGER FOR PEDESTRIANS
AND BICYCLISTS. BLOWING AS
BEING WITH IS NOT LOWER SPEED
SIMPLY LOWERED THE BAR TO
ENFORCEMENT MAKING VIOLATORS
OUT OF THE VAST MAJORITY OF
DRIVERS. SPEED LIMITS ARE
SUPPOSED TO INDICATE WHO THE
OUT LIARS ARE BUT WHEN THE
SPEED LIMIT BY DEFINITION MAKES
FIFTY SIXTY OR EVEN 80% OF
DRIVERS OF THE VIOLATORS.
THAT'S THE ONLY BECOMES
MEANINGLESS ENDANGERED
ENGENDERING DISRESPECT FROM THE
MOTORING PUBLIC AND MAKING THE
JOB OF THE POLICE MUCH MORE
DIFFICULT. THANK YOU FOR
CALLING THE POLICE TO ENFORCE
UNREALISTICALLY LOW SPEED
LIMITS OF ROADS THE TRUST
BETWEEN GOVERNMENT OFFICIALS
AND THE PUBLIC AT A TIME WHEN
THE TRUST WHEN I TRUST HIS
INSTRUCTIONS AND OUR SOCIETY
CAN LITTLE AFFORD TO FURTHER
DAMAGE TO. THIS FRAGILE
RELATIONSHIP. IN CONCLUSION
THAT WE CURRENTLY REMAIN IN
OPPOSITION WE WOULD LIKE TO
THANK THE AUTHOR FOR AGREEING
TO ACCEPT THE COMMITTEE'S
PROPOSED AMENDMENTS INTENDED TO
RESTRICT THE ABILITY TO REDUCE
SPEED LIMITS AND TO NO MORE
THAN TEN MILES PER HOUR BELOW
THE MEASURED OPERATING SPEED.
HOWEVER AN AMBIGUITY EXISTS TO
SECTION SEVEN OF THE BILL WHICH
MAY ALLOW GREATER VARIATION IN
THE FORMAT. MILE PER HOUR
REDUCTION UNFORTUNATELY AS OF
THE TIME THIS HEARING WE DO NOT
YET HAVE A COMMITMENT THE
AUTHOR'S OFFICE THAT THE TEXT
OPINION MATTERS WILL CLARIFY
THIS AMBIGUITY WE THEREFORE TO
MINIMUM ARE ASKING FOR THIS
COMMITMENT. PRIOR TO PASSING
THIS BILL OUT OF COMMITTEE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MR. WE
APPRECIATE YOUR TIME. AS WELL-
SO ANY. OTHER WITNESSES AND AN
OPPOSITION TO AB. THREE ON THE
LINE MODERATOR PLEASE. THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION OF EIGHTY FORTY
THREE YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. IN ONE
MOMENT WELL WE GOT TO THE LINE
NUMBERS. ONE SIXTY FOR YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS THE LONGER ON
BEHALF OF THE ACLU HELLO
ACTIONS BY THAT DATE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT COMMENT THE ONE.
AT NINE FIFTY ONE POINT NINE IS
OPEN TO. THANK YOU GOOD MORNING
AMANDA BOTHERING WITH TRIPLE A
LEGITIMATE A POSITION OF
OPPOSING WITH THE MAN I WANT TO
THANK THE AUTHOR HER STAFF AND
HER STAFF FOR WORKING WITH US
ON THE CELL. WITH THE
AMENDMENTS TAKEN IN COMMITTEE
AMANDA ARE. TRIPLE A WILL MOVE
TO A POSITION OF NEUTRAL ON
EIGHTY FORTY THREE THANK YOU.
THERE ARE NO FURTHER COMMENTS
THANK YOU OKAY THANK YOU
MODERATOR- WE'VE CONCLUDED THE
OPPOSITION- ON THE CONFERENCE
LINE IS THERE ANYONE IN THE
GALLERY IN OPPOSITION. C. NINE
IN ROOM ONE TWELVE. EIGHTY NINE
OKAY WE'LL TAKE THIS BACK TO
MEMBERS FOR DISCUSSION SENATOR
RUBIO. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR- I
REALLY DO THINK THIS IS A
REALLY GOOD FELL ON NOT ONLY
WILL I SUPPORT IT BUT I ALSO
WANT TO BE A CO AUTHOR- YOU
KNOW AND I DO APPRECIATE THE
WORK THAT WAS DONE BY THE ZERO
FATALITY TASK FORCE- I BELIEVE
THIS BILL COMPLEMENTS. ANOTHER
BILL THAT I THAT I HAVE WHICH
IS SB SEVEN THIRTY FIVE WHICH
ATTEMPTS TO REDUCE SPEEDS
AROUND. SCHOOL ZONES AS A
SCHOOL TEACHER FOR SEVENTEEN
YEARS AND VICE PRINCIPAL. YOU
KNOW I KEEP SHARING HOW I SAW
SO MANY NEAR MISSES AND ONE
CHILD IN PARTICULAR GET STRUCK
AND IT'S ALWAYS UNFORTUNATE SO.
WE DO NEED TO TRY AND MAKE
STREETS SAFER FOR KIDS AND OUR
COMMUNITY- I DO APPRECIATE THAT
CITIES HAVE DISCRETION BASED
ON. AND I BELIEVE THE AUTHOR
SAID IT YOU KNOW THE RIGHT
LOCATION AND UNDER CERTAIN
CIRCUMSTANCES AND I DO BELIEVE
THAT'S IMPORTANT FOR EACH CITY
TO. TO REALLY ASSESS THEIR OWN
COMMUNITY AND SEE WHERE THEY
NEED S. I ALSO THINK THAT THAT
THIS IS A MODEST APPROACH- YOU
KNOW ANYTHING THAT WE CAN DO
FOR OUR FAMILIES TO MAKE SURE
THAT THEY'RE SAFE I THINK IT'S
ALWAYS A GOOD THING. I AM WE
ALSO HAVE TO ACKNOWLEDGE WE
LIVE SO FAR IN TERMS OF LOCAL
COMMUNITIES AND STATES TRYING
TO GET. PEOPLE OFF THE ROAD AND
DRIVE I MEAN I'M SORRY RIDING
BIKES AND WE EVEN. DESIGNED
ROADS NOW MORE FRIENDLY TO TWO
BIKES WHICH WE DIDN'T HAVE IN
THE PAST AND WE ALSO HAVE TO.
TAKE THAT INTO CONSIDERATION
THAT THERE IS A LOT MORE PEOPLE
BIKING AND WALKING AND THAT WAS
OUR GOAL RIGHT TO GET PEOPLE
OFF CAR SO I THINK THIS IS
REALLY. JUST A GOOD APPROACH TO
TRYING AND BE SAFE SO WITH THAT
I WANT TO MOVE THE BILL THANK
YOU THANK. YOU SENATOR RUBIO
SENATOR AKOWSKI. I THINK MATT.
MADAM I HAVE A QUESTION FOR THE
AUTHOR. OF ON SOME OF THE
POINTS THAT WERE RAISED BY THE-
OPPOSITION IN PARTICULAR I'M
READING- SECTION SEVEN. OF THE
BILL ON PAGE NINE. AND I THINK
WHAT THEY'RE- LOOKING AT IS IT
STARTS AT. FIVE POINT NINETEEN.
WHERE IT TAKES THE SPEED LIMIT
NEEDS TO BE ROUNDED UP TO THE
HIGHEST THE NEAREST FIVE MILES
PER HOUR INCREMENTS BUT THE
EIGHTY FIVE. EIGHTY FIFTH
PERCENTILE SPEED. THE
DEPARTMENT TRANSPORTATION A
LOCAL AUTHORITY MAY DECIDE
INSTEAD TO. ROUND DOWN THE
SPEED LIMIT. TO THE LOWER FIVE
MILES. PER HOUR INCREMENTS SO.
I'M WONDERING. IF THIS POSTED
SPEED LIMIT IS- THIRTY. N. N.
THIS SPEED THEY DO THE TESTS
AND EIGHTY FIFTEEN ECHOES. I
UNDERSTAND. THIRTY TWO POINT
NINE IS BELOW OR THIRTY TWO
POINT FOUR IS BELOW THIRTY TWO
AND A HALF SO THAT WOULD ROUND
DOWN BUT IF IT GOES TO THIRTY
FOUR OR THIRTY FIVE. WITH
THIRTY FOUR POINT NINE NINE
NINE. THE SAD. GIVE CALTRANS
ANY TORY THIS STAY AT THE
THIRTY RATHER THAN GOING TO
THE- THIRTY FIVE. THAT QUESTION
THE SENSE TO. I DIDN'T KNOW
THAT THEY WERE B. MATH AS PART
OF THIS QUIZ BUT I WILL DO MY
BEST SO ARE YOU'RE ASKING UNDER
OUR BILL OR UNDER THE CAR UNDER
CURRENT LAW YOU'RE SO YOU'RE
SAYING UNDER OUR BILL AND YOUR
BILL WOULD GIVE THEM THE OPTION
NOW OF STAYING AT THAT ORIGINAL
SPEED LIMIT. OKAY SO IT'S MY
UNDERSTAND IS LONG AS IT
DOESN'T GO OVER THIRTY FIVE IT
DOESN'T INCLUDE A FULL FIVE
MILES RIGHT AND ACTUALLY AN
ORIGINAL INCARNATION OF THE
BILL DID GIVE THEM MORE
FLEXIBILITY TO LOWER IT EVEN
MORE. BUT BUT BASED ON CONCERNS
WE MADE THAT. A LOT MORE YOU
KNOW WE COMPROMISE AND MADE IT
TO WHERE IT WASN'T AS LARGE OF
A SWING. IN THE STAFF REPORT TO
SAY GOOD JOB ABOUT TALKING THE
CHALLENGE THAT WE HAVE ON
LOWERING SPEED LIMITS- WE'RE AS
THE OPPOSITION IN THE CRATE
INDICATED THAT THERE'S NOW YOU
COULD HAVE 6070% OF THE PEOPLE
THAT MAYBE OUT LIARS. BECAUSE
OF THE WAY THAT THE STREETS
DESIGNED- AND THAT WOULD CREATE
THE STAFF REPORTS PARTS OUT
MORE- PAST DISPARITY BETWEEN
HOW FAST PEOPLE ARE DRIVING
BECAUSE SOMEBODY'S GOING TWENTY
MILES AN HOUR IN SOMEBODY'S
GOING FORTY IN THE STREETS
DESIGNED TO GO FORTY FIVE- CAN
YOU ADRESS THAT CONCERN THAT
THE OPPOSITION HAS. RAISED THAT
WE MAY ACTUALLY INCREASE
DISPARITY BECAUSE THE POSTED
SIGN MAY BE- SIX IT IS
SIGNIFICANTLY BELOW WHAT THE
STREET DESIGN WAS AND WHAT THE
DATA POINTS OUT OF HOW THE
AVERAGE DRIVER DRIVES ALONG THE
STREET SO I HAVE LOOKED AT SOME
OF THE DATA THAT SUGGESTED THAT
I ACTUALLY DON'T FIND IT VERY
COMPELLING. THE IDEA THAT IF
YOU HAVE A SPEED LIMIT THAT'S
TWENTY FIVE MILES AN HOU AND
PEOPLE FEEL COMFORTABLE GOING
THIRTEEN YOU'VE GOT SOME GOING
FORTY FIVE MEANS THAT YOU'RE
GOING TO SOMEHOW COME OVER HERE
AND SOMEONE ELSE. OR THEY'RE
GOING AT SUCH DIFFERENT SPEEDS
THAT CAUSES ACCIDENTS I
PERSONALLY DON'T THINK IS
REALLY BORN OUT IN THE DATA I-
AND I THINK IT CERTAINLY WOULD
BE IN A MUCH MORE EXTREME
SITUATION SOMEBODY GOING THIRTY
FIVE MILES AN HOUR FREEWAY WITH
THE- SPEED LIMIT IS SIXTY FIVE
MILES AN HOUR COULD INDEED POSE
A DANGER. BUT ON CITY SREETS
THAT ARE NORMALLY TWENTY FIVE
THIRTY THIRTY FIVE MILES AN
HOUR I JUST DON'T SEE THAT
DISCREPANCY YOU KNOW WE'RE
TALKING. A LOT OF AREAS THAT
ARE HEAVILY POPULATED WHERE
WOULD THIS PARTICULAR- SPEED
LIMIT CHANGE WOULD AFFECT YOU
KNOW THE BILL IS LIMITED TO
BUSINESS DISTRICT IT'S LIMITED
TO AREAS THAT ARE HIGH INJURY
ALREADY IT'S LIMITED TO AREAS
WHERE THERE'S A LOT OF
PEDESTRIANS OR CYCLISTS. YOU'RE
NOT GOING TO HAVE THESE HUGE
VARIATIONS IN SPEED SORT OF
PROGRAMMED INTO THOSE ROADS I
CAN CERTAINLY SEE THAT IF ALL
OF A SUDDEN OF A SECTION OF
HIGHWAY WITH A SPEED LIMIT
CHANGES. BUT I DON'T THINK THAT
THOSE CONDITIONS EXIST WHERE
THIS BILL. TAKES EFFECT. MA'AM
I THE BECAUSE- I THINK I
UNDERSTAND WHAT THE- WHAT THE-
ADVOCATES AND THE AUTHOR IS
GETTING AT IS THAT THIS IS A-
RATHER THAN CHANGING THE STREET
SCAPE. INDUSTRY ENGINEERING. I
KNOW I COME FROM FREMONT. IT
WAS DESIGNED. WITH THE IDEA
THAT THEY WOULD HAVE TO
FREEWAYS AND THERE ARE PLENTY
OF STREETS. WHERE YOU HAVE.
FOUR LIGHTS AND YOU HAVE A-
RIGHT HAND TURN LANE THAT YOU
DON'T EVEN HAVE TO SLOW DOWN
YOU CAN GO AT FORTY FIVE MILES
AN HOUR BECAUSE- THEY WERE
EXPECTING PEOPLE BE WHISTLING
OFF. ONE FREEWAY TO GET TO THE
OTHER SO. THAT'S WHAT THE BUILD
COMMUNITY IS IN THE STAFF
REPORT. SEEMS TO POINT OUT THAT
THE MOST IMPORTANT FACTOR. IN
DETERMINING C. US. SPEED IS THE
ST ENGINEERING AND WE HAVE A-
OUR PREVIOUS CHAIR. HAS
AUTHORED A BILL THAT IS GOT A
BOAT LOAD OF MONEY THAT'S GOING
INTO LOCAL. DISTRICTS RIGHT NOW
AND THERE'S A LOT OF. BIKE
LANES AND A LOT OF TRAFFIC
CALMING THAT'S GOING ON-
THAT'S- THAT'S CHANGING THAT
STREETSCAPE THAT'S GOING TO. TO
GET THE SAME RESULTS I THINK
THAT THE AUTHORS TRYING TO GET
TO. THE CHALLENGES THAT I'M
HAVING IS THAT. THOUGH WHICH
COMES FIRST THE APPLE OR THE-
CHICKEN OR THE EGG DO WE CHANGE
THE STREET SCAPE AND THEN
REDUCE THE SPEEDS. ARE REDUCED
TO SPEEDS. N. SITE PEOPLE AND-
CREATE HIS DISPARITY SO THAT'S
THAT'S- WHAT MY CONCERN IS IT'S
NOT. IT'S NOT TRYING TO REDUCE
THE THIRD OF THE DEATHS THAT
OCCUR BY TRAFFIC ACCIDENTS
RESULT OF SPEED. BECAUSE TWO
THIRDS. ARE NOT BY SPEED SO WE
GOT TO DEAL WITH THAT- WHAT HAS
GIVEN ME- WE SPOKE WITH MANY
AGENCIES. THE COMMITTEE MYSELF
DIRECTLY- SPEAKING WITH MANY
AGENCIES ONE IN PARTICULAR BAY
AREA TRANSIT LOS ANGELES
DEPARTMENT OF TRANSPORTATION.
ARE OF COURSE NEED THE SOLUTION
SO I THINK YOUR POINT WHAT
THEY'RE LOOKING TO DO NOW AFTER
THIS BILL IF IT SHOULD PASS A
MOVE THROUGH AND BE SIGNED BY
THE GOVERNOR. IS TO CREATE NEW
STREETSCAPE IN. NEW ENGINEERING
AND DESIGNS AND PLANS. IN THEIR
LOCAL. AND THAT'S WHAT THEY
COMMITTED TO A SPA FOR PLACES
LIKE SOUTH LOS ANGELES IT HAS
SEEN. AN INCREASE IN
FATALITIES- THAT DEFINITELY
NEEDS THAT THE SPEEDS LOWERED
WITH THE COMP AND THEN TO
COMPLEMENT THE- THE- THE CHANGE
IN ENGINEERING AND STREETSCAPE.
THOUGH MORE BOLD- YOU KNOW MORE
STREET BALTIMORE- EITHER YOU
KNOW INFRASTRUCTURE CHANGES
THAT WOULD HELP- EVEN FURTHER
REDUCED SPEEDS IN AREAS THAT.
MAYBE WERE INTENDED IT
HISTORICALLY TO BE YOU KNOW
FASTER SORT OF AREAS AROUND
THREE WAYS IN WHICH ONE OF THEM
ONE OF WHICH I LIVE. I THINK IT
REALLY OKAY I THINK WE ALL HAVE
THAT IN OUR DISTRICT RIGHT
THANK YOU FOR THAT
CLARIFICATION OF COURSE AND
THANK YOU FOR THE QUESTION AS
SENATOR BECKER. THANK YOU. I
THINK THE AUTHOR OF I WILL BE
SUPPORTING THIS BILL I HAD A
QUESTION AROUND. YOU IN GENERAL
WE TRY TO. IF POSSIBLE DECREASE
IN REACTION TO PEOPLE OF COLOR
WITH PUBLIC SAFETY AND I'M
JUST. HOW DO YOU THINK ABOUT
THIS BILL IN TERMS OF- THE TEND
TO BE HIGHER POLICE PRESENCE IN
TERMS IN LOW INCOME
NEIGHBORHOODS AND HOW THEY CAN
ACTUALLY INCREASE INTERACTION
AND- AND- MAYBE INCREASE FINDS
AN INCREASE- YOU KNOW ROUTE
RESULTING. SITUATIONS WITH
PEOPLE OF COLOR HOW DO YOU
THINK ABOUT THAT IN THE CONTEXT
OF THIS BILL. CHECK THE
QUESTION AND THAT'S CERTAINLY
THE CONCERN THAT THE ACLU I
THINK WAS WAS VOICING. SO RIGHT
NOW ON ANY GIVEN DAY WE ASSUME
THAT ABOUT 15% OF PEOPLE ARE
ACTUALLY SPEEDING- THEY MAY NOT
BE AGREE JUST A SPEEDING BUT
THEY'RE SPENDING ENOUGH TO GET
PULLED OVER BY LAW ENFORCEMENT.
AND YET 50% OF PEOPLE DON'T GET
PULLED OVER EVERY DAY- SO. IT
MEANS TO THE EXTENT THAT YOU
KNOW THIS WOULD INCREASE
TICKETING REALLY THEY'RE GIVING
TICKETS LEFT AND- POLICE
OFFICERS HAVE ENOUGH PEOPLE TO
TAKE IT- IT'S NOT GOING TO GIVE
THEM SORT OF MORE PEOPLE BUT IT
DOES. ALLOW FOR SIGNAL TO BE
SENT- SO. I THINK FIRST OF ALL
OUR PROBLEMS REALLY WITH THE
FEE STRUCTURE THAT WE HAVE ON
TRAFFIC TICKETS WHICH ARE VERY
PUNITIVE IN VERY HIGH. AND
DEFINITELY DISPROPORTIONATELY.
HURT PEOPLE WHO DON'T HAVE THE
ABILITY TO PAY THOSE TICKETS
AND THAT'S FOR ALL TRAFFIC
INFRACTIONS ACROSS THE BOARD.
AND THAT'S SOMETHING THAT WE
SHOULD LOOK AT SEPARATELY JUST
BECAUSE WE FEEL THAT. IN MANY
CASES THE PENALTIES NOT FITTING
THE CRIME DOESN'T MEAN THAT WE
JUST SAY WE'RE JUST NOT GONNA
TAKE IT ANYMORE I THINK WE
SHOULD REALLY SHOULD TAKE A
LOOK AT. WHAT WE'RE WHAT WE'RE
CHARGING AND HOW MANY FEES ARE
TACKED ON TO THESE TICKETS THAT
YOU KNOW. MAYBE ORIGINALLY WERE
FIFTY DOLLARS BUT THEN YOU
START PUTTING COURT FEES IN
THIS FEE AND THAT FEE. THE NEXT
THING YOU KNOW THEY'RE THREE
FOUR HUNDRED DOLLARS FIVE
HUNDRED DOLLARS NOT FOR A LOW
INCOME PERSON IS REALLY HARD.
THING TO OVERCOME SO I DO
BELIEVE THAT WE NEED TO LOOK AT
THAT BUT I THINK THAT'S A
SEPARATE ISSUE FROM THIS BILL.
AND THEN SECONDLY THERE WAS A
COMPANION BILL TO THIS ABOUT
AUTOMATED SPEED ENFORCEMENT.
THAT DID NOT MAKE IT THROUGH
THE ASSEMBLY BUT I THINK THAT'S
AN IMPORTANT PART. BECAUSE WHEN
YOU HAVE THE AUTOMATED
ENFORCEMENT PIECE YOU ARE ABLE
TO REDUCE THOSE IN PERSON
INTERACTIONS. AND THOSE TICKETS
ARE MUCH LOWER THAN ANY TICKET
THAT WILL BE GIVEN BY A LIVE
OFFICER. SO I DO THINK THAT
CITIES NEED TO BE MINDFUL OF
WHERE THEY'RE ENFORCING THEY
SHOULD CERTAINLY BE ENFORCING
IN AREAS WHERE THEY'RE TRYING
TO BRING THE SPEED LIMITS DOWN.
THEY ALSO HAVE TOOLS AT THEIR
DISPOSAL IN MY CITY OF GLENDALE
IT'S VERY COMMON THAT THEY WILL
GIVE WARNINGS TO PEOPLE ON THE
FIRST OFFENSE WHEN IT COMES TO
SPEEDING. BECAUSE THEY'RE
REALLY TRYING TO DO AN
EDUCATION OUTREACH AND THIS IS
A POLICY. THAT THEY DID
DELIBERATELY TALKED ABOUT WITH
THE CITY COUNCIL THAT PEOPLE
WHO ARE. NOT A- SPEED. BUT
GOING. YOU KNOW. SEVEN TEN
MILES AN HOUR OVER THE SPEED
LIMIT IF THEY DON'T HAVE A
PREVIOUS. INFRACTION IN A MANY
TIMES IN GLENDALE THEY WILL GET
A WARNING. SO THERE ARE
POLICIES THAT CAN BE DONE BY
CITIES WHO WANT TO ADDRESS.
THIS CONCERN. BUT JUST BECAUSE
WE ARE CHANGING THE THRESHOLD
OF WHAT THE SPEED LIMIT IS.
DOESN'T MEAN THAT YOU'RE
NECESSARILY GOING TO HAVE MORE
OFFICERS ON THE STREET OR MORE
ENFORCEMENT I THINK THAT'S
SOMETHING TO REALLY BE MINDFUL
OF- THERE DOES. THIS DOES THIS
BILL ISN'T THERE'S AN IN NO WAY
WILL ENCOURAGE CITIES TO GO OUT
AND HIRE MORE MOTORCYCLE
OFFICERS- SEND THEM TO
DIFFERENT AREAS IT'S REALLY
GOING TO BE THE SAME
ENFORCEMENT IN THE SAME AREAS.
BUT NOW THEY'LL HAVE THE TOOLS
HOPEFULLY. TO SEND SIGNALS TO
PEOPLE THAT THEY SHOULD BE
DRIVING AT A LOWER RATE OF
SPEED IN AN AREA. WHAT THANK
YOU FOR THAT AND I MIGHT HOPE
FOLKS WILL TAKE ADVANTAGE OF
THE WARNINGS THAT YOU MENTION-
AND I DO HAVE A COURT FEE
WAIVER BILL THAT IS MAKING ITS
WAY THROUGH OUR PROCESS HERE SO
I APPRECIATE THAT- AS WELL ON-
ON FEES- IN THE END- THAT YOU
APPRECIATE YOU THINKING ABOUT
THIS AND I DO BELIEVE WE SHOULD
TRY TO A LOOK AT THAT WE TALK
ABOUT AUTOMATED SPEED- THEN
THAT'S FINE WE LOOK AT THAT IF
IT DOES HAVE LOWER TICKETS
BECAUSE WE KNOW THE RED LIGHT
CAMERAS HAVE MASSIVE FINES.
WHICH AGAIN ARE DEEPLY DEEPLY
INEQUITABLE SO I APPRECIATE
YOU- I DO THINK WE SHOULD LOOK
AT THAT ALL IN THE FUTURE SO
THANK YOU. THANK YOU IN A FIGHT
MAY I CENTER BECKER THIS
COMMITTEE I WOULD SAY DOES A
PRETTY GOOD JOB OF ENSURING
THAT WERE NOT BEING AS PUNITIVE
BUT THAT WERE BEING- MORE
EQUITABLE IN THE WAY THAT
WE'RE- IMPLEMENTING FEE
STRUCTURES- YOU'LL SEE THAT AND
MANY OF THE COMMITTEE ANALYSIS
AND SO THE COMMITTEE
CONSULTANTS HAVE DONE A GREAT
JOB. OF THAT- I DON'T SEE ANY
OTHER MIKES UP AT ALL JUST.
CLOSE BY SAYING- YOU STARTED AT
A VERY COLLABORATIVE SPACE AND
THIS IS WHAT I APPRECIATE ABOUT
THIS BILL THAT YOU HAD. STARTED
WITH THE VISION ZERO TASK
FORCE. COLLABORATIVE IN MANY
SPACES EQUITY PARTNERS LAW
ENFORCEMENT ALL THE PLAYERS
WERE AT THE TABLE. AND WE HEARD
FROM MANY OF THEM. AND AGAIN
THIS IS HOPEFULLY WILL
ENCOURAGE PLANS FOR THE LOCALS
TO BE ABLE TO CHANGE THEIR
STREETSCAPES IF THEY IF THEY
NEED TO. WHICH IS THE MOST
IMPORTANT THING IS TO
INTERCHANGE THE ENGINEERING IF
NEED BE. TO ENSURE THAT
REDUCING TRAFFIC FATALITIES. SO
THANK YOU FOR THE BILL I SAID
CERTAINLY SUPPORTED AND IF
YOU'D LIKE TO CLOSE A FAMILY
MEMBER WOULD LOVE TO HAVE THAT.
I WOULD JUST SAY DO IT JUST TO
KEEP IN MIND THAT THE SPEED
LIMITS OUR- SERVER PURPOSE
THEY'RE THERE FOR A REASON-
AND- IT IS IMPORTANT THAT WE
REVIEW WHAT THEIR FUNCTION IS
AND HOW THEY WORK. THE END
ROADS WERE DESIGNED AT A TIME
WHEN CARS WENT SLOWER. THEY
FELT LIKE THEY WERE GOING
FASTER THEY WERE FOR THE
OCCUPANT. AND IT'S ABSOLUTELY
IMPORTANT AS THE OPPOSITION
RAISE THAT CITIES FOCUS ON ST
ENGINEERING THAT IS KEY. BUT
THERE'S NOTHING IN THE LAW NOW
THAT REWARDS THAT INVESTMENT
WOULD BE ABILITY TO CAPTURE
LOWER SPEED LIMITS. ALONG WITH
THAT AND ALL OF THESE
DIFFERENT. MODALITIES NEED TO
BE SEEN IN CONCERT TOGETHER.
THE ENFORCEMENT THE EDUCATION.
BUT ALSO. THE SPEED LIMITS THEY
ALL HAVE A ROLE TO PLAY AND
CITIES FOR YEARS HAVE BEEN
STYMIED BY THIS. THIS BEING
FORCED TO RAISE SPEED LIMITS TO
ACCOMMODATE SPEEDING DRIVERS
AND FASTER CARS. CARS AND FUEL
MAKE THE ROOM FEEL SAFER THAN
IT ACTUALLY IS. AND THE RESULT
HAS BEEN ANINCREASE IN DEATHS
PEDESTRIAN AND BICYCLIST DEATHS
CONSISTENTLY. OVER THE PAST
SEVERAL YEARS. IF WE HAVE FOUR
THOUSAND PEOPLE IN CALIFORNIA
DYING EVERY YEAR IN PLANE
CRASHES WOULD PROBABLY GROUND
THE FLEET IN A MINUTE. BUT
SOMEHOW WE. ACCEPT THAT WHEN IT
COMES TO PEDESTRIAN AND BICYCLE
FATALITIES- AND WITH THAT I DID
IS ONE PIECE OF THAT PUZZLE AND
I URGE MY VOTE. THANK YOU THANK
YOU SOMETHING MEMBER DO YOU
HAVE A MOTION ON A. B. FORTY
THREE. MOTION BY SENATOR RUBIO
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU SENATOR-
MISTER CHIEF CONSULTANT CAN YOU
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
AND REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE
ON APPROPRIATIONS. CENTER
CONSULTS FIVE DOLLARS I BATES.
BATES I HELEN WHAT'S A LETTER.
BECKER HI THERE I PUT EIGHTY
CORTESE I. DALI DOLLY NO DOT.
WHERE MELINDA'S. MAN NEWMAN
HUMANITE RUBIO RUBIO HI SKINNER.
NUMBER BY CAL SKI. WELL. SIX
ONE OKAY SIX ONE WILL LEAVE THE
BILL ON CALL THANK YOU AND WE
HAVE OUR NEXT BILL ALSO BY
ASSEMBLYWOMAN FRIEDMAN THAT'S
VIOLATED NUMBER. TEN EIGHTY
ELEVEN FORTY SEVEN. THANK YOU-
IT INSTEAD MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS I WANT TO THANK YOU AND
YOUR STAFF FOR YOUR HELP WITH
THIS BILL. AB ELEVEN FORTY
SEVEN TAKES A MULTI FACETED
APPROACH TO CIRCLE FORNEY ON
THE COURSE TO MEET ITS
GREENHOUSE EMISSION REDUCTION
TARGETS. BY MAKING CHANGES AT
THE STATE LOCAL AND REGIONAL
LEVEL TO PROVIDE TOOLS
ACCOUNTABILITY AND INCENTIVES.
TO METROPOLITAN PLANNING
ORGANIZATIONS NPOS TO MEET
THERE TWENTY TWENTY THREE
REGIONAL GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSION TARGETS. S. B. THREE
SEVENTY FIVE BY DARRELL
STEINBERG IN TWO THOUSAND EIGHT
ABOUT SUSTAINABLE COMMUNITIES
WAS A FIRST OF ITS KIND AND
GROUNDBREAKING LAW THAT
RECOGNIZES THE CRUCIAL ROLE. OF
INTEGRATING TRANSPORTATION LAND
USE AND HOUSING DECISIONS TO
MEET UR CLIMATE GOALS
BASICALLY TO DESIGN OUR CITIES
IN SUCH A WAY THAT WE GIVE
PEOPLE MORE OPTIONS TO WALK AND
BIKE. HOWEVER THE REPORTS FROM
THE AIR RESOURCES BOARD THE LA-
AND OTHERS HAS SAID THAT AS
WELL INTENTIONED AS THAT BILL
WAS IT'S NOT HASN'T YET
ACHIEVED. REALLY AT SCHOOL AND
OUR ADMISSIONS FROM
TRANSPORTATION CONTINUE TO
CLIMB. ELEVEN FORTY SEVEN
REQUIRES THE NPOS TO CREATE A
TWENTY TWENTY FIVE TARGET-ACTION PLAN TO DEVELOP AND IT
ALSO DEVELOPS A BLOCK GRANT
PROGRAM. TO PROVIDE FUNDING TO
THOSE NPOS TO ACHIEVE THOSE
GOALS. AND THE REASON WE LEAVE
IT UP TO AND THEN HE OWES
BECAUSE ADMISSION EMISSION
REDUCTIONS ARE GOING TO LOOK
VERY DIFFERENT IN THE CENTRAL
VALLEY THAN THE LOOKING OVER
LOS ANGELES. THEN LOOK IN SAN
FRANCISCO ALL OF THESE
COMMUNITIES HAVE WAYS OF
REDUCING VEHICLE MILES
TRAVELED. AND THIS BILL GIVES.
THEM FUNDING TO HELP ACHIEVE
THAT- THE BUDGET CONTAINED
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS FOR
BLOCK GRANTS TO IMPLEMENT. S.
C. O. S. AND WE'RE IN
DISCUSSIONS WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION AND THE BUDGET
STUFF ABOUT THIS BILL. AND HOW
IT INTERSECTS WITH THE BUDGET
PROPOSAL. IF THE TRAILER BILLS
VOTED ON LATER THIS WEEK WE
WILL SUBMIT AMENDMENTS TO
REMOVE THE BLOCK GRANT PROGRAM
AND ALIGN THE BILL TO THE
BUDGET ACTION SO WE'VE BEEN IN
CONVERSATION WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION. ABOUT HOW THIS
BILL INTEGRATES WITH THEIR
GOALS AND THEIR BUDGET. IN
ADDITION WE PLAN ON PROVIDING
AUTHORS AMENDMENTS TO THE
SENATE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
THAT WILL ADJUST THE USE OF THE
TERM VEHICLE MILES TRAVELED. TO
CONSIDER ALL THE RAMIFICATIONS
OF BMT REDUCTION ON JOBS IN THE
ECONOMY AND LOW INCOME
COMMUTERS. WITH THESE
AMENDMENTS WE BELIEVE THAT THE
OPPOSITION WILL HOPEFULLY GO
NEUTRAL ON THE BILL. WE HAVE A
GROUP OF BILLS HERE TO TALK TO
US ABOUT THIS BILL BILL MCGEE
EVEN FROM THE COALITION FOR
CLEAN AIR. AND BILL HIGGINS
FROM CAL COG IN SUPPORT WITH
THAT IRISH AND I BOTH THINK
THANK YOU ASSEMBLYMEMBER THAT
FIRST MODERATOR WE HAVE MISTER
BILL MCGOVERN. WITH THE
COALITION FOR CLEAN AIR. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MADAM CHAIR THIS
IS BILL MCGOVERN WITH COALITION
FOR CLEAN AIR AND WE STRONGLY
SUPPORT. THE B. ELEVEN FORTY
SEVEN BECAUSE IT WOULD
SIGNIFICANTLY IMPROVE THE
STATE'S EFFORTS. TO PROVIDE
TRANSPORTATION CHOICES. THAT
REDUCE HARMFUL AIR ND CLIMATE
POLLUTION. AS WELL AS VEHICLE
MILES TRAVELED. CALIFORNIA WELL
WE'VE LED THE NATION IN
APPLYING ADVANCED TECHNOLOGIES
TO VEHICLE ENGINES AND
PROMOTING INNOVATION IN
TRANSPORTATION FUELS. WE HAVE
STRUGGLED TO ALIGN LAND USE.
WITH THE NEED TO REDUCE VEHICLE
MILES TRAVELED. AND ITS
CORRESPONDING EMISSIONS THAT
ARE CAUSING. THE TWIN CRISES OF
AIR POLLUTION AND CLIMATE
CHANGE. THE PASSAGE OF SB THREE
SEVENTY FIVE- AS MISTREATMENT
SAID. RAISED HOPES FOR A
PARADIGM SHIFT BUT THAT WAS NOT
A BIG DEAL BEING IT'S INTENDED
CLIMATE HEALTH EQUITY AND
CONSERVATION RESULTS. OF THE
TRANSPORTATION SECTOR IS THE
LEADING SOURCE OF ERROR IN
CLIMATE SOLUTION WE DO NEED TO
REDUCE VEHICLE MILES TRAVELED
AND THIS BILL WOULD MAKE THE
FIRST REALLY IMPORTANT
IMPROVEMENTS IN SP THREE
SEVENTY FIVE. IN THE THIRTEEN
YEARS SINCE IT IS PAST. IT
WOULD GET THE BILL WITH THE
DIFFERENT GOVERNMENTAL ENTITIES
TALKING TO EACH OTHER WHICH IS
CRUCIAL. AND ALSO WELL I THINK
THERE'S A LOT OF DISAGREEMENT
ON THE ISSUE OF VEHICLE MILES
TRAVELED SOMETHING THAT WE ALL
AGREE ON IS THAT WE NEED MORE
FUNDING. FOR SUSTAINABLE
COMMUNITIES AND THIS BILL WOULD
HAVE THE FUNDING AND DIRECTED
IN THE RIGHT WAY. WE ALSO ARE
IN SUPPORT OF FIFTEEN MINUTE
COMMUNITIES AND- BICYCLE
HIGHWAYS AND SO FOR ALL THOSE
REASONS WE SUPPORT THIS BILL
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MR
MCGOVERN- NEXT WE HAVE MISTER
BILL HIGGINS FROM CAL COG. GOOD
MORNING THIS IS BILL HIGGINS
FROM THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
COUNCIL THE GOVERNMENT THAT
REPRESENTS A REGIONAL
TRANSPORTATION PLANNING
AGENCIES ACROSS THE STATE AND
ALSO ALL EIGHTEEN METROPOLITAN
PLANNING ORGANIZATIONS
RESPONSIBLE FOR THIRTY THREE
SEVENTY FIVE. FIRST OF ALL WE
WANT TO THANK ASSEMBLYMEMBER
FRIEDMAN FOR HER LEADERSIP HER
WILLINGNESS TO DIG DOWN IN HERE
ALL THE PERSPECTIVES IT'S BEEN
GREAT TO WORK WITH OUR WE HAVE
HAD A FEW COMMANDMENTS POSITION
FROM THE BEGINNING APPRECIATING
HER WORK. BECAUSE OUR BOARDS
ARE MADE UP OF CITY AND COUNTY
OFFICIALS AND THEY HAD SOME
CONCERNS AND WE'VE BEEN WORKING
WITH THEM MY UNDERSTANDING IS
WHAT THE AUTHORS AMENDMENT
SUGGESTING THAT THOSE. WILL BE
OUR CONCERNS WILL BE ADDRESSED
AND WE'RE TAKING THE WIN LET IT
OUT WE'RE TAKING THAT TO OUR
BOARD AND I ANTICIPATE A CHANGE
POSITION VERY SHORTLY BUT I
WANTED TO SAY- ONE THING A
COUPLE OF THE THINGS THAT THIS
BILL REALLY DOES. THAT WORK CUT
IT OUT FIRST OF ALL THE BLOCK
GRANT PROGRAM THAT IN THE
BUDGET THAT- SIMPLY MEMBER HAS
BEEN LEADING ON IS ONE THING
THAT WE'VE BEEN ASKING FOR
TWELVE YEARS A LOT OF FOLKS
THAT SAID WELL THREE SEVENTY
FIVE DOING EVERYTHING THAT IT
SHOULD. IT'S NEVER BEN FUNDED
THE WAY IT'S ABOUT TO BE FUNDED
AND WE ARE EXCITED TO SEE THE
RESULTS. THE SECOND THING IS
THOSE SMALL CHANGE IN THE
LANGUAGE THAT DEALS WITH HOW
THE STRATEGIC GROWTH COUNCIL
WILL ANALYZE THE STATE
TRANSPORTATION PLAN- AND IT IS
IN A WAY THAT I. THINK IS
REALLY RELEVANT TO THIS
COMMITTEE- THE-STAKES. PLAN IS
NOW UP THIS WEEK. STOCKMAN FOR
OUR REGIONAL TRANSPORTATION
PLAN FOR THIS YEAR THE CARD THE
DIFFERENCES. WITH BOTH TRY AND
ACHIEVE THE MOST WE CAN BUT IN
A PICKLE CONSTRAINED DOCUMENT
YOU CAN ONLY DO IT WITH THE
EXPECTED REVENUES. ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT THIS BILL THAT IS
ANALYZED THAT DIFFERENCE. AND
TO GIVE YOU AN EXAMPLE OF ONE
OF THE THINGS OUR MEMBERS ARE
STRUGGLING WITH- WE EMBRACE THE
TRANSITION TO ELECTRIC
VEHICLES. BUT WE'RE ALSO
CONCERNED THAT IN OUR
TRANSPORTATION PLANS THAT ARE
ON THE BOOKS RIGHT NOW. WE'VE
MADE SOME REVENUE ASSUMPTIONS
ABOUT GAS TAXES THAT WON'T
MATERIALIZES IN THE TRANSITION
TO ELECTRIC VEHICLES. AND
THERE'S NO BACK BILLING WHEN WE
LOOK OUT IN THE OUT YEARS WE
HAVE A LOT OF MITIGATION
STRATEGIES THAT WE'RE THINKING
ABOUT THAT WILL BE. AT THE
STATE WILL BE ONE TO FOUR
BILLION DOLLARS A YEAR SHORT ON
BECAUSE THEY WILL BE THE GAS
TAX REVENUES TO FILL IT OUT. WE
THINK THAT- THIS STUDY WILL
ALLOW US TO DO LIKE SOME OF
THOSE ISSUES TO TALK ABOUT
THOSE ISSUES SO THAT WE CAN
PLAN AHEAD. SO THAT WE CAN HAVE
A WELL FUNDED. SUSTAINABLE
TRANSPORTATION SYSTEM NOT ONLY
NOW BUT GOING TO TWENTY FORTY
SO WE APPRECIATE- MISTREATMENT
LEADERSHIP ON THAT. AND THANK
YOU FOR OFFERING THIS BILL
THANK YOU MR HIGGINS A PREACHER
TESTIMONY. ALL RIGHT- WILL GO
TO THE COASTLINE AGAIN I'M
SORRY THE CONFERENCE LINE AGAIN
IF THERE ARE ANY WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT. OF AB ELEVEN FORTY
SEVEN. AND THANK YOU MADAM.
LADIES AND GENTLEMAN THAT YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF
EIGHTY ELEVEN FORTY SEVEN YOU
MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO AT
THIS TIME. NINE FIFTY SIX YOUR
LINE IS A HUNDRED GRAND. HELLO
WE'RE TAKING I. EIGHTY ONE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
IN A BROWN AND ABSENCE THEY'RE
CLICK COUNSELING AND SUPPORT
THANK YOU. NINE NINETY THREE.
GOOD MORNING FROM OUT OF THE
COALITION FOR SUSTAINABLE
PLANNING AND B. C. S. T-
SPEAKING IN SUPPORT. NINE FORTY
NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THANK YOU YOUR
NUMBER'S MAKITA CROWD EVEN THE
NATURAL RESOURCES DEFENSE
COUNCIL CALLING FOR TO BE
DELIVERED FORTY SEVEN THANK YOU.
NINE THIRTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MICHAEL SNYDER
ABOUT MENTAL SPACE STREET FOR
ALL IN SUPPORT OF EIGHTY ELEVEN
FORTY SEVEN. NINE THIRTY FIVE.
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING AND WE
MARCHED OUT ON BEHALF OF THREE
FIFTY BAY AREA ACTION IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. NINE NINETY
SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING PHIL MURPHY
ELDERS CLIMATE ACTIONS NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN SUPPORT.
NINE THIRTY TWO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. YOUR
THIRTY TWO RIGHT. YES PLEASE GO
AHEAD PERFECT- GOOD MORNING MY
NAME IS JONATHAN ESCOBAR WITH
THE AMERICAN LUNG ASSOCIATION
IN SUPPORT- AT ELEVEN FORTY
SEVEN. NINE EIGHTY SEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD-
JANET **** FOR THREE FIFTY
STALKING VALLEY IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU. NINE THIRTY ONE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
CHRISLEY ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
COUNTIES WE HAVE A NEUTRAL
POSITION BASED ON THE PROPOSED
AUTHORS A MOMENT I WANT TO
THANK SOMEONE OVER TREATMENT
FOR WORKING WITH US TO ADDRESS
OUR CONCERNS. NINE FIFTY FOUR
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. NINE FIFTY FOUR YOU MAY
BE ON MUTE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THIS IS DONNA MAPS CALIFORNIA'S
YOUR QUALITY MANAGER WITH YOUR
BOX PARTNERSHIP AND SUPPORT
THANK YOU. NINE FIFTY SIX YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
NORTH AMERICA WITH THE
CALIFORNIA LEAGUE CONSERVATION
VOTERS INTO A CORNER. WE HAVE
NO FURTHER COMMENT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MODERATOR WILL TAKE
IT TO THE GALLERY IS THERE
ANYONE WHO'D LIKE TO SUPPLY-
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF A B.
ELEVEN FORTY SEVEN C. NONE WILL
GO TO ROOM ONE TWELVE C. NINE-
AND SO WE'VE CONCLUDED SUPPORT
WILL NOW GO INTO OPPOSITION
THERE IS NO LEAD A WITNESS AND
AN OPPOSITION. MODERATOR TO
HAVE ANYONE ON THE LINE IN
OPPOSITION TO AB ELEVEN FORTY
SEVEN PLEASE. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR AND LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF AB ELEVEN FORTY
SEVEN. YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. ONCE
AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF EIGHTY ELEVEN
FORTY SEVEN YOU MAY PRESS ONE.
AND THEN ZERO. NINE TWENTY NINE
ONE MOMENT PLEASE. LOOKS LIKE
NINE TWENTY NINE OKAY YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINE
TWENTY NINE YOU MAY BE ON HERE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. WE HAVE NO
RESPONSE FROM NINE TWENTY NINE
THERE AE NO FURTHER COMMENT
THANK YOU THANK YOU MODERATOR
DO WE HAVE ANYONE ELSE IN THE
GALLERY WHO'D LIKE TO TESTIFY
IN OPPOSITION TO AB ELEVEN
FORTY SEVEN C. NINE ROOM ONE
TWELVE. C. NONE OKAY SO WE'VE
CONCLUDED SUPPORT AND
OPPOSITION WILL TAKE IT BACK TO
MEMBERS ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM MEMBERS AT THIS
TIME. OKAY SEE NONE I DO HAVE A
MOTION ON ELEVEN FORTY SEVEN.
SENATOR NEWMAN THANK YOU-
ASSEMBLYWOMAN WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE I JUST WANT TO
ACKNOWLEDGE IT MICHAEL JARED
FROM THE NATURAL RESOURCES
COMMITTEE STAFFS INCREDIBLE
WORK ON THE BILL WITH THAT I
WOULD ASK FOR AN IPHONE THANK
YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH- MISTER
CHIEF CONSULTANT CAN YOU PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AND REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS.
CENTER CONSULTS HI. KEN DOLLS I
IT'S NO HELLO. SUCH A LETTER.
BECKER BY BECKER HIGH CORTESE.
DOLLY DOLLY NOW DONE HI DAD I.
WHERE BLENDERS LENDERS NOW MANY.
MAN I NEWMAN NEWMAN HIGH
REVEALED. RUBIO I SCARE. NUMBER
I CASKEY BY KELSEY I BOOK.
SEVEN THREE THANK YOU SOMEONE
NUMBER WILL KEEP THAT ON CALL A
WONDERFUL SO NEXT WE'LL GO ON
TO IT LOOKS LIKE WE HAVE-
SIMPLY MEMBRANOUS ARIAN WHO IS
HERE WHO WILL PRESENT NEXT ON
FILE ITEM EIGHT WHICH IS A B.
SEVEN SEVEN THREE. WELCOME
ASSEMBLY MEMBER. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH A GOOD AFTERNOON. THAT
AFTERNOON YEP GOOD MORNING
MADAM CHAIR AND SENATORS THIS
BILL AUTHORIZES LOCAL
AUTHORITIES TO MAKE TEMPORARY
SLOW STREETS PERMANENT. IN
ADDITION AB SEVEN SEVEN THREE
AUTHORIZES LOCAL AUTHORITIES TO
ADOPT A RULE OR REGULATION TO
DESIGNATE A LOCAL STREET WITHIN
ITS JURISDICTION AS A SLOW
STREET. THE CITY OF LOS ANGELES
HAS IMPLEMENTED TEMPORARY
PROGRAMS DURING THE COPA
NINETEEN PANDEMIC THAT HAVE
CREATED MORE THAN FIFTY MILES
OF SLOW STREETS. FOR PEOPLE FOR
THE RESIDENTS ESPECIALLY THAT
NEED IT THE MOST- THIS IS BEEN
A WINNING CONCEPT IT'S A
CONCEPT THAT'S BEEN USED
UTILIZED QUITE A BIT IN OTHER
PARTS OF THE WORLD- CREATING
MORE OPEN SPACE FOR BICYCLING
WALKING WHILE INCREASING
OPPORTUNITIES FOR RECREATION.
THOSE TWEETS PROGRAM HAS BEEN
MET WITH AN OVERWHELMING DEMAND
FROM THE RESIDENTS AND DOZENS
OF NEIGHBORHOODS ARE WAITING ON
LOCAL INSTALLATIONS TO CONTINUE
AND EXPAND THIS PROGRAM AND TO
REALIZE THE FULL LONG TERM
BENEFITS- SLOW STREETS THE
PERMANENCE AND THAT'S WHAT THIS
BILL DOES- A. B. SEVEN SEVEN
THREE HAS NO FISCAL IMPACT TO
CALIFORNIA HAS REGISTERED NO
OPPOSITION. AND WITH ME IS
TRULY A SALINAS FROM MAYOR
GARCETTI'S OFFICE THANK YOU
SOME REMEMBER MODERATOR CAN YOU
ENSURE THAT A MISSILE IN THIS
IS ON THE LINE. SHE'S ON THE
LINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN THE
SCHOOL IN. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR VICE
CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
TRANSPORTATION COMMITTEE THANK
YOU AT THE- MY NAME'S JULIA.
TRANSPORTATION MANAGER WITH THE
OFFICE OF MY- ERIC GARCETTI WE
ARE PROUD EIGHTY SEVEN SEVEN
THREE WHICH WOULD GIVE YOU THE
ABILITY TO PRIORITIZE STREET
FOR COMMUNITY. JUST OVER A YEAR
AGO CLICK ON THE NINETEENTH AND
THEN EXPORT CALIFORNIANS THEY
CALL FOR PUBLIC SPEAKING. COM
AT HOME ORDERS AND COMMUNITIES
IN NEED THANKS FOR YOUR TO GET
OUTSIDE HER HOME CITIES ACROSS
THE STATE AS WELL AS ACROSS THE
NATION WORLD. ONCE PROGRAMS
COLLECTIVELY CALLED CLOSE
STREET. IN LOS ANGELES THE
DEPARTMENT OF TRANSPORTATION
SALLY BEAUTY WORKED WITH
COMMUNITY INVOLVED INSTALLED.
ON APPROXIMATELY FIFTY MILES
AND NEIGHBORHOOD STREETS. WELL
THREE PROGRAM IN LA WITH THE
TRUE PARTNERSHIPS BETWEEN LOCAL.
GOVERNMENT AND FARM THREE KEY
GROUP. VOLUNTEERED MONITOR THE
TEMPORARY INSTANTLY WITH THEIR
OWN TIME. THE PROGRAM ONCE IN
MAY TWENTY TWENTY AND ALMOST
ALL ARE STILL IN PLACE TODAY.
IN LOS ANGELES. VERY POPULAR
PROGRAM WE'VE ACTUALLY BEEN
UNABLE TO MEET THE DEMANDS OF
COMMUNITY FOR TEMPORARY PROGRAM
AND YOU'RE CURRENTLY WORKING
WITH COMMUNITIES TO MAKE
EXISTING INSTALLATIONS MORE
FOR. EIGHTY SEVEN SEVEN THREE
BOOK PROVIDES CITIES WITH A
TOOL TO MAKE. AND ALLOWS CITIES
TO ADOPT AN ORDINANCE WHICH
WOULD INCLUDE A PUBLIC
EDUCATION AND OUTREACH
COMPONENT. THAT MEET THE NEEDS
AND THEIR NEIGHBOR. AND TO BE
CLEAR THE ONLY BE ON
NEIGHBORHOOD STREETS RATHER
THAN COMMERCIAL CORRIDORS IT
WOULD NOT AFFECT PARKING AND IT
WOULD NOT AFFECT STRUGGLING.
WITH CHANGE WOULD NEVER PREVENT
ANYONE FROM ACCESSING A LOCAL
STREET THANK YOU. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR CONSIDERATION AND HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS AND
ACTUALLY ASK FOR IT. THANK YOU
MISSILE INDUSTRY PROCEDURE
TESTIMONY A MODERATOR TO HAVE
ANYONE ELSE IN THE QUEUE WOULD
LIKE TO SUPPORT. AB SEVEN SEVEN
THREE PLEASE. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF
YOU WISH TO SUPPORT. EIGHTY
SEVEN SEVEN THREE YOU MAY PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
NINE FORTY NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
CANNOT INSURE MEMBERS WHO KEEP
A KARATE WITH ENERGY C. CALLING
IN SUPPORT OF EIGHTY SEVEN
SEVEN THIRTY THANK YOU. NINE
EIGHTY SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS SAID IN
A COFFIN WITH THE LEAGUE OF
CALIFORNIA CITIES- CALLING IN.
SUPPORT THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
NINE NINETY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING- BRUISING ONE FROM OUR
NEW COALITION FOR SUSTAINABLE
PLANNING NBC'S SKI CALLING IN
SUPPORT OF A. B. SEVEN SEVEN
THREE. MY NINETEEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINE
NINETEEN YOU MAY BE ON MUTE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MEDICARE
MEMBERS JOSHUA SHOPPER SIM
CISCO MARYLAND BREED INTERCOM
SUPPORT THANK YOU. NINE NINETY
TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS BERNARD
I'M A RESIDENT OF LOS ANGELES
AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT. EIGHTY
SEVEN THOUSAND THREE THANKS
YEAH. WE HAVE NO FURTHER
COMMENT AND CUTE THANK YOU
MODERATOR- SO WE'LL TAKE IT TO
THE GALLERY IS THERE ANYONE WHO
WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF A. B. SEVEN SEVEN
THREE THREE NINE ROOM ONE
TWELVE C. NINE. A WE DO NOT
HAVE ANY LEAD OPPOSITION AT
THIS TIME- MODERATOR DO WE HAVE
ANYONE ON IN THE QUEUE WOULD
LIKE TO OPPOSE AB SEVEN SEVEN
THREE PLEASE. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR AND LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF BABIES SEVEN
SEVEN THREE YOU MAY PRESS ONE.
AND ZERO AT THIS TIME. ONCE
AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF AB SEVEN SEVEN
THREE YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND
THEN THERE. WE HAVE NO ONE IN
THE QUEUE AT THIS TIME. OKAY
THANK YOU MODERATOR- WILL GO TO
THE GALLERY ANYONE IN
OPPOSITIONOF A. B. SEVEN SEVEN
THREE C. NINE ROOM ONE TWELVE
C. NINE. SO WE'VE CONCLUDED
SUPPORT IN OPPOSITION- WE'LL
TAKE IT BACK TO MEMBERS ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS SENATOR
BECKER. THANK YOU BUT I WANT TO
COMMEND THE AUTHOR FOR THIS
BILL I THINK IT'S VERY
IMPORTANT BUT FOR COMMUNITIES
THAT ARE VERY SUPPORTIVE OF
THIS I'VE BEEN WORKING WITH.
FOLKS IN MY DISTRICT ON WHAT
THEY CALL COMPLETE STREETS N. I
THINK THIS IS A HUGE STEP IN
THE RIGHT DIRECTION AND- THE
GOAL OF ROSSI COMPREHENSIVE
INTEGRATIVE APPROACH TO
MANAGING OUR STREETS A SHARED.
PUBLIC SPACES FOR SOCIALISING
RETREATING GET TO WORK SHOPPING
AND GATHERING AND I HOPE AS WE
LOOK AT THIS ISSUE EVEN GOING
FOR THE FURTHER AS YOU WORK TO
MAKE OUR STREETS SAFER AS WE'VE
DONE WITH THIS BUILD ONE
EARLIER TODAY. WE CAN ALSO MAKE
THEM MORE ATTRACTIVE WE BETTER
MANAGE STORMWATER INCREASE OUR
NATURE OUR URBAN TREE CANOPY A
NATIVE PLANTS- BEYOND SEE ALL
KIND OF BENEFITS THAT WHEN WE
MANAGE OUR STREETS AND PUBLIC
SPACES. AS A SHARED ASSET THE
BENEFIT OF FOR ALL NOT JUST AS
CONDUITS FOR CAR TRUCK TRAFFIC
SO AGAIN I COMMEND THE AUTHOR
AND- I WILL MOVE THE BILL WHEN
APPROPRIATE. THANK YOU SENATOR
BAKER I DON'T SEE ANY OTHER
MIKES UP- ASSEMBLYMEMBER
NAZARIAN I JUST WANNA THANK YOU
AS WELL FOR WORKING WITH OUR
COMMITTEE AND THIS IS GOING TO
BE A GREAT BENEFIT FOR MANY
LOCATIONS I'D LIKE TO SEE THEM
HISTORICALLY IN PLACES THEY
HAVEN'T BEEN SO LIKE SOUTH LOS
ANGELES OUT THESE DELAY- PLACES
WHERE PEOPLE REALLY. WANT TO
GET OUT AND GATHER AND DON'T
WANT TO SEE TRAFFIC IN FRONT OF
THEIR THEIR HOME SO THAT WOULD
I KNOW THIS IS GOING TO. LEAD
TO THAT AND MANY MORE UP AND
DOWN THE STATE SO WITH THAT
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR ALL BOTH OF
YOUR COMMENTS PREVIEW TO
SUPPORT AND- THAT THE GOAL IS
ULTIMATELY TO GET TO WHERE. THE
SENATOR WAS TALKING ABOUT AND I
APPRECIATE WHAT THE CHAIR SET
AS WELL THE GOAL IS TO MAKE
SURE THAT THE POOR COMMUNITIES
ARE TAKING FULL ADVANTAGE OF
THIS AND THEY BECOME THE
PRIORITY. THANK YOU I
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL THANK
YOU ASSEMBLYMEMBER WE HAVE A
MOTION BY SENATOR BECKER MISTER
CHIEF. CONSULTNT CAN YOU
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. THE
MOTION IS TO PASS- GONZALEZ
FIVE DOLLARS I BATES. HELEN
HELLO BECKER HI THERE I PUT
EIGHTY. DOLLY DOLLING UP DOT
DOT I REQUIRE. LET THIS. LATEST
NOW. MAN MAN HI HUMAN NEWMAN
NEWMAN I REVEAL. RUBIO LIFE
SKINNER. NUMBER CASKET HI BY
KELSEY I WILL. SEVEN TWO OKAY
WE'LL LEAVE THE BILL ON CALL
THANK YOU SOMEBODY MEMBER VERY
MUCH. GREAT SO WE ARE WAITING
ALL I DO SEE OTHER AUTHORS WAS
HIDING BACK THERE SO THERE HE
IS. WE HAVE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
LOWELL WHO IS ABOUT TO PRESENT
FILE ITEM SEVEN AND I APOLOGIZE
FOR GOING IN AND OUT OF ORDER
BUT YOU KNOW IT'S VERY BUSY
SEASON RIGHT NOW. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER LOW WILL BE PRESENTING
ON AB SEVEN TWO THREE WELCOME
ASSEMBLY MEMBER. COMMITTING
MADAM CHAIR AND COLLEAGUES THIS
IS ASSEMBLY BILL SEVEN TWENTY
THREE WHICH WOULD ALLOW THE
DEPARTMENT OF MOTOR VEHICLES TO
ESTABLISH A RECIPROCAL DRIVER'S
LICENSE AGREEMENT. BETWEEN
CALIFORNIA AND OTHER COUNTRIES.
CLOSE TO THIRTY STATES ALREADY
HAVE SUCH PROGRAMS IN PLACE I'M
HOPE TO CREATE NEW
OPPORTUNITIES FOR COUNTRIES TO
CREATE RECIPROCAL AGREEMENTS
WITH ME TODAY IS THE STEAM
CONSUL GENERAL OF JAPAN CONSUL
GENERAL MYERS. WITH RESPECT WE
ASKED RIVAL. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH- WE HAVE YES THE CONSUL
GENERAL OF JAPAN TORU MEHTA. WE
BELIEVE IS HERE IN PERSON. MR
CONSUL GENERAL WELCOME THANK
YOU FOR JOINING US IF YOU GO
THROUGH THE- GO GO. BUT I'M
SURE THE LOCAL COMMITTEE
MEMBERS GOOD MORNING BUT I'M
STILL REMINDED POSITIONAL
DISCIPLINE IS OF A CISCO. I'M
VERY MUCH HONORED AND GRATEFUL
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO EXPRESS
THEIR OPINION ABOUT THE EIGHTY
SEVEN TO THREE ON BEHALF OF THE
JAPANESE GOVERNMENT. WHICH THAT
WE EXPECT THAT IF THE BILL AB
SEVEN TWENTY THREE HIS PAST OF
THE BURDEN ASSOCIATED WITH
GETTING DRIVER'S LICENSES
REDUCED THE QUALITY OF LIVES
OF JAPANESE PEOPLE LIVING IN
CALIFORNIA AND CALIFORNIA
PEOPLE LIVING IN JAPAN. FLUTE
CERTAINLY REDUCED. WELL WE SAW
IMPROVED QUALITY OF LIFE WOULD
BE TO BE PROVED BY THE MALL AS
A RESULT THIS DEPARTMENT
BECAUSE MANY RELATIONS WILL BE
STRENGTHENED IN THE AREAS OF
BUSINESS TOURISM. AND MANY
OTHERS. SYSTEM IS THE LARGEST
FOREIGN INVESTOR IN CALIFORNIA.
MANY JAPANESE BUSINESSPERSONS
HAVE COME TO LIVE AND DO
BUSINESS IN CALIFORNIA. I HOPE
THIS BILL IF IT COMES. INTO
EFFECT. WILL FURTHER TO A GREAT
JAPANESE COMPANIES AN INFANT
INTO PRINTERS TO INVEST AND
OPERATE IN CALIFORNIA. HELLO
BOYS FOR THE CURRENT ONE AND
CONFLICTS. BUT AS OF TODAY
JAPAN HAS SYMBOLS HE'S WITH
TWENTY NINE COUNTRIES AND
REGIONS FULL RECIPROCAL PARTS
OF THE ENGINE. OF THE
EXAMINATION OF THE FULL
DRIVER'S LICENSE. TO BURN AS
EMBASSIES WITH THE SIX U. S.
STATES NAMELY INDIANA OHIO
VIRGINIA POLITE MARILYN AND
WASHINGTON. THE LOCAL SIMS OF
COMMERCE INDUSTRIES HAVE OPENLY
EXPRESSED THEIR APPRECIATION
FOR THE EXEMPTION THE FULL. THE
JAPANESE GOVERNMENT IS VERY
MUCH INTERESTED IN PURSUING
SUCH INTIMACY WITH THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. BUT I HOPE THIS
BILL WOULD ENCOURAGE SUCH
ANIMAL C. HOWEVER TAKING THIS
OPPORTUNITY I'D LIKE TO DRAW
THE ATTENTION O THE HONORABLE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS TO THE
FOLLOWING THREE POINTS. FIRST
THIS BILL REQUIRES DRIVER'S
LICENSES ISSUED IN FOREIGN
COUNTRIES TO BE SURRENDERED TO
CUT THROUGH ANY AUTHORITIES OR
DESTROYED. THIS COULD CAUSE A
MAJOR PROBLEM FOR THOSE WHO
TRAVEL BETWEEN CULTURAL AND IN
JAPAN. ALL THOSE WHO RETURNED
TO JAPAN AFTER A PERIOD OF
RESIDENCE IN CALIFORNIA BECAUSE
OF THAT THERE'S NO SUCH
REQUIREMENT INTIMACIES BETWEEN
JAPAN AND THE ABOVE MENTIONED
SIX STATES IN THE UNITED STATES.
SECOND THE BILL IS SUPPOSED TO
EXAMINE THE PRACTICAL
EXAMINATION. BUT IN THE
EMBASSY'S BETWEEN JAPAN AND THE
OTHER SIX STATES THE WRITTEN
EXAMINATION. ALSO NEW TO THE-
ISN'T IT. THE THIRD. THE BILL
REQUIRES AN AUTHORIZATION OF
THE DRIVER'S LICENSE BUT THE
DIPLOMATIC MISSION IN THE U. S.
BUT IN SOME CASES THIS IS NOT
REQUIRED IN OTHER STATES. IN
CLOSING. I'D LIKE TO REITERATE
OUR SUPPORT IN PRINCIPLE FOR
THE EIGHTY SEVEN TO THREE. AND
WE VERY MUCH APPRECIATE THE
INITIATIVE TAKEN BY.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER LITTLE TO
INTRODUCE THIS BILL. OF COURSE
THE JOURNAL IN JAPAN OF JAPAN
IS- FRANCISCO STANDS READY TO
COOPERATE WITH THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA IT ANYWAY THE CAT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU
MR CONSUL GENERAL- AND I WANT
TO WELCOME FORMALLY YOUR
DELEGATION- FROM THE CONSULATE
OF JAPAN IN SAN FRANCISCO THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR BEING WITH US
WE APPRECIATE THE TESTIMONY.
WONDERFUL SO WE'VE CONCLUDED
THAT LEAD WITNESS AND SUPPORT A
MODERATOR DO WE HAVE ANYONE
ELSE ON THE LINE IN SUPPORT OF
AB SEVENTY THREE. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR AND LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SIT HE
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF EIGHTY
SEVEN TWENTY THREE YOU MAY
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF EIGHTY
SEVEN TWENTY THREE. YOU MAY
PRESS ONE AND THEN AFTER. WE
HAVE AN APPOINTMENT IN THE
QUEUE. OKAY THANK YOU AND DO WE
HAVE ANYONE ELSE WOULD LIKE TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT IN THE GALLERY
OF BEST OF I'M SORRY AB SEVENTY
THREE. THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING.
MY NAME IS A POOR CHILD I'M
SERVING AS A- SACRAMENTO
KOREAN. COMMUNITY A PRESIDENT
OF A SACRAMENT THE COMMITTEE
COMMITTEE. HI IS STRONGEST
SUPPORT. A. B. SEVEN TWENTY
THREE THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. ANYONE ELSE WOULD LIKE TO
SUPPORT AB SEVENTY THREE. OKAY
I THINK WE'RE GOOD IN THE
GALLERY THANK YOU VERY MUCH
AGAIN FOR BEING WITH US- WILL
NOW GO TO ROOM ONE TWELVE IS
THERE ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT.
NOW AT THE C. NINE WE'LL TAKE
IT BACK TO MEMBERS FOR
DISCUSSION ON A. B. SEVEN TWO
THREE. OKAY SEE NON MEMBERS WHO
WOULD LIKE TO DISCUSS- ASSEMBLY
MEMBER I JUST WANNA THANK YOU
FOR BRINGING THIS FORWARD- WE
ARE AN INTERNATIONAL STATE. ONE
OF THE LARGEST ECONOMIES- IT
CERTAINLY MAKES SENSE
ESPECIALLY TO WORK WITH OUR
INTERNATIONAL PARTNERS AND
ENSURE THAT WE'RE STREAMLINING
THE PROCESS FOR SOME OF OUR
STATE AGENCY PROCESSES SO WITH
THAT. I WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
THAT RECOGNITION MANAGER AND
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL. THE
SYSTEM. THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND
I FAILED TO ASK FOR OPPOSITION
YOU DON'T HAVE ANY LEAD
OPPOSITION HERE- BUT I WILL GO
TO THE CONFERENCE LINE MY
APOLOGIES ANYONE IN OPPOSITION
OF A. B. SEVEN SEVEN. TWO THREE
BEFORE WE CLOSE HERE. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR AND LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION OF EIGHTY SEVEN
TWENTY THREE YOU MAY PRESS ONE.
AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF EIGHTY
SEVEN TWENTY THREE YOU MAY
PRESS ONE. AND THEN ZERO ONE
MOMENT. WE DO HAVE ONE COMMON
THANK YOU. IT LOOKS LIKE OUR
CALLER. WITH A COMMENT IS IN
OPPOSITION OF EIGHTY SEVEN
TWENTY THREE REMOVE THEMSELVES
FROM Q. OKAY THANK YOU IS THERE
ANYONE ELSE IN THE QUEUE IN
OPPOSITION JUST TO CONFIRM. WE
HAVE NOBODY OKAY. THANK YOU WE
SEE. ANYONE IN THE GALLERY IN
OPPOSITION TO STAY B. SEVENTY
THREE WE SEE NONE ROOM ONE
TWELVE IN OPPOSITION. CNN OKAY
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SO WE'VE
CONCLUDED SUPPORT OPPOSITION WE
DON'T HAVE ANY MEMBER QUESTIONS
THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE AGAIN MY
APOLOGIES. CALIFORNIA IS A
GLOBAL ECONOMY AND THIS HELPS
TO RECOGNIZE THE IMPORTANCE OF
THE ROLE THAT WE PLAY IN THE
WORLD I RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- AND DO WE
HAVE A MOTION ON AB SEVENTY
THREE. SENTIMENT TO MOVE
SENATOR THANK YOU MISTER CHIEF
CONSULTANT CAN YOU PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. THE MOTION IS TO PASS
TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS. FEDERER
GONZALEZ FIVE DOLLARS I BATES.
BATES NO ALAN ARCHULETA BECKER
BEDRIJF CORTESE DOLLY DOLLY NOW
DOT. BUT I GLARE BELINDA'S
BELINDA'S NOW MEN. NEWMAN
NEWMAN I YEAH. SKINNER NUMBER
BY KELSEY WELL. FOUR THREE
THANK YOU SUMMER MEMBER WILL
LEAVE THE BILL ON CALL THANK
YOU AND THANK YOU AGAIN FOR
BEING WITH US WE APPRECIATE THE
TESTIMONY AGAIN. ALL RIGHTS-
OUR NEXT BILL AND I DON'T SEE
ANY OTHER AUTHORS IN. SO WE'RE
JUST WAITING FOR SOME OFFERS AT
THIS TIME BUT WE'VE GONE
THROUGH HALF OF OUR BILL LOAD
WHICH IS WONDERFUL SO WE WILL
WAIT FOR A FEW MINUTES AND
WE'LL COME BACK.
THEY'VE BEEN
ABLE. TO OKAY YEAH SURE. OKAY
WELL WE'RE WAITING THANK YOU
SENATOR MELENDEZ WILL GO HEAD
AND- LIFT THE CALLS AND A FEW
OTHER BILLS WHILE WE'RE WAITING
FOR AUTHORS TO PRESENT- WILL
START- IN FILE I DON'T FILE
ORDER PLEASE MISTER CHIEF
CONSULTANT NUMBER FILE ITEM
NUMBER TWO EIGHTY FORTY ONE.
I'M SORRY NUMBER THREE A. B.
FORTY THREE. MAYBE FORTY THREE
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED AND REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS THE
CHAIR AND THE VICE CHAIR
BUILDING HI. ALAN SUCH A LETTER.
DOT DONNA HI REQUIRE. LENDERS
LENDERS I MEAN MAN HI SCANNER.
HUMBERT CASKEY I LIKE WHAT
CASKEY I WILL. TEN ONE OKAY
THANK YOU MISTER CHIEF
CONSULTANT WILL CONTINUE TO
LEAVE THAT BILL ON CALL AND I
DO SEE HER ASSEMBLY MEMBER HE
IS HERE AND READY TO PRESENT
ASSEMBLYMEMBER QUIRK AB
THIRTEEN OH TWO WELCOME. THANK
YOU SENATOR. SENATORS CHAIR AND
MEMBERS- EIGHTY THIRTEEN OH TWO
CODIFIES REGULATIONS THAT THE
BUREAU OF CANNABIS CONTROL
ADOPTED WITH RESPECT TO
CANNABIS ADVERTISING ALONG
HIGHWAYS. SPECIFICALLY THIS
BILL WILL ALLOW CANNABIS
LICENSEES TO ADVERTISE OR
MARKET ONE OF BILLBOARDS ALONG
THE HIGHWAY THAT IS FURTHER
THAN FIFTEEN MILE RADIUS FROM
CALIFORNIA VOTERS BORDER. WHICH
IN PROP SIXTY FOUR STATES THE
LICENSEE SHALL NOT ADVERTISE OR
MARKET ON A BILLBOARD OR
SIMILAR ADVERTISING DEVICE
LOCATED ON INTERSTATE OR STATE
HIGHWAY THAT CROSSES THE
CALIFORNIA BORDER. THIS IS
ALREADY PROBLEMATIC BECAUSE
STATE HIGHWAYS DON'T CROSS THE
BORDER. IN TWENTY NINETEEN THE
BUREAU OF CANNABIS CONTROL
CONCLUDED THE PROP SIXTY FOUR
DOES NOT CLARIFY TO WHAT EXTENT
SUCH PROHIBITIONS WOULD TAKE
PLACE FELT THAT A FIFTEEN MILE
RADIUS WAS APPROPRIATE. TWO
THINGS I'D LIKE TO NOTE MY
STAKEHOLDERS REACHED OUT TO
SOME OF THE ORIGINAL DRAFTERS
OF PROPOSITION SIXTY FOUR. TO
SEE IF THEY COULD SHARE
BACKGROUND AND WHY THE LANGUAGE
WAS ADDED AND NONE COULD RECALL.
MY SUPPORTERS AND I FIND IT
DIFFICULT TO COMPREHEND THAT WE
WOULD FORMALLY LEGALIZED
INDUSTRY. BUT MAKE
ADVERTISEMENT SO RESTRICTIVE
THAT IT WOULD ESSENTIALLY
PROHIBIT THEM FROM ADVERTISING
ALTOGETHER. UNFORTUNATELY THE
BUREAU'S REGULATIONS WERE
CHALLENGED IN THE ST LOUIS
OBISPO COURT WHICH RULED THAT
THE BUREAU LACKED AUTHORITY IN
IMPLEMENTING THESE REGULATIONS.
MY SUPPORTERS AND I
FUNDAMENTALLY DISAGREE ON THIS
POINT WHICH IS WHY THIS BILL
WILL FORMALLY CODIFY THESE
REGULATIONS. I THOUGHT THE
DECISION ISSUED BY THE JUDGE IN
THE FORMER CASE PROHIBITS
BILLBOARDS ALONG FOUR THOUSAND
MILES OF INTERSTATE HIGHWAYS
INCLUDING I. FIVE I. TEN AND I.
EIGHTY. ADVERTISEMENT IS A
LISLE ALLOWED ALONG ALL
SEGMENTS OF I. FOUR OH FIVE I
SEVEN TEN I. EIGHT EIGHTY FIVE
FIVE EIGHTY HIGHWAY THIRTY
SEVEN. CALIFORNIA STATE ROUTE.
FOURTEEN ONE SEVENTY SEVEN
EIGHTY NINE JUST TO NAME A FEW.
FOR SERIOUS ABOUT CLOSING THE
DOORON THE ILLICIT MARKET
WHICH IS WERE MINORS GIVE
ACCESS TO CANNABIS WITH UNKNOWN
CONTAMINANTS. WE NEED TO MAKE
SURE WE HELP THE LEGAL MARKET
GROW AND SURVIVE. A. B.
THIRTEEN OH TWO DOES THAT. I
WOULD NW LIKE TO TURN IT OVER
TO MY WITNESSES FIRST AMY
JENKINS ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA. CANNABIS INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION. BANDANA SLOPER ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE
OUTDOOR ADVERTISING
ASSOCIATION. AND FINALLY I HAVE
RON BEALS ON THE PHONE TO
ANSWER ANY TECHNICAL QUESTIONS
YOU MAY HAVE ABOUT HIGHWAY
ADVERTISEMENT HE RETIRED AS
GENERAL COUNSEL FROM CALTRANS.
PLEASE THANK. CALIFORNIA
CANNABIS INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION
PLEASE. YES YES THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR COMMITTEE MEMBER AMY
JENKINS ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA CANNABIS INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION AND STRONG SUPPORT
OF EIGHTY THIRTEEN OH TWO I
WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR FOR
INTRODUCING BELL AS HE STATED
WHEN VOTERS APPROVED PROP SIXTY
FOUR INCLUDED A PATHWAY FOR
LEGAL CANNABIS BUSINESSES YOU
ADVERTISE ON BILLBOARDS SUBJECT
TO FURTHER RESTRICTIONS ON AND
THAT HE ALSO STATED- THE COURT
DECISION IN FARMERS FIRST
BUREAU OF CANNABIS CONTROL.
INTEREST ONE OF THE ONLY
PATHWAYS FOR LEGAL CANNABIS
OPERATORS ADVERTISE THEIR
BUSINESSES ONLY SERVING TO
UNDERMINE COMPLIANT BUSINESSES
AND STRENGTHEN THE ILLICIT
MARKET WHICH CONTINUED TO
OUTNUMBER LEGAL OPERATORS BY
ABOUT 70% CALIFORNIA ALREADY
HAS THE MOST RESTRICTIVE LAWS
AND REGULATIONS DEALING WITH
BILLBOARD CANADA ADVERTISING IN
THE NATION AND NO OTHER
LEGALIZED ADULT USE STATES DOWN
TO THE BILLBOARD ADVERTISING.
REGULATIONS AND SHORT KIND OF
ADVERTISEMENTS ARE NOT
ATTRACTED A MARKETABLE TO
CHILDREN IN ANY WAY AND MUST BE
MORE THAN A THOUSAND FEET FROM
THE PLAYGROUND COOL YOU BETTER
OR OTHER AREA MINERS FREQUENT
THE LEGAL CANNABIS INDUSTRY
STRICTLY ADHERES TO BE APPLIED
AND TAKES VERY SERIOUSLY EIGHTY
THIRTEEN AND TO CLARIFY THE
DISPUTED PROVISION OF PROP
SIXTY FOUR BY CLEARLY
ESTABLISHING IN STATUTE THE
FIFTEEN MILE ADVERTISING
PROHIBITION PREVIOUSLY
ESTABLISHED AND REGULATIONS. BY
CODIFYING THE REGULATION AND
LICENSING AGENCIES HAVE CLEAR
ASSURANCE ON HOW TO IMPLEMENT
STATE LAW AND CANNABIS LIKE
THESE WILLCONTINUE TO
ADVERTISE ON BILLBOARDS IN
ACCORDANCE WITH THE STATE
STRICT ADVERTISING CALLED A
STRONGLY REGULATED CANNABIS
INDUSTRY IS ONE OF CALIFORNIA'S
PRIMARY TOOL TO REDUCE ILLICIT
CANNABIS ACTIVITY AND PROTECT
YOU FROM ACCESSING CANNABIS
PRODUCTS BEFORE THE AGE OF
TWENTY ONE WE STRONGLY SUPPORT
THE BILL AND RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST. YOUR IDOL TODAY THANK
YOU. THE YOU MR AND SORRY NEXT
WILL TO MISS DE LOPER WITH THE
CALIFORNIA. OUTDOOR INTO AS-
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR WOULD
TELL STATE. OUT BECAUSE SEARCH.
OUR MEMBERS THE SMALL SUPPORT
COMPANIES IN CALIFORNIA ON
OUTDOOR ADVERTISING AND WE
REPRESENT ABOUT 90% OF THE
LICENSED OXIDES SIGNS FOR
MEMBER SUPPORTED BE THIRTEEN OH
TWO EVEN THOUGH NOT ALL KERRY
LICENSED CANNABIS SAYS. FINAL
ORDERS RECOGNIZE THAT BANNING
ADVERTISING FOR LEGAL PRODUCTS.
IS A THREAT TO ALL ADVERTISING.
I CANNOT TERRITORY EXTREMELY
RUDE RESTRICTED PRESS
CONFERENCE YOUR STANDARDS THAT
INCLUDE ZONING SIDE HI SPACING
LANDSCAPES AND CARS ARE WE
PROHIBITIONS. EXIST EXISTING
LAW PROHIBITS CANNABIS
ADVERTISING WITH ONE THOUSAND
FEET OF SCHOOLS PLAYGROUND YOU
CENTERS AND OTHER YOUTH MAGNET
LOCATIONS THIS IS A STRICT
MUSLIM. INTENTIONALLY OUT
COUNTRY. YOU KNOW TO HAVE NO
IMPACT ON THIS. CURRENT LOG.
IT'S THAT ADVERTISES A MOVE
MARKERS ADVERTISING LOCATED
INTERSTATE WE'RE THAT CROSSES
CALIFORNIA BORDER THIS SECTION
WAS IN OUR OUR PLEA DRAFTED.
APPLE SAID ARLENE SAID YOU'RE
NOT PROUD SUPPORTER WOULD BE
THE LOGICAL TO PREVENTABLE
BOARD OWNERS SAY FIVE LOS
ANGELES BECAUSE OF FIVE FIVE
CROSSES BORDERS. WHAT SO WHILE
ALLOWING BILLBOARDS ON OTHER
HIGHWAYS NOW INCLUDING. SIXTEEN
FOUR OH FIVE AND MANY OTHERS.
THE ONLY ONE ANSWER PROP SIX IS
LANGUAGE WAS LIMIT ADVERTISING
ON SIGNS THAT WOULD BE READ BY
TRAVELS ACROSS THE BORDER. WE
BELIEVE AT THE TIME OF THIS
THAT- CANNABIS WAS NOT LEGAL IN%
AND- IN CORRESPONDENCE. WHICH
IS NOW RESEARCH OH TWO WHAT'S
ALL THE SUPERIOR COURT'S
CONCERN BY COVERING TE
REGULATIONS AGAINST REGULATIONS
THAT CHALLENGE BUT OUT OF THIS
WORLD TOUR INDUSTRIES ON
CONSTITUTIONAL GROUNDS AS THE
COURT SAID WE DIDN'T HAVE
STANDING SINCE IT WAS A- OF. BY
THE C. SIX. THE CLOSING WILL
WHAT RESTAURANT SUPER ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS REGARDS TO
COUNSEL. CHALFORD THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MR LOPER REPEATED THE
TESTIMONY- SO MODERATOR WE
WOULD LIKE TO GO TO NEXT TO ANY
OTHER WITNESSES WHO LIKE TO
PORT EIGHTY THIRTEEN OH TWO
PLEASE. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
AND LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO SIT. ABC THIRTEEN OH
TWO YOU MAY PRESS ONE AT THAT.
AT THIS TIME. NINE ONE OH NINE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
RANDY MARTIN ON BEHALF OF CMG
KHALIFA ONE OF THE LARGEST
CANNABIS COMPANIES IN THE STATE
I'M IN VERY STRONG SUPPORT OF
AB THIRTEEN OH TWO THANK YOU.
FIND ONE OF SEVEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING CONNECTED ABOUT THREE
STRATEGIES ON BEHALF OF GENERAL
AFTER ADVOCATING LAMAR
ADVERTISING AND BEAL OUTDOOR
ADVERTISING AND TRUMP SUPPORT
AT E. B. THIRTEEN OF HIM THANK
YOU. LINE ONE SIXTEEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. SH THE
MORNING AND THANK YOU I'M DAVID
NELSON- DOCTOR POSTED
CALIFORNIA ASIAN PACIFIC
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE SUPPORTS
HEALTH CANADA'S BUSINESS
DISTRIBUTING MANY SOCIAL AGREED
BUSINESSES AND WE SUPPORT AB WE
APOLOGIZE. FOR EIGHTY ONE THREE
ZERO ZERO. ONE ONE FOURTEEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR
MY NAME IS DAVID GOLDMAN I AM
THE PRESIDENT OF THE SAN
FRANCISCO CHAPTER OF PRIMARY
DEMOCRATIC CLUB ON BEHALF OF
OUR CLUB WHAT CALLING IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF EIGHTY THIRTEEN OH
TWO. THANK YOU. NINE ONE
FIFTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES GOOD
MORNING THANK YOU CHAIR AND
MEMBERS MY NAME IS CLINT
OLIVIER I'M THE CEO OF CENTRAL
VALLEY BUSINESS THAT WE WERE ON
A BUSINESS COALITION LETTER
SUPPORTING AB THIRTEEN OH TWO
BUT WE ALSO WANTED TO ADD THAT
WE ALSO SUPPORT THIS ON BEHALF
OF OUR SEVENTY MEMBERS. THANK
YOU. NINE SIXTY ONE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
MORTY AREA REPRESENTING ME IN
THE DISTRIBUTION AND A MEMBER
OF THE LEGAL CANNABIS FOR
CONSUMER SAFETY COALITION I'M
PRESENTING ON BEHALF OF OUR
LARGE COALITION LICENSED
CANNABIS BUSINESSES AND
ORGANIZATIONS SUCH AS TAX
MARIJUANA POLICY PROJECT
SURELY. FIFTY FIVE OTHER
BUSINESSES AND ORGANIZATIONS IN
SUPPORT OF EIGHTEEN THIRTEEN OF
TAIL THANK YOU. NINE SIXTY TWO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING CHAIR AND
MEMBERS MY NAME IS PATRICIA
BRUNO AND I AM REPRESENTING THE
ALLEY CHAMBER OF COMMERCE WITH
OUR FOURTEEN HUNDRED BUSINESS
MEMBERS ARE CHAMBER STRONGLY
SUPPORT AT THIRTEEN OKAY THANK
YOU. NINE ONE THIRTEEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR CHRIS
WILTON BLOCK GRANTS WITH CONNIE
BUSINESS FEDERATION PALLY BIS
SAID IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
EIGHTY THIRTEEN OH TWO THANK
YOU. NINE FIFTY NINE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. SHARKS
SHARKS WILL BE USED TO IT NOW
DUE TO THE STRONG SUPPORT OF
EIGHTY THIRTEEN OH TWO. AND ONE
MOMENT. NINE ONE TWENTY TWO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MY NAME'S WALKED%
WATCHING ON THE RADIO AND CO
FOUNDER OF DRUMS MINORITY ON
CAMPUS BRAND BASED IN LOS
ANGELES WE STRONGLY URGE THE
COMMITTEE IN PAST EIGHTY
THIRTEEN OH TWO. ONE ONE TWENTY
FOUR YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. ONE TWENTY FOUR YOU
MAY BE ON MUTE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. NEXT COMMENT PLEASE. ONE
MOMENT WHILE WE GATHER THE LINE
NUMBER. IT IS THE LAST COMMENT
IN QUEUE AT THIS TIME OKAY JUST
A BRIEF MOMENT WHILE WE GATHER
THAT LINE NUMBER. WE DO HAVE A
NINE ONE TWENTY FOUR. PLEASE GO
AHEAD YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THANK
YOU FOR NOT MENTIONING THE
CUSTOM LEVEL I'M REPRESENTING
THE SOCIAL EQUITY LICENSE KIND
OF THE FRIEND ZONE WE STRONGLY
URGE THE COMMITTEE TO PASS A.
B. ONE THREE ZERO PM. AND MINE
ONE SEVENTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINE ONE
SEVENTEEN YOU MAY BE ON MUTE
PLEASE GO AHEAD YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HI MY NAME IS TONY BOWLS
ON BEHALF OF THE BAY AREA
CHAPTER OF AMERICANS FOR SAFE
ACCESS. I'D LIKE TO SAY I
SUPPORT. EIGHTY THIRTEEN OH
TWO. WE HAVE NO FURTHER COMMENT
IN Q. THANK YOU MODERATOR- SO
WE CONCLUDED OUR CONFERENCE
LINE AND SUPPORT DO WE HAVE
ANYONE IN THE GALLERY IN
SUPPORT OF AB THIRTEEN OH TWO.
SEE NONE WE'LL GO O ROOM ONE
TWELVE SEE NONE. SO NOW WE'LL
MOVE ON TO OPPOSITION- WE DO
HAVE THE OPPOSITION WE HAVE
LYNN SILVER PUBLIC HEALTH
INSTITUTE ON THE COASTLINE- AND
WE ALSO HAVE PHILIP DRUM AN
INDIVIDUAL. ALSO ON THE CO HOST
LINE- MODERATOR WILL PLEASE
START WITH A MISSILE FOR. CAN
YOU HEAR ME YES I CAN'T. MADAM
CHAIR SENATORS GOOD MORNING I'M
DR LINDA SOBER PEDIATRICIANS
FIGHTERS LIKE HELP. WITH A FULL
PROFESSOR AT THE UCSF THERE ARE
FOUR REASONS WHY YOU SHOULD
OPPOSE THIS BILL. FIRST IT IS
NOT A PERMISSIBLE AMENDED A
PROP SIXTY FOUR AT THE BREAK
THE PROBLEM IS CLEARLY MADE TO
THE VOTERS THAT WE WOULD HAVE
THE NATION'S STRICTEST CHILD
PROTECTION. LEGAL ADVISER MR
MICHAEL COHEN TO KNOW A WIDELY
RESPECTED ATTORNEY REVIEW THE
ISSUE IN A MEMO SHARED WITH
YOUR OFFICES AND CONCLUDED A.
B. THIRTEEN OH TO EXCEED THE
LEGISLATORS LEGISLATURES
AUTHORITY BECAUSE IT
CONTRAVENES WE'VE DEALT WITH
MARIJUANA TAX PROCEEDS TO
PREVENT BILLBOARD ADVERTISING
OF CANNABIS ON AN INTERSTATE.
OR ON A STATE HIGHWAY. SECOND
DURING THE PREVIOUS HEARING
BEGIN TO DATE UNDER ITS WORKING
FOR BUT NORTHERN STATES BANNED
CANNABIS BILLBOARD ADVERTISING
IS INACCURATE WE REVIEWED THE
LAWS OF OTHER STATES CAN FIND
THE LACK OF MEANINGFUL WHY IN
VERMONT AND ALL BILLBOARDS NEW
YORK OHIO RHODE ISLAND AND
VIRGINIA FAN DON'T BOARD
MONTANA FLORIDA MISSOURI
CONNECTICUT AND NEW MEXICO
ATTENTION WE DO SO THROUGH
ADVERTISING RESTRICTIONS THAT
MAKE CERTAIN INCREMENTS FOR.
OUTDOOR ADVERTISING WORKS
EFFECTIVELY TO HOOK KIT
INCREASES INTEREST IN USE AND
POSITIVE PERCEPTIONS OF HARMFUL
PRODUCTS A RECENT STUDY OF
FIFTEEN TO NINETEEN YEAR OLD
CANNABIS USERS QUITE STATE
INCLUDING OURS FOUND THAT
EXPOSURE TO CANNABIS BILLBOARDS
EVEN ONLY OCCASIONALLY HAD A
STRONG INSIGNIFICANT
RELATIONSHIP TO FREQUENT USE
AND ADDICTION COULD HAPPEN ON
THE CANNABIS USE DISORDER
SCHLAFLY INCREASED CANNABIS USE
DIRECTLY CONTRIBUTES TO
INCREASED MOTOR VEHICLE CRASHES
INCLUDING FATAL ONES WHY ALLOW
ADVERTISING ON HIGHWAYS FOR
MORE ACCIDENTS. IT TOOK DECADES
IN THE TOBACCO MASTER
SETTLEMENT AGREEMENT TO GET THE
MARLBORO MAN OFFER HIGHLY WHY
LEGISLATE TO BRING HIS CANNABIS
CURTAINS BACK AND MISSILE
RECORDING RAP A MINUTE SO IT
LIKE TO ENSURE THAT YOU'RE
WRAPPING UP HERE SO WE CAN.
ENSURE THAT MR TRUMP HAS. I'M
WRAPPING UP LEGAL INDUSTRY CAN
OPERATE WELL IN. AND AT.
WITHOUT THE AND THEY WILL NOT
SOLVE PROBLEM OF THE ILLICIT
MORE FOR EQUITY WE RISK. ASK
THAT YOU CALL TRUE TO THE-
PROTECT OUR KIDS INVOKE ME
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MR. OUR
NEXT WE ACTUALLY MISS DRUM IN.
PERSON HERE'S MR DRUMMING UP
TWO MINUTES PLEASE GO AHEAD
YOU'RE NOT POSITION. SENATORS
ON THE PHARMACIST AND WAS
PLACED AS A CONTENT EXPERT
MEMBER ON THE PROP SIXTY FOUR
SENATE BILL NINETY FOUR
MANDATED REVIEW OF IMPAIRED
DRIVING IN CALIFORNIA WITH THE
CHP. NURSE ROSEMARY TEMPLE WAS
KILLEDIN A VEHICLE BY A
SPEEDING DRIVER WHO WAS A TWO
TIME FELON WITH MULTIPLE
MARIJUANA D. WEISS WAS UNDER
THE INFLUENCE OF ONLY
MARIJUANA. CAN CAUSE THEM A CAR
PILE UP THE DETECTIVE TESTIFIED
HE SAW MARIJUANA AND MARIJUANA
DISPENSARY CARDS FALL OUT OF
THE MURDERS CAR WHEN BEING
OPERATED. ROSE MARIE WAS MY
MUCH LOVED SISTER. SINCE HER
MURDER THE OVERWHELMING
CONCLUSION TO DRAW FROM MY NEAR
DECADE LONG INVOLVEMENT WITH
THIS ISSUE IS THAT LESS NOT
MORE MARIJUANA WOULD MAKE
ROADWAYS SAFER FOR THE PUBLIC.
MARIJUANA IS THE SECOND MOST
COMMON SUBSTANCE FOUND IN FATAL
D. Y. CASES THE COLORADO
DEPARTMENT OF TRANSPORTATION
HAS REPORTED THE INCIDENCE OF
MARIJUANA POSITIVITY IN FATAL
CRASHES HAS GONE FROM 6% IN TWO
THOUSAND AND SIX. 23% IN TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN MARIJUANA
POSITIVE DRIVERS PUT THEMSELVES
OTHER DRIVERS PEDESTRIANS
CYCLISTS AND THEIR PASSENGERS
AT RISK IN A RECENT STUDY BY
CAMERON THE JOURNAL OF AMERICAN
MEDICAL ASSOCIATION THE
ESTIMATED ADDITIONAL. SEVEN
HUNDRED DEATHS WILL OCCUR IN
CALIFORNIA DUE TO PROP SIXTY
FOUR THIS IS ABOVETHE TWO
HUNDRED AND TWENTY MARIJUANA
POSITIVE DRIVING DOES SEEM IN
CALIFORNIA IN TWENTY SIXTEEN
BEFORE PROP SIXTY FOUR WAS
APPROVED. MARIJUANA FOR MEDICAL
PURPOSES WAS LEGALIZED IN
CALIFORNIA TWENTY FIVE YEARS
AGO AND NOTHING HAS BEEN DONE
TO PROTECT CALIFORNIANS AGAINST
MARIJUANA POSITIVE DRIVERS
ADDRESSING THE RECOMMENDATIONS
OF THE JANUARY TWENTY TWENTY
ONE C. H. P. TASK FORCE. MUST
BE THE PRIORITY OF THE SENATOR
S. COMMITTEE. THE PERMISSIONS
OF MORE. ON ALL FREEWAYS WILL
INCREASE THE USE OF THE VERY
NATURE OF ADVERTISING IS TO
GENERATE SALES. EVEN TO TWO
CHILDREN RECENTLY THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA PASSED LEGISLATION
TO REDUCE ACCESS TO MARIJUANA.
THE ILLEGAL MARIJUANA MARKET
CONTINUES TO UNDERCUT THE
REGULATED PRICE OF THE LEGAL
MARKET AND HAS EXPLODED IN
EVERY STATE THAT HAS LEGALIZED
MARIJUANA I HEARD YOU. IN THE
MEMORY OF MY SISTER TO VOTE TO
OPPOSE A BI. FOR PUBLIC SAFETY
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER JOHN
WE APPRECIATE YOUR TESTIMONY
WILL POP WE ALSO OFFER
CONDOLENCES AS WELL. ALL RIGHTS
THANK YOU- WE'VE CONCLUDED
OPPOSITION LEADER- TESTIMONY
THERE SO WE'LL GO TO THE
MODERATOR BACK TO YOU IS THERE
ANYONE ELSE IN OPPOSITION. TO
AB THIRTEEN OH TWO PLEASE.
THANK YOUMADAM CHAIR AND
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF
AB THIRTEEN OH TWO YOU MAY
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. NINE ONE ELEVEN. YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD
THANK YOU GOOD MORNING TURN
NUMBERS NOT ON PAPER WITH ME
OFTEN MARKS MARA BEHALF OF
CONTRA COSTA COUNTY AND
RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION THANK YOU
ALL. NINE ONE EIGHTEEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO JUDY STRING ON BEHALF OF
CCP CALIFORNIA CONCERNED
PARENTS WHO FEEL CHEATED THAT
PROP SIXTY FOUR DID NOT PROTECT
OUR CHILDREN AS WE HAD HOPED TO
TAKE A EXAM AN ORGANIZATION AT
THIS TIME AND JUST WHETHER
YOU'RE IN OPPOSITION OR NOT TO
A. B. THIRTEEN OH TWO THANK YOU.
AN OPPOSITION THANK THE THANK
YOU. WHAT. NINE ONE TWENTY ONE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME IS PAMELA
MCCALL I'M WITH THE DRUG
PREVENTION NETWORK AND I AM THE
STATUS MEMBER WITH UNITED
NATIONS OFFICE OF. A CRIME AND
DRUGS AND WE OPPOSE THIS BILL
AND WE SUPPORT THE U. N. BAN ON
THE TOTAL BAN OF CANNABIS
ADVERTISEMENT. THANK YOU NEXT
COMMENT PLEASE. NINE ONE TEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME IS-
STORIES ON THE ATTORNEY IN THE
CASE OF A FARMER VERSUS EURO
CANS CONTROL REPRESENT THE
HUNDREDS OF CHILDREN PARENTS
AND CENTRAL COAST CANNABIS%
INJURY HAS PLENTY OF OTHER
WE'RE JUST- TAKING NAME AND-
ORGANIZATION PLEASE. SORROW
RIZZO- ATTORNEY IN THE CASE OF
FARMERS THE BUREAU KENNISON
TROLL I- CALLED IN OPPOSITION
TO ONE THREE ZERO TWO THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT
COMMENT PLEASE. NINE ONE OH ONE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO KEEP YOUR STRENGTH
THE KING OF DIRECTOR WITH THE
SAN MARCOS PREVENTION COALITION
IN VERY STRONG OPPOSITION THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU NEXT
COMMENT. TWENTY ONE TWENTY YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THE CAP LIMITED ON BEHALF OF
COASTAL COMMUNITY COALITION
AGAINST DRUGS. AND I AM AGAINST
WE ARE AGAINST THIS VERY
STRONGLY AGAINST THIS BILL IT
IS THANK YOU WERE JUST. AN
ORGANIZATION AT THIS TIME THANK
YOU. THANK YOU NEXT COMMENT
PLEASE. TWENTY ONE TWENTY YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK. TWENTY ONE TWENTY YOUR
NINE ONE TWENTY EIGHT YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO
THIS IS KELLY MCCORMICK
REPRESENTING HEALTH ADVOCATES
OPPOSED TO MARIJUANA AND WE ARE
IN OPPOSITION TO THE BILL.
THANK YOU NINE THIRTY FOUR YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI MY NAME IS RJ CONCERN ON-
POLICY RESEARCH ASSOCIATE AT
THE PUBLIC HEALTH INSTITUTE AND
I'M COMING IN OPPOSITION TO AB
ONE THREE OH TWO THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NINE NINETY FOUR YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS JOE
EVER SIGN ON THE PROGRAM
MANAGER FOR THE SAN DIEGO
COUNTY MARIJUANA. INITIATIVE
AND I OPPOSE THE NEED- KEYNOTE.
LINE ONE THIRTY YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY
NAME IS CAROL GREEN I'M FROM
THE SAN DIEGO AREA I HAVE THREE
CHILDREN I OPPOSE. THAT TELL.
WE HAVE NO FURTHER COMMENT IN
Q. OKAY THANK YOU MODERATOR
WE'VE CONCLUDED THE CONFERENCE
LINE IN OPPOSITION TO IS THERE
ANYONE ELSE IN THE GALLERY
WOULD LIKE TO POSE A. B.
THIRTEEN OF TWO. THREE NINE
ROOM. ONE TWELVE THIRTY NINE.
WE'LL TAKE IT BACK TO MEMBERS
ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS- FOR
THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER. OKAY YOU
SEE NOT AT THIS TIME ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
YES ON AGAIN THANKS VERY MUCH
FOR HEARING THIS BILL- I'D LIKE
TO EMPHASIZE THAT. CHILDREN
HAVE BEEN GETTING- MARIJUANA
CANNABIS FOR YEARS FIVE A FORTY
YEAR OLD DAUGHTER AND A THIRTY
FOUR YEAR OLD SON MY DAUGHTER
WAS EXPOSED TO CANNABIS WHILE
IN HIGH SCHOOL BEING SOLD ON
OUR CAMPUS MY SON WAS EXPOSED
TO A MIDDLE SCHOOL. THIS IS
BECAUSE WE HAVE AN ILLEGAL
INDUSTRY. WE ARE PREVENTING THE
LEGAL INDUSTRY WHICH DOES NOT
SELL TO CHILDREN FROM
FLOURISHING IF WE KEEP THIS BAN
ON I. TEN I. EIGHTY I. FIVE. SO
I WOULD JUST ASK YOU TO HELP US
SUPPORT THE LEGAL INDUSTRY.
I'LL ALSO POINT OUT THAT WHAT
CAN BE PUT ON THESE BILLS
BILLBOARDS IS HIGHLY REGULATED
NOTHING THAT APPEAL TO CHILDREN
CAN DO IT FURTHERMORE 72% OF
THE PEOPLE WHO THE REGULATION
IS SUCH THAT 72% AT LEAST OF
THE PEOPLE WHO SEE THIS HAVE TO
BE ADULTS- WE BELIEVE. THAT IT
IS VERY ARD TO INTERPRET. A
BILL WHICH AS YOU CAN ADVERTISE
ON THE STATE HIGHWAY. THAT
CROSSES THE BORDER WHEN NO
STATE HIGHWAY DOES. WE DON'T
THINK THAT WHOEVER PUT THAT IN.
HAD ANY INTENTION OF ALLOWING-
THE ADVERTISEMENTS ON THE FOUR
OH FIVE FOUR EIGHTY EIGHTY BUT
NOT ON EIGHTY FOUR NOT ON FIVE.
SO WHAT'S THERE IT'S VERY HARD
TO INTERPRET WE THINK THAT THE-
AGENCY IN CHARGE GOT THIS RIGHT
WHICH IS WHY WE'RE PROPOSING
THIS. AND AGAIN WE DON'T KNOW
WHAT WHOEVER PUT THAT IN HAD
MINE BECAUSE IT SIMPLY WASN'T.
PUT DOWN. HAVING GONE THROUGH A
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS I DOUBT
ANYTHING WITHOUT WORDING WOULD
HAVE GOT THROUGH. SO I THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
ATTENTION- WHEN THERE WERE ALSO
SOME STUDIES ABOUT THIS AND
THAT AND CLAIMS- I COULD JUST
SAY THAT CORRELATION IS NOT THE
SAME AS CAUSATION. I CAN SAY
THAT THERE ARE LOTS OF STUDIES
THAT SHOW IN FACT THAT CANNABIS
IS NOT- SOMETHING WHICH- ARE
IMPAIRED DRIVERS SHOULD ANYWAY
I LIKE THE WAY HAT- CANADA
THAT ALCOHOL DOES. I COULD SURE
USE STUDIES AND ALL SORTS OF
THINGS BUT RIGHT NOW WHAT I'M
ASKING IS THAT WE SUPPORT THE
LEGAL INDUSTRY SO WILL OUT
COMPETE THE ILLEGAL INDUSTRY
WHICH SELLS TO OUR KIDS THAT'S
THE BOTTOM LINE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FOR MAKING THAT A
CLARIFICATION ASSEMBLY MEMBER
AND I KNOW YOU'VE BEN VERY
MINDFUL TO THIS PROCESS THANK
YOU FOR WORKING WITH OUR
COMMITTEE AS WELL- MISTER CHIEF
CONSULTANT OF FIRST OFF TO HAVE
A MOTION ON A. B. THIRTEEN OF
TWO SENATOR MCCASKEY THANK YOU-
MISTER CHIEF CONSULTANT CAN YOU
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AND REFERRED
TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS. SENATOR
GONZALEZ HI THE DOLLAR SIGN
BATES. HELEN SUCH A LETTER.
BECKER CORTESE. DOLLY DOLLY NO
DOT DOT HI WHAT. LATEST LINDA
IS NOW. MAN MAN I NEWMAN EWMAN
I REBUILT. SKINNER HUMBERT HI
CASCADE CASCADE HIGH BOOK. FIVE
TWO OKAY THANK YOU SOMEONE
NUMBER WILL KEEP THE BILL ON
CALL THANK- THANK YOU NEXT WE
HAVE ASSEMBLY MEMBER BERMAN-
FILE ITEM NINE THAT IS. EIGHTY
SEVEN NINETY SIX. GREAT WELCOME
ASSEMBLY MEMBER AND WE HAVE A
MOTION BY SENATOR MCCASKEY
THANK YOU MATT INSURANCE AND
THERE'S A B. SEVENTY SIX SIX TO
IMPROVE AND REFINE THE
CALIFORNIA NEW MOTOR VOTER
PROGRAM. TO ENSURE ITS
CONTINUED SUCCESS AND
EFFECTIVENESS WHEN CALIFORNIA
LAUNCHED THE NEW MOTOR VOTER
PROGRAM IN APRIL TWENTY
EIGHTEEN IT BECAME THE LARGEST
AND ONE OF THE FIRST STATES TO
IMPLEMENT AUTOMATIC. VOTER
REGISTRATION TO THE DMV. NEW
MOTOR VOTER HAS MADE IT EASIER
FOR ELIGIBLE VOTERS TO REGISTER
OR UPDATE THEIR REGISTRATION
WHEN COMPLETING A DRIVER'S
LICENSE AND STATE
IDENTIFICATION CARD
APPLICATIONS. IT IS PLAYED AN
INSTRUMENTAL ROLE IN CLOSING
VOTER REGISTRATION GAPS. AS
WELL AS IMPROVING THE ACCURACY
OF VOTERS MAILING ADDRESSES
WHICH IS CRUCIAL TO INCREASING
ACCESS TO VOTE BY MAIL VOTING.
BETWEEN APRIL TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN IN JANUARY TWENTY
TWENTY ONE MORE THAN TWELVE
MILLION NEW OR UPDATED VOTER
REGISTRATIONS RESULTED FROM THE
NEW MOTOR VOTER PROGRAM.
DESPITE THE SUCCESSES
CHALLENGES WITH MODERNIZING THE
MOTOR VOTER REGISTRATION
PROCESS. CONTINUE TO LIMIT THE
PROGRAM'S EFFECTIVENESS. AT ITS
HEART A. B. SEVENTY SIX WOULD.
APPLY LESSONS LEARNED AND ADOPT
FEDERAL MOTOR VOTER TIMELINES
FOR CAP THE TRANSMITTAL. OF
VOTER REGISTRATION INFORMATION
FROM THE DMV TO THE SECRETARY
OF STATE. AS WELL AS CODIFIED
NUMBER BEST PRACTICES FROM THE
ONGOING LEGAL SETTLEMENT
INCLUDING DATA REPORTING ON
PROCESSING TIMES. TRAINING OF
DMV AND SECRETARY OF STATE
STAFF. IN MAINTAINING
COORDINATORS AT THE DMV AND
SECRETARY OF STATE TO MONITOR
COMPLIANCE WITH THE FEDERAL AND
STATE. MOTOR VOTER LAWS. THIRTY
SEVEN NINETY SIX WILL ENSURE
THAT THE PROGRESS MADE UNDER
OUR NEW MOTOR VOTER PROGRAM
WILL CONTINUE. AND KEEP
CALIFORNIA'S VOTER ROLLS
ACCURATE AND UP TO DATE. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AND I VOTE
ON EIGHTY SEVEN NINETY SIX AND
WITH ME. OUR DOOR ROSE ON
BEHALF OF THE LEAGUE OF WOMEN
VOTERS AND BRITNEY STONECIPHER.
ON BEHALF OF THE ACLU HAS
PRIMARY WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU ASSEMBLYMEMBER
MODERATOR CAN YOU ENSURE THAT
MIS ROSES ON THE LINE WITH THE
LEAGUE OF WOMEN VOTERS. I'M
HERE. GOOD MORNING SURE DOES
LOVE THE NUMBERS UNDER ROSE
DEPUTY DIRECTOR WITH THE LEAGUE
OF WOMEN VOTERS IN CALIFORNIA.
AB SEVENTY SIX ACTUALLY
TRANSPONDERS BY THREE GOOD
GOVERNMENT ORGANIZATIONS ONLY
COME ACROSS CALIFORNIA AND THE
ACLU CALIFORNIA ACTUALLY. THE
BUILDER CENTRAL TO OUR SHARED
MISSION BECAUSE LITERALLY
STRETCHING OUT HELLO. CHUCK
SPAN BUILDING ACCESS. AND
ULTIMATELY. TO CREATE A MORE
REPRESENTATIVE WILL ACTUALLY.
QATAR HAS BEEN PRACTICE USUALLY
TO COUNSEL MOTOR VOTER PROGRAM
MOST OF WHICH YOU'VE BEEN
INCREASED SINCE TWENTY EIGHTEEN
PURSUANT TO LEGAL SETTLEMENT
AGREEMENTS CONTRACTUALLY SET TO
EXPIRE IN EARLY TWENTY TWENTY
TWO. THE NEW MOTOR VOTER
PROGRAM TO STREAMLINE THE VOTER
REGISTRATION PROCESS IT MADE IT
MORE CONVENIENT TO REGISTER OR
UPDATE VOTER REGISTRATIONS AND
GOING THROUGH. A DRIVER'S
LICENSE OR ID TRANSACTIONS AT
THE DMV. SINCE THE ROLLOUT OF
THE PROGRAM THREE YEARS AGO
THERE'S BEEN ALMOST FOURTEEN
MILLION NEW OR UPDATED VOTER
REGISTRATION BUT THE IN THE
INDIAN OCEAN ABOUT. TWELVE
MILLION- MENTIONED IN THE LAST
YEAR THAT INCLUDES ABOUT TEN
AND A HALF MILLION UPDATED
REGISTRATIONS IN ABOUT THREE
AND A HALF MILLION NEW VOTERS
BEING ADDED TO THE WALL. SO
pUP THE HIGHEST THE REGISTRATION
RATE IN RECENT HISTORY 88% OF
OUR ELIGIBLE POPULATIONS. HOW
DESPITE THESE ADVANCES. MORE
THAN TWO MILLION ELEGY ADULTS
REMAIN UNREGISTERED AND
UNFORTUNATELY A
DISPROPORTIONATE NUMBER THOSE
PEOPLE ARE FROM
UNDERREPRESENTED GROUPS SO.
WE'VE GOT TO CLOSE THAT GAP TO
REFLECT THE REALITY OF OUR
STATE'S DIVERSE DEMOGRAPHICS TO
MOVE. BEYOND WHAT YOU KNOW FOR
DOMINO LIKE OLDER WHITE ACTOR.
THE GUY WAS SURE THAT THE G. IN
THE PROCESS CONTINUES TO
IMPROVE THE ACCURACY OF OUR
VOTER ROLLS SOMETHING THAT IS.
INCREASINGLY IMPORTANT ACTUALLY
IS MORE CALIFORNIA YOU KNOW.
POSSIBLY ALL OF THOSE. SOON
WE'RE GONNA BE RECEIVING ABOUT.
WHICH IS TO BACKS ON THE- THESE
SHOULD BE THE CATCH IS. I DON'T
AGREE. WE GOT A THE MORE TOWARD
MARK DEMOCRACY. SO WE URGE YOU
TO APPEAR EITHER. THANK YOU.
THANK MISS ROSE SWEEPING THE
TESTIMONY AND NEXT WE HAVE
BRITNEY'S STONECIPHER WITH THE
ACLU IN SUPPORT OF SB. SEVEN
NINETY SIX. GOOD MORNING MY
NAME IS BERNIE FOUND FAVOR AND
I WITH ACLU OF NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA A PROUD CO SPONSOR
OF EIGHTY SEVEN NINETY SIX.
ACLU IN OUR PARTNERS HAS SPENT
MANY YEARS ADVOCATING TO
INCREASE THE FAIRNESS AND
EFFICIENCY OF THE MOTOR VOTER
SYSTEM. IN RECENT YEARS THE
ADVOCACY HAS TAKEN THE FORM OF
THE SETTLEMENT AGREEMENT THAT
THE DMV AND THE SECRETARY OF
STATE. UNDER THAT SETTLEMENT
PNB AND THE SECTOR AND THEN
PROVIDING DETAILED MONTHLY
REPORT ABOUT THE PROCESSING OF
VOTER REGISTRATION APPLICATIONS
AT THE M. B. AS WELL AS
REGULARLY. MEETING WITH THIS
GUY THIS REPORT. THE
TRANSPARENT AND ACCOUNTABILITY
THAT THESE REQUIREMENTS HAVE
CREATED A DMB. ALLOWED
STAKEHOLDERS TO IDENTIFY
COLLAPSE AND COLLABORATIVE LEE
RESOLVED SYSTEMIC ISSUES THAT
ARE DELAYING THE REGISTRATION.
IT ALSO SIGNIFICANTLY IMPROVED
CALIFORNIA'S COMPLIANCE WITH
STATE AND FEDERAL ELECTIONS
WELL. UNFORTUNATELY HOWEVER
THESE REQUIREMENTS WHICH HAVE
BEEN SO CRITICAL TO
TRANSFORMING THE MOTOR VOTER
PROGRAM INTO THE SUCCESS IT IS
TODAY WILL EXPIRE IN EARLY
TWENTY TWENTY TALE. EIGHTY
SEVEN NINETY SIX WILL CODIFY
BEST PRACTICES ALREADY IN PLACE
AT THE DMV AND RESULT THAT
CUSTOMER. AND CREATE MORE
CLARITY AND CONSISTENCY ACROSS
THE N. B. WORKSTREAM. EITHER
COMMON SENSE PROVISIONS LIKE
REQUIRING DMB TO CONTINUE
TRACKING AND REPORTING
REGISTRATION PROCESSING TIME.
REQUIRING THE SECRETARY INDIAN
B. TO TRAIN RELEVANT STUFF AND
HOW THE MOTOR VOTER SYSTEM MARK.
BY CLEARLY DEFINING TIMELINES
FOR DMB TO PROCESS MOTOR VOTER
RECORDS. THE BILL ALSO ENSURE
THAT ELIGIBLE INDIVIDUALS ARE
NOT DISENFRANCHISED BECAUSE A
BACKLOG IN THE IN THE MAIL ROOM
OR ADMINISTRATIVE RED TAPE.
DESPITE THE SIGNIFICANT
ACHIEVEMENTS OF THE MOTOR VOTER
PROGRAM MORE MUST BE DONE TO
PERMANENTLY SECURE RECENT
IMPROVEMENT AND CAN BRING THREE
MILLION ELIGIBLE BUT
UNREGISTERED CALIFORNIANS INTO
OUR DEMOCRACY. EIGHTY SEVEN
NINETY SIX OF THE PRACTICAL
GOOD GOVERNMENT MEASURE AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK DERIVE. THANK
YOU THANK YOU- IS STILL SAFER
WE APPRECIATE THAT- WILL NEXT
TAKE IT TO THE SUPPORT LINE ANY
OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF
EIGHTEEN SEVEN NINETY SIX AND
BEFORE WE DO THAT I'M GOING TO
HEAD OUT TO PRESENT SOME BILLS
ARE GOING TO PASS THE BATON
OVER. TO OUR VICE CHAIR SENATOR
BATES- BUT- MS MODERATOR IF YOU
CAN ENSURE THAT THEIR
SUPPORTERS ON THE LINE. THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR AND LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF EIGHTY SEVEN
NINETY SIX YOU MAY PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
NINE FIFTY SIX YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. MELISSA
ROMERO THE CALIFORNIA
CONSERVATION VOTERS IN SUPPORT.
NINE ONE THIRTY THREE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
TERRACE WITH DISABILITY RIGHTS
CALIFORNIA AND STRONG SUPPORT.
NINE THIRTY THREE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING THIS IS LUCY SALCEDO
CARTER WITH THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF NONPROFIT
SUPPORT. WE HAVE NO FURTHER
COMMENT FROM THE SUPPORT QUEUE.
THANK YOU HI AMANDA MODERATOR I
LET US GO TO THOSE WHO WISH TO
SPEAK. IN OPPOSITION TO AB
SEVEN NINETY SIX HONDA I DO NOT
SEE DO WE HAVE. TO FIND MY
PLACE HERE IF WE HAVE A. YEAH
NINE POINT OUT HERE. WE DO NOT
HAVE A LEADERSHIP POSITION SO-
WE WILL LOOK TO THE GALLERY TO
SEE IF THERE'S ANYONE PRESENT
THAT WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION. YOU DO NOT SEE
ANYONE IN THE GALLERY OR IN
ROOM ONE TWELVE ON THE SCREEN
THE ANALYTICS GO TO ALL THOSE
WHO MADE IT MAY WISH TO TESTIFY
IN OPPOSITION WHO ARE WAITING
ON THE TELECONFERENCE LINE NOT
A MODERATOR. I THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF SB SEVEN NINETY
SIX YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. ONCE AGAIN
IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION EIGHTY SEVEN NINETY
ZERO. WE HAVE NO ONE IN THE US
OPPOSITION TO A- IT'LL BRING IT
BACK TO COMMITTEE MEMBERS SIDE
ANY CALL CONCERNS COMMENTS
QUESTIONS THAT YOU WOULD LIKE
TO ASK OUR AUTHOR. US SENATOR
NEWMAN ED THANK YOU MEASURE-
ASSEMBLYMAN BERMAN WANNA
COMMEND YOU ON THIS LEGISLATION
AND RESPECTFULLY ASK UNITED AS
A CO AUTHOR IF AND WHEN THE
OPPORTUNITY ARISES AND WHEN THE
MOMENT YOU PROBABLY LIKE TO
MOVE THE BILL. THANK YOU
SENATOR. I DO NOT SEE ANY OTHER
HANDS. THEREFORE WE WILL TAKE
YOUR COMMENT SENATOR NEWMAN AS
A MOTION AND A YOU MAY CLOSE
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR JUST
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE.
FELTON PLEASE CALL THE VOTE.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AND
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS. CENTERS
GONZALEZ BATES NO NO HELEN.
SUCH A LETTER. BECKER CORTESE.
DOLLY ALI NO BUT DOT HIGH GLARE
MELINDA IT'S- MAN. NEWMAN
NEWMAN I REBUILT. SKINNER
NUMBER BY KASKADE KASKADE HIGH
LOOK. THREE TWO THEN WE'LL KEEP
THE ROLE OPEN THE CENTERS. AND
DO WE HAVE ANOTHER AUTHOR. HERE
ARE WE WERE AWAITING AUTHOR.
I'M. WE HAVE AN OFFICE
WAREHOUSE YES OKAY. I DIDN'T
WANT T DO THAT WE HAD SO MANY
MISSING. WELCOME TO A FAMILY
MEMBER ANDREAS AND I BELIEVE
THAT YOU WERE GOING TO PRESENT
AB THIRTEEN EIGHTY NINE. THAT
IS CORRECT MY ADDRESS THEN
PLEASE BEGIN. THANK YOU. EIGHTY
THIRTEEN EIGHTY NINE. WILL
MODERNIZE THE CALIFORNIA ENERGY
COMMISSION'S CLEAN
TRANSPORTATION PROGRAM. BY
REVISING THE PROGRAM TO SUPPORT
INFRASTRUCTURE NEEDS IN THE
CLEAN TRANSPORTATION SECTOR
INVESTMENTS IN OUR MOST
POLLUTED AREAS. THE CLEAN
TRANSPORTATION PROGRAM HAS BEEN
A CRITICAL TOOL TO ADVANCING
CLEAN VEHICLE TECHNOLOGY IN
CALIFORNIA THE PROGRAM IS
TECHNOLOGY AND FUEL NEUTRAL.
AND IS MEANT TO DEPLOY
INNOVATIVE TECHNOLOGIES THAT
TRANSFORM CALIFORNIA'S FUEL AND
VEHICLE TYPES. EIGHTY THIRTEEN
EIGHTY NINE WILL INCORPORATE
PROGRAM CHANGES THAT WILL FOCUS
INVESTMENTS IN. ONE ADDRESSING
INFRASTRUCTURE GAPS IN THE IN
THE CLEAN LIGHT DUTY VEHICLE
MARKET TO SUPPORT
INFRASTRUCTURE FOR THE EMERGING
CLEAN MEDIUM AND HEAVY DUTY
VEHICLE FREIGHT INDUSTRY. AND
THREE DEDICATE 5050% OF FUNDING
TO PROJECTS LOCATED IN AND
BENEFITING DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES AND LOW INCOME
COMMUNITIES. CALIFORNIA HAS
SOME OF THE WORST AIR QUALITY
IN THE COUNTRY MANY OF THESE
AIR POLLUTANTS COME FROM THE
TRANSPORTATION SECTOR THE SAN
JOAQUIN VALLEY AND THE SOUTH
COAST AIR BASIN ARE CURRENTLY
CLASSIFIED AS EXTREME NON
ATTAINMENT AREAS THE WORST
CLASSIFICATION. UNDER THE
FEDERAL CLEAN AIR ACT MANY
OTHER PARTS OF THE STATE SUCH
AS THE BAY AREA AND SACRAMENTO
RANGE FROM MODERATE TO SEVERE
NON ATTAINMENT. CLEANING UP THE
TRANSPORTATION SECTOR IS AT THE
INTERSECTION OF ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE AND ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT. URBANIZING THIS
INDUSTRY WILL HELP CLEAN THE
AIR FOR COMMUNITIES AND HELP
THE STATE MEET ITS CLIMATE
GOALS HERE TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL TODAY IS
MEREDITH ALEXANDER WITH CAL
START. HIS ALEXANDER'S HERE AND
PRESENT IN THE GALLERY A PLEASE
PROCEED WITH ALEXANDER. GOOD
MORNING CHAIRMAN WALLIS AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS I'M HERE TO
HELP XANDER POLICY DIRECTOR FOR
CAL START HERE IS THE SPONSOR
OF EIGHTY THIRTEEN EIGHTY NINE.
FIRST WE WISH TO THANK SENATOR
GONZALEZ FOR HER LEADERSHIP AND
OF COURSE ASSEMBLY MEMBER RAY
S. HER TEAM AND THE COMMITTEE
STAFF WHO WORKED HARD WITH US
ON THIS POLICY. CAN START AS A
MEMBER BASED NONPROFIT WITH
OVER TWO HUNDRED AND SEVENTY
MEMBERS DEDICATED TO
TRANSFORMING TRANSPORTATION.
INCLUDING VEHICLE MANUFACTURERS
ZERO EMISSION AN ALTERNATE FUEL
PRODUCERS PUBLIC AND PRIVATE
FLEETS AND MORE. THE ENERGY
COMMISSION'S CLEAN
TRANSPORTATION PROGRAM HAS BEEN
A CRITICALELEMENT OF OUR
STATE'S TRANSPORTATION CLEAN
AIR AND CLIMATE PROGRAMS. IT IS
TECHNOLOGY NEUTRAL AND HAS
HELPED ADVANCE VEHICLE AND
FEELING TECHNOLOGIES HOWEVER WE
PASSED MANY LANDMARK CLIMATE
LAWS SINCE THE PROGRAM WAS
ESTABLISHED ALMOST FIFTEEN
YEARS AGO. AND WE'VE ADOPTED
AMBITIOUS MANDATES FOR CLEAN
VEHICLES AND VEHICLE EMISSIONS
REDUCTION TARGETS. SO TO
REFLECT THESE NEW REALITIES IT
ONLY MAKES SENSE TO MODIFYING
THE STATUTE GUIDING THIS
PROGRAM TO ENSURE THAT IT
REFLECTS OUR GOALS. AND MARKET
TRENDS THIS BILL DOES JUST
THAT. FOR EXAMPLE THIS BILL
WILL ENSURE THAT WE'RE ABLE TO
ACCELERATE ZERO EMISSION CAR
TRUCK AND BUS ADOPTION. WHICH
IS WHY MANY EVEY AND HYDROGEN
FUEL CELL TRUCK AND BUS
MANUFACTURERS SUPPORT THIS
BILL. THIS BILL IS TECHNOLOGY
NEUTRAL AND FUEL NEUTRAL AND
DOES NOT INCLUDE CARVE OUTS FOR
SPECIFIC TECHNOLOGIES WHICH THE
MAJORITY OF STAKEHOLDERS AGREE
IS CRITICAL. THE RECENT
AMENDMENTS TAKE AN ADDRESS THE
NEED TO ENSURE EQUITABLE ACCESS
TO CHARGING INFRASTRUCTURE AND
CLEAN TRANSPORTATION. BY
ENSURING THAT HALF OF PROGRAM
FUNDS WILL BENEFIT
DISADVANTAGED AND LOW INCOME
COMMUNITIES IT'S FOR THESE
REASONS WE ARE HAPPY TO SPONSOR
THIS BILL. WE'RE COMMITTED TO
CONTINUING DISCUSSIONS WITH
STAKEHOLDERS TO MAKE FURTHER
ENHANCEMENTS WHILE KEEPING THE
BILL TECHNOLOGY NEUTRAL. THANK
YOU AND. WE RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR I. PHONE. THANK YOU
MISTER ALEXANDER I DO WE HAVE
ANY OTHER WAY. IAN'S HERE IN
THE GALLERY. CNE AND- THEN IN
ROOM ONE TWELVE SEE THAT UP YET.
CURRENTLY THERE ARE NINE THEN
ON MANTA MODERATOR WE WILL MOVE
TO THE TELECONFERENCE- THOSE
WISHING TO SUPPORT IN FOR ABC
THIRTEEN EIGHTY NINE DO WE HAVE
ANY IDEA WHO WERE WAITING TO
START TEST FIND SUPPORT ON THE
CONFERENCE LINE. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR AND LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF A. B. THIRTEEN
EIGHTY NINE YOU MAY PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
ONCE AGAIN. IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF A. B.
THIRTEEN EIGHTY NINE YOU MAY
PRESS ONE. AND THEN THERE ARE.
ONE MOMENT PLEASE. OUR FIRST
COMIC COMES FROM NINE FORTY
NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. THANK YOU TERRY
MEMBERS NIKITA KARATE BUT THE
NATURAL RESOURCES DEFENSE
COUNCIL INSTRUCTED FORTY EIGHT
THIRTEEN EIGHTY NINE AND THE
LIKE THANK YOU FROM A RADIUS OF
THE SPONSORS OF THE BILL. THE
MOST RECENT AMENDMENTS TO
STRENGTHEN THE EQUITY
CORRECTION TO DIRECTLY BENEFIT
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. NINE ONE THIRTY
SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. ONE ONE THIRTY SIX YOU
MAY BE ON MUTE PLEASE GO AHEAD
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. STILL THE
ONLY FISH ON BEHALF OF THE
ADVANCED ENERGY ECONOMY AND
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU. NINE
EIGHTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. JANET ****
SCORED THREE FIFTY SO I CAN
RALLY SUPPORT THANK YOU.
MODERATOR DO WE HAVE ANYONE YOU
DO GOING ON FINE ONE THIRTY
FIVE PM MAYBE A NEW PLEASE GO
AHEAD- SHE WAS SLIGHTLY
DIFFERENT FROM THE PORT OF THE
PHONE. NINE NINETY FIVE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI THERE WHEN JASPRIT STRING
SUPPORT FOR THE FOLLOWING
ORGANIZATIONS ELECTRIC VEHICLE
CHARGING ASSOCIATION A. B. B.
ABC COMPANY APTLY POWER ANAHEIM
TRANSPORTATION NETWORKS AND-
VALLEY TRANSIT AUTHORITY A
RIVAL BALLARD POWER SYSTEMS.
THEORIES CHANGE ENERGY EMAIL
GREENPOWER MOTOR COMPANY JB
POINDEXTER AND COMPANY MOMENTUM
DYNAMICS CORPORATION MOTIV
POWER SYSTEMS NICOLETTE
CORPORATION- DYING SYSTEMS
PHOENIX MOTORCARS PROTERRA
ELECTRIC. THE MY INSURANCE
AGENCY THE LINE ELECTRIC
COMPANY THE CLIMATE CENTER LOCK
THE ENERGY VOLVO. GROUP NORTH
AMERICA ALL IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. AND OUR LAST COMMENT COMES
FROM LINE ONE THIRTY SEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI THIS IS BILL MCGOVERN WITH
THE COALITION FOR CLEAN AIR AND
ALSO ON BEHALF OF THE CHARGE
AHEAD CALIFORNIA CAMPAIGN. IN
SUPPORT OF THE EIGHTY THIRTEEN
EIGHTY NINE AND- WE THANK
ASSEMBLYMEMBER REYES AND CAL
STAR. THANK YOU WITH NO NO
FURTHER COMMENT ON THE CASE.
THANK YOU WE DO NOT HAVE A
PRIME WITNESS- FOR US IN
OPPOSITION SO LET'S STAY ON THE
TELECONFERENCE LINE ARE THERE
ANY ARE INDVIDUALS ON NOT THE
TELECONFERENCE LINE THAT WOULD
LIKE TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION. TO
AB THIRTEEN EIGHTY NINE. THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR AND LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION OF AB THIRTEEN
EIGHTY NINE YOU MAY PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION OF EIGHTY
THIRTEEN EIGHTY NINE YOU MAY
PRESS ONE. AND THEN THERE. ONE
MOMENT WHILE WE GATHER THE LINE
NUMBERS. NINE ONE EIGHT YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU YOUR NUMBER'S JANA
SITUATED ON THE HELP OF THE
CALIFORNIA HYDROGEN COALITION
RESPECTIVELY IN A POSITION
BEING HERE. FIND ONE THIRTY
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN. I'M
SORRY ONE MOMENT PLEASE. THE
NINE ONE OH EIGHT YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. AND ONE MOMENT PLEASE
NINE ONE THIRTY EIGHT IF WE MAY
HAVE TO PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO
AGAIN PLEASE. NINE ONE THIRTY
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HELLO THIS IS
MARGARET CLANCY APOLOGY- I AM
NOT IN OPPOSITION I'M HERE ON
BEHALF OF MY COLLEAGUE CREATED
TO ADDRESS THE COURT IT'S
AMENDED ADDITION WE WOULD LIKE
TO SEE YOUR MISSION BRIDE
SHOULD YOUR EMISSIONS VEHICLE
RIDE SHARING ADDED TO THE BILL.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. AND WE
HAVE NO FURTHER COMMENT IN
QUEUE AT THIS TIME. THANK YOU
WE WILL LOOK TO THE GALLERY TO
SEE IF THERE'S ANYONE HERE IN
PERSON THAT WISHES TO TESTIFY
IN OPPOSITION. DO NOT SEE
ANYONE NOR IAN ROOM ONE TWELVE.
THEN WE WILL BRING IT BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE ANY QUESTIONS-
SENATOR WHITE COUNTY. YEAH
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR I'M- THE
STAFF REPORT HIGHLIGHTS ON PAGE
FOUR UNDER A POINT NUMBER
THREE- PROGRAM OUTCOMES AND
POLICIES AND AS OF LAST MAY
THEY INDICATE HOW MUCH IS IN
REFUELLING INFRASTRUCTURE
ALTERNATIVE FUEL VEHICLES AND
THEN THEY HAVE ALTERNATIVE FUEL
PRODUCTION THAT'S WHAT I WOULD
LIKE TO FOCUS IN ON WHAT MY
QUESTION IS 20% OF THE MONIES
NOW I HAVE BEEN AWARDED TO.
ALTERNATIVE FUEL PRODUCTION SO
NOW I'M ON THE- PAGE ELEVEN OF
THE BILL THIS IS STARTS UP WITH
SECTION THREE WHICH- BEGINS
WITH THIS INVESTMENT CYCLE IN
TWENTY TWENTY TO TWENTY TWENTY
FIVE TALKS ABOUT THE COMMISSION
SHALL EXPEND 50% OF THE MONEY
IS APPROPRIATED. THROUGH THIS
ALTERNATIVE FUEL PUMP PRODUCT
PROGRAMS THAT DIRECTLY BENEFIT
OR SERVE RESIDENTS A
DISADVANTAGE LOW INCOME
COMMUNITIES AND LOW INCOME
CALIFORNIANS AND AT LEAST 50%
OF THOSE LOW LOCATION BASED
INVESTMENTS THAT CAN BE
EXPANDED. IN DISADVANTAGED IN
LOW INCOME COMMUNITIES SO I SEE
THE VALUE IN THE LOCATION OF
ZEV CHARGING STATIONS AND ALL
THAT I'M LOOKING AT THE FUEL
PRODUCTION BECAUSE AT LEAST. IN
THE BAY AREA WE HAVE BECAUSE OF
A COASTAL BREEZE WE HAVE A LOT
OF AREAS WHERE THEY HAVE A
REFINERY THAT DOESN'T ACTUALLY
FALL INTO A QUOTE UNQUOTE.
ENVIRO SCREEN DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES WERE TRYING TO GET
DIFFERENT DIFFERENT DEFINITIONS
SO THAT. AND THEN I GUESS AT
SOME UNIVERSITIES OR SOMEBODY
WHO'S LOOKING TO ALT TO DEVELOP
ALTERNATIVE FUELS AND HAS. HAS
INVESTED IN ALTERNATIVE FUELS
THAT WAS WORKING WITH UC
RIVERSIDE OR UC DAVIS FARMERS
SAID THAT MIGHT NOT BE LOCATED
IN THE QUOTE UNQUOTE.
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES BUT
THAT'S THE FIGHT IS DEFINED BY
THE BY THE ENVIRO SCREEN SO
I'M- I'M WORRIED ABOUT IS THAT
GOING TO IT I GUESS EITHER THE
BILL WHAT I'M READING IT THIS
WILL ASKING QUESTIONS THAT THEY
WOULD NOT BE ENTITLED TO ANY OF
THIS MONEY FOR THE ALTERNATIVE
FUEL PRODUCTION. NOT THE BUT
THE LOCATION OF THE THINGS BUT
THE ACTUAL PRODUCTION BECAUSE
SOME OF THAT STUFF. IS NOT EASY
TO MOVE. AND I WOULD WONDER IF
THE AUTHOR OR- THE- UPSTART.
FOR HILLSIDE FAMILY MEMORY IF
WOULD YOU LIKE TO RESPOND TO
THAT IT'S A VERY GOOD QUESTION
I WOULD ASK DAD TO MEREDITH
ALEXANDER WOULD YOU ASSIST US
WITH THAT PLEASE. SURE HAPPY
TAIL HI AGAIN MEREDITH
ALEXANDER FOR CAL STAR- THANK
YOU SENATOR MURKOWSKI FOR THOSE
QUESTIONS SO. ONE THING OF NOTE
IS THAT THE CURRENT 20%
REQUIREMENT. IS FOR LIGHT DUTY
HYDROGEN FUELING- AND SO
FUELING STATION LOCATED IN A
DISADVANTAGE FOR LOW INCOME
COMMUNITY. WOULD COUNT TOWARDS
THAT 50% OF PHYSICAL
INVESTMENTS LOCATED IN ONE OF
THOSE COMMUNITIES SO.
NOTEWORTHY THAT IT IS NOT JUST
D. A. SEES AS DEFINED BY
CAROLINE VIRUS SCREEN BUT ALSO
LOW INCOME COMMUNITIES. AND WE
RECOGNIZE THAT NOT ALL- PROGRAM
EXPENDITURES YOU KNOW HOW THIS
LOCATION BASED ELEMENT. AND SO
THAT'S WHY WE'RE GIVING
GUIDANCE TO THE COMMISSION BUT
IF THIS IS SOME TANGIBLE
LOCATION BASED INVESTMENT. BUT
YOU LOOK AT ON BALANCE OVER
MULTIPLE YEARS PUTTING 50% OF
THE FUNDS INTO THOSE
COMMUNITIES. SO WE HOPE THAT
WILL STRIKE THE RIGHT BALANCE
AND ENSURE THAT THOSE REALLY
CRITICAL RESEARCH PROGRAMS AT
THOSE UNIVERSITIES- THAT AREN'T
TANGIBLE LOCATION BASED.
WOULDN'T COUNT IN THAT
CALCULATION- AND WE'RE ALSO
PROVIDING IN THE BILL THAT BOTH
THE EXISTING PROGRAM ADVISORY
BOARD AND THE DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES ADVISORY BOARD TO
HELP THE COMMISSION. FURTHER
INTERPRET- WHAT. QUALIFIES. FOR
BOTH OF THOSE 50% PROVISIONS.
OKAY YEAH BECAUSE I MEAN I GET
THE HYDROGEN FUEL STATIONS
THAT'S ALRIGHT BUT SOME OF THE
ACTUAL PRODUCTION AND THAT
RESEARCH PORTION OF THE
PRODUCTION. I CAN'T BELIEVE
THAT ANYBODY WOULD WANT TO STOP
RIGHT TO MAKE SURE THAT THEIR
CLOTHES AND SO. I FEEL A LITTLE
BIT BETTER ON THAT- SINCE. WITH
THAT CLARIFICATION AND I HOPE
THAT EVERYBODY SEES THAT THAT'S
THAT WE DON'T IMPEDE THAT. THE
ALTERNATE FUEL PRODUCTION WHICH
IS REALLY IMPORTANT FOR US TO
MEET. THESE GOALS WHATEVER IT
MAY BE. AND THE RESEARCH HAS
ASSOCIATED WITH THAT. THANK YOU
SENATOR ANY OTHER QUESTIONS. IS
THERE A MOTION. SENATOR NEWMAN
HAS MOVED- WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE FAMILY MEMBER RALF. THANK
YOU I WOULD RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR RIVALS. PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. THE MOTION IS TO PASS
AND REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE
ON APPROPRIATIONS SENATORS
CONSULTS. BATES NO PAGE NOW
ALAN SUCH A LETTER. BECKER
CORTESE DOLLY DOLLY NO DOT DOUG
HIGH BEFORE BLEND THIS MEN.
NEWMAN NEWMAN I. SKINNER NUMBER
MICHALSKI LIKE CASKEY I WILL.
THREE TWO. THANK YOU FOR
REMEMBERING US WE HAD TO HAVE A
LOT OF MEMBERS ARE MISSING SO
WILL HOLD TE ROLE OPEN THANK
YOU MAJOR FOR YOUR PRESENTATION.
AND. HI THIS IS ALWAYS SCEA.
WELCOME TO A FAMILY MEMBER
O'DONNELL YOU KNOW AND YOU ARE
HERE TO PRESENT THE B. FIFTEEN
TWENTY FOUR IS THAT CORRECT
THAT IS CORRECT. FIVE M. NUMBER
THIRTEEN NOW PLEASE PROCEED.
AND WELCOME A GOOD MORNING
MADAM CHAIR AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS I'M PLEASED TO PRESENT
AB FIFTEEN TWENTY FOUR WHICH
DIRECTS THE CALIFORNIA AIR
RESOURCES BOARD TO EXTEND THE
PROJECT EIGHT HUNDRED
INITIATIVE TO PROVIDE CONTINUED
FINANCIAL INCENTIVES TO SUPPORT
THE ORDERING OF AN ADDITIONAL
1-000-215-0016 HUNDRED ZERO
EMISSION- DRAYAGE TRUCKS IN
TWENTY TWENTY TO. LAST YEAR
GOVERNOR NEWSOM SIGNED
EXECUTIVE ORDER AND S. SEVENTY
NINE DASH TWENTY WHICH REQUIRES
ALDRIDGE TRUCKS TO BE NEEDING
TO BE ZERO EMISSION BY TWENTY
THIRTY FIVE. DESPITE THE
ADVANCEMENTS IN TECHNOLOGY THE
TRANSITION TO ZERO EMISSION
DRAYAGE OPERATIONS WILL BE AN
UP HILL BATTLE DUE TO THE PRICE
DIFFERENTIAL BETWEEN DIESEL AND
ZERO EMISSION TRUCKS.PROVIDING
FUNDING TO OFFSET THE UP FRONT
COSTS WILL BE CRITICAL. EARLY
THIS YEAR CARB DIRECTED CREATED
THE PROJECT EIGHT HUNDRED
INITIATIVE TO SUPPORT THE
DEPLOYMENT OFZERO EMISSION
DRAYAGE TRUCKS AT CALIFORNIA'S
PORTS BY SETTING A GOAL OF
EIGHT HUNDRED ZERO EMISSION
DRAYAGE TRUCKS TRUCK ORDERS IN
TWENTY. TWENTY ONE. EIGHTY
FIFTEEN TWENTY FOUR TRACKS
CARPET TO EXTEND THE PROJECT
EIGHTEEN HUNDRED INITIATIVE TO
PROVIDE CONTINUED FINANCIAL
INCENTIVES TO SUPPORT YOUR
ORDER OF AN ADDITIONAL. ONE
THOUSAND TO SIXTEEN HUNDRED
ZERO EMISSION DRAYAGE TRUCKS IN
TWENTY TWENTY TO. CONTINUING
THE STATE'S PROGRESS TOWARDS
THE GOAL OF ZERO EMISSION
DRAYAGE OPERATIONS. JOINING ME
ARE MY PHONE TO TESTIFY TODAY
IS- NATE- SOLD OFF REPRESENTING
THE PORT OF LOS ANGELES AND
ERIC MEANDERS FROM THE SAN
PEDRO BAY PORTS- SUSTAINABLE
SUPPLY ADVISORY COMMITTEE.
THANK YOU- MODERATED I DO HAVE
A MISTER SOLD OFF- PREPARED TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT. GOOD
MORNING SHARE NUMBERS MAKES ALL
OF ON THE OUTS OF THE PORT OF
LOS ANGELES EXPRESSING OUR
STRONG SUPPORT FOR A. B.
FIFTEEN TWENTY FOUR WHICH
CODIFIES CARBS PROJECT EIGHT
HUNDRED INITIATIVES TO EXPEDITE
THE CONVERSION OF THE PORT
DRAYAGE TRUCK FLEET FROM DIESEL
TO ZERO EMISSION. WE ARE PROUD
TO SPONSOR THE BILL AND ARE
GRATEFUL TO THE LEADERSHIP OF A
FAMILY MEMBER- DONALD TRAINER
DO SAYING THE MEASURE AND
COLLABORATING WITH STAKEHOLDERS
TO INCORPORATE LANGUAGE THAT
SUPPORTS THE TRUCKING WORKFORCE.
THE SAN PEDRO BAY PORT
COMPLEXES THE BUSIEST CONTAINER
PORT COMPLEX IN THE WESTERN
HEMISPHERE. IN ADDITION TO
SUPPORTING ONE IN NINE JOBS IN
THE REGION. IN ENSURING 35% OF
OUR NATION'S IMPORTS AND
EXPORTS ARRIVE AT THEIR
DESTINATION. WE HAVE LED AIR
QUALITY AND CLIMATE IMPROVEMENT
INITIATIVES THROUGH OUR CLEAN
AIR ACTION PLAN. WHICH HAS THE
GOAL OF THE ZERO EMISSIONS
TRADES FLEET SERVING THE PORTS
BY TWENTY THIRTY FIVE
CONSISTENT WITH GOVERNOR NEWSOM
EXECUTIVE ORDER. ACHIEVEMENT OF
THESE GOALS RELIED ON THE
PARTNERSHIP OF THE STATE TO
SUPPORT THE PROCUREMENT OF NEW
ZERO EMISSION TRUCKS. CURRENTLY
A USED DIESEL TRUCK COSTS UNDER
FIFTY THOUSAND DOLLARS WELL A
NEW ZERO EMISSION TRUCK COULD
COST OVER THREE HUNDRED AND
FIFTY THOUSAND DOLLARS. CARBS
PROJECT EIGHT HUNDRED AND IT
SHOULD HAVE AN A. B. SIXTEEN
TWENTY FOUR SEEK TO PROVIDE
ESSENTIAL ASSISTANCE THAT IS
NEEDED TO CLOSE THIS GAP AND
MAKE THE NEW ZERO EMISSION
DRAYAGE TRUCKS MORE AFFORDABLE.
BY CODIFYING PROJECT EIGHT
HUNDRED MAYBE FIFTEEN TWENTY
FOUR WILL ENSURE THAT FRONTLINE
COMMUNITIES ADJACENT TO PORTS
WILL BE THE FIRST TO EXPERIENCE
THE AIR QUALITY BENEFITS
ACCOMPANYING THESE INVESTMENTS.
WE SUPPORT THE RECENT
AMENDMENTS TO INCREASE THE SIZE
AND DURATION OF THE PROJECT.
AND THIS BILL HAS BEEN
NEGOTIATING WITH CARB LABOR AND
THE TRUCKING ASSOCIATION. J.
YOUR SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK
YOU MR SOLA FINEX TESTS TO FIRE
IN SUPPORT IS ERICA NEON GROWTH
MR NEANDER FOR YOU ON THE LINE.
I AM POLICE RECEIVED. THANK YOU
GOOD AFTERNOON EVERYONE MY
DESERT THE ADDRESS ON THE SEA
OF GLAD STEVE YOUNG PERSON
ASSOCIATES WE ARE CONSULTING
FIRM SPECIALIZES IN STRATEGIES
TO DEVELOP AND DEPLOY ZERO
NURTURE MACHINE VEHICLE
TECHNOLOGY INTO THE COMMERCIAL
TRANSPORTATION SECTOR WITH
SPECIFIC EMPHASIS IN GOOD
MOVEMENT AND PORTS WE DO A LOT
OF WORK WITH PORTS AND PORT
STAKEHOLDERS ESPECIALLY IN THE
TRUCKING SECTOR AND THEN HAVE
BEEN ACTIVELY WORKING WITH THE
PORT OF LA AND LONG BEACH ON
THEIR PROGRAMS OVER THE LAST
FIFTEEN YEARS OR SO. ONE OF THE
ACTIVITIES OF THE PORTS OF THE
THIN GAUGE MY FIRM TO ASSIST
WITH THE ONGOING FACILITATION
OF THE SUSTAINABLE SUPPLY CHAIN
ADVISORY COMMITTEE- MY
REPRESENTING HERE TODAY THIS IS
AN ELEVEN MEMBER COMMITTEE
MEMBERS ARE ACTIVE AND
KNOWLEDGEABLE ABOUT PORTUGAL
GROUP IN THIS YEAR'S MEMBERSHIP
IS VERY DIVERSE THEY REPRESENT
A VERY SET OF STAKEHOLDERS
INCLUDING LABOR BUSINESS GROUPS
REGULATORY AGENCIES AND
PERMANENT RIPS THE MEMBERS OF
THE COMMUNITY ABOUT THE LA AND
LONG BEACH SIDE OF THE HARBOR.
ADVISOR HE'S BEEN MEETING
ACTIVELY SINCE TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN THE BELT SMITH
RECOMMENDATIONS TO THE
RESPECTIVE PORT EXECUTIVE
DIRECTORS AND CITY MAYORS HIS
RECOMMENDATIONS FOCUS ON
INNOVATIVE WAYS TO ACCELERATE
THE PORTS EFFORTS UNDER A NEAR
YOUR MACHINE TECHNOLOGY.
EMPHASIS OF THE ADVISORY
COMMITTEE OVER THE LAST FOUR
PLUS YEARS. ONE OF THE
RECOMMENDATIONS ADOPTED BY
MAJORITY DIVIDE RETURNING
MEMBERS WITH A LETTER OF
SUPPORT FOR A. B. FIFTEEN
TWENTY FOUR WHICH WAS SUBMITTED
TO YOU ALL ON THIS COMMITTEE.
LAST MONTH. ARE THEY
REPRESENTING THE MEMBERS OF THE
ADVISORY COMMITTEE THAT SIGNED
ON TO THE AB FIFTEEN TWENTY
FOUR LETTERS OR- WHICH INCLUDED
HARBOR TRUCKING ASSOCIATION.
I'LL W. YOU LOCAL THIRTEEN ST
PETER NEIGHBORHOOD COUNCIL
COALITION FOR CLEAN AIR
EARTHJUSTICE AND GREEN
EDUCATION. BUT THE LETTER
SUPPORTING THE ADVISORY
COMMITTEE NOTED THAT WAS
MENTIONED BY SENATOR O'DONNELL
IN HIS OPENING REMARKS. GIVEN
THE EXTREMELY HIGH COST OF THE
ZERO EMISSION TRUCK TECHNOLOGY
AND THE SIGNIFICANT FINANCIAL
CHALLENGES FACED BY THE DRAYAGE
TRUCK INDUSTRY IN CALIFORNIA.
THE STREAMLINING APPROACHING
FUNDING PROPOSED IN THIS BILL
WILL BE HELPFUL IN THE OVERALL
EFFORT TO ACCELERATE THE
PURCHASE DEPLOYMENT AND USE. OF
ZERO EMISSION ELECTRIC TRUCKS
IN THE TRADE MARKET. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME EFFORTS TO
IMPROVE AIR QUALITY IN AROUND
THE PORTS WHILE SIMULTANEOUSLY
ENSURING. THAT THE PORTS REMAIN
COMPETITIVE AN IMPORTANT
ECONOMIC ENGINE FOR OUR STATE.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TESTIMONY OF
WE WILL NOW GO TO THOSE WHO
WISH TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF
AB FIFTEEN TWENTY FOUR. THAT TO
ME I'LL BE ON THE
TELECONFERENCE LINE MODERATOR
YOU PLEASE. KEEP THEM UP. THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR AND LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF AB FIFTEEN TWENTY
FOUR YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. WHICH AGAIN
IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OF AB FIFTEEN TWENTY FOUR HOURS
YOU MAY PRESS ONE. AND THEN
ZERO POINT ONE TWENTY THREE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
FALCONS ALL THE SOMEBODY OUT TO
THE SOUTH COAST AIR QUALITY
MANAGEMENT DISTRICT IN SUPPORT.
NINE ONE FORTY FOUR YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS BACKGROUND BE
AFTER THE CALIFORNIA TEACHERS
AND SUPPORT THANK YOU. LINE ONE
FORTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS JULIA RANDALL WITH
THE COALITION FOR CLEAN AIR AND
SUPPORT THANK YOU KNOW. NINE
ONE FORTY SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS IMMEDIATELY ON BEHALF
OF THE PORT OF LONG BEACH AND
THE COURT. NINE MONO EIGHT YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
NINE ONE EIGHT YOU MAY BE ON
MUTE PLEASE GO AHEAD YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. HI CAN YOU HEAR ME.
YES YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THANK
YOU SEVENTY ON THE TV ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA HYDROGEN
COALITION SUPPORT. AND WE HAVE
NO FURTHER COMMENT IN QUEUE AT
THIS TIME. THANK YOU- WE DO NOT
HAVE A LEAD OPPOSITION WITNESS
IDENTIFIED- SO LET US STAY ON
THE- TELECONFERENCE LINE FOR
THOSE WHO MAY WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION. TO AB FIFTEEN
TWENTY FOUR MODERATOR YOU
PLEASE CALL THEM. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR AND LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION OF EIGHTY FIFTEEN
TWENTY FOUR YOU MAY PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION OF EIGHTY FIFTEEN
TWENTY FOUR YOU MAY PRESS ONE
AND THEN AFTER. WE HAVE NO ONE
IN THE QUEUE AT THIS TIME.
THANK YOU THEN WE'LL BRING IT
TO THE COMMITTEE ARE THERE ANY
QUESTIONS ARE. FOR OUR AUTHOR.
I DO HAVE A QUESTION-
ASSEMBLYMEMBER O'DONNELL I DID
SUPPORT THIS BILL WHEN IT WAS
IN- I BELIEVE IN THE QUEUE AND-
SINCE THAT TIME THERE HAS BEEN
AN AMENDMENT THAT APPEARS TO
IMPACT ON THE SOLO AND SMALL-
TRUCK OPERATORS SON ESPECIALLY
WITH REGARDS TO A. B. FIVE. HOW
COULD YOU CLARIFY THAT IS THAT
ACCURATE- THAT IS ACCURATE THAT
THAT AMOUNT WAS WORKED OUT WITH
THE CALIFORNIA TRUCKING
ASSOCIATION AND OUR FRIENDS AND
LABOR. AND ALL OUR SUPPORT OF
THE BILL TODAY. I'M SURE THE
LETTERS THAT WERE REPRESENTED
OUR- WERE MONTHS AGO AND I
THINK THIS HAPPENED IN THE NEAR
TERM SO I'M GOING TO LAY OFF
TODAY ON THIS. UNTIL I GET A
REAL CLARIFICATION ON THAT
UNDERSTOOD. ON THE IN HOUSE
SENATOR SKINNER- I WILL MOVE
THE BUILDING THANK THE AUTHOR
FOR BRINGING IT- I WAS ALSO A
REPRESENTATIVE OF A PORT
COMMUNITY. AND PEACE AT THIS.
REDUCING TRUCK EMISSIONS FROM
OUR PORT NEIGHBORHOODS IS VERY
POOR THANK YOU. SOME OF THE
BILL. THANK YOU. THEN YOU CALL
THE ROLL PLEASE FAN EITHER
WISHING TO SPEAK. THE MOTION IS
TO PASS AND REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS.
CENTERS GONZALEZ. SIX ALAN
HELEN HI WHICH LETTER. BECKER
CORTESE. DOT PATES III DOLLY
GOLINO DOT DOT I WHERE. LONDIS
MAN. NEWMAN NEWMAN HIGH RUBIO
SKINNER SKINNER A HIGH NUMBER.
BUT KASKY HI CASKEY I WILL. SIX
ONE. WELL NOW WE WILL KEEP THE
ROLE OF AN ASSEMBLY MEMBER FOR
DONNA THANK YOU. WE JUST. TO
WHICH IS OUR LAST IS. SENATE.
OKAY OKAY OKAY GREAT. THE
FAMILY MEMBER WOULD WELCOME.
YOU'RE HERE TO OUR PRESENT AB
FORTY ONE AND SO IS OUR
CHAIRMAN SO. HERE'S THE GAVEL.
I THINK THAT LIFE'S. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MADAM CHAIR AND
SENATORS. THE THIS COMMITTEE IS
WELL AWARE OF THE MYRIAD OF
WAYS IN WHICH THE DIGITAL
DIVIDE HAS MANIFESTED ITSELF
THROUGHOUT OUR STATE THIS PAST
YEAR. WHETHER IT'S EDUCATION
THE DIGITAL MARKETPLACE HEALTH
CARE OR ACCESS TO GOVERNMENT
SERVICES THE GATEWAY TO
FUNDAMENTAL. FUNDAMENTAL
RESOURCES IS INCREASINGLY
ONLINE. SINCE TAKING OFFICE
COMMONSENSE EXPANSION OF
BROADBAND ACCESS BEEN HAS BEEN
A PRIORITY OF MINE. I'M EXCITED
TO BRING THAT WORKING KNOWLEDGE
TO THE TABLE AS WE HAVE
COLLABORATED BY CAMERA LAKE
WITH THE ADMINISTRATION TO
CLOSE THE DIGITAL DIVIDE. THE
CONCEPT THE DIG ONCE IS NOT A
NEW POLICY AREA FOR ME I'M
BRINGING THIS PROPOSAL BEFORE
YOU AGAIN BECAUSE UNFORTUNATELY
SOME OF OUR STATE AGENCIES DO
NOT RECOGNIZE THE URGENCY WITH
WHICH WE MUST ROLL OUT.
CRITICAL BROADBAND
INFRASTRUCTURE. PUT SIMPLY AS
WE UPGRADE OUR STATE ROADWAYS
WE NEED TO DETERMINE HOW NOT IF
BROADBAND IS A PART OF THE
IMMINENT INFRASTRUCTURE
IMPROVEMENTS. I CAN'T THINK OF
A BETTER TIME TO LAY CON DO IT
THEN WE HAVE THE GROUND ALREADY
OPEN. WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
SPENDING BILLIONS OF DOLLARS ON
MIDDLE MILE DEPLOYMENT WHICH IS
EXCITING. BUT WE DON'T HAVE BUT
WE DON'T WE HAVE A FIDUCIARY
RESPONSIBILITY TO MAXIMIZE COST
SAVINGS OPPORTUNITIES. IS IT
TOO MUCH TO ASK THAT WE GET
BROADBAND INFRASTRUCTURE
DEPLOYMENT IN SYNC WITH PLANNED
ROAD INFRASTRUCTURE UPGRADES.
I'M ASKING FOR SIMPLE PLANNING
WHERE STATE AGENCIES WHICH CAN
REDUCE THE COST OF BROADBAND
DEPLOYMENT BY 90% ACCORDING TO
THE FEDERAL HIGHWAY
ADMINISTRATION. ON THE LINE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT IS ERICA
HOFFMAN WITH THE CALIFORNIA
SCHOOL BOARDS ASSOCIATION I
RESPECTFULLY ASK HERE I GO.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLYMEMBER-
MODERATOR DO HAVE MISS HOFFMAN
ON THE LINE. YES SHE IS ON THE
LINE AND HER LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD MR OFTEN. GOOD
MORNING CHAIR MEMBERS ERICA
HOPPING WITH THE CALIFORNIA
SCHOOL BOARDS ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT OF A. B. FORTY ONE.
HERE COMMITTED TO BROADBAND
EXPANSION IN CALIFORNIA TO
CLOSE THE DIGITAL DIVIDE AND
IMPROVE LEARNING OPPORTUNITIES
FOR ALL STUDENTS- OTHER STATED
GOALS NAVIGATE EDUCATION IN THE
TIME OF THE CALL THAT. THE NEED
FOR MORE BROADBAND ACCESS HAS
BECOME ABUNDANTLY CLEAR.
BROADBAND NETWORKS AND SERVICES
ARE CRITICAL FOR EDUCATION BUT
ALSO FOR HEALTHCARE
TELEMEDICINE. PUBLIC SAFETY AND
EMERGENCY RESPONSE WORLD
COMMUNITIES IN LOW INCOME
HOUSEHOLDS WITHOUT ACCESS TO
HIGH QUALITY BROADBAND. ARE
CURRENTLY AT A MEDIA
DISADVANTAGED. SCHOOLS CONTINUE
WITH VIRTUAL EDUCATION PROGRAM
HOMEWORK AND SCHOOL RESEARCH
PROJECT THAT ARE BASED ON THE
DIGITAL PLATFORM. THOSE IN
RURAL COMMUNITIES IN LOW INCOME
HOUSEHOLDS NEED TO BE CONNECTED
IN ORDER TO ENSURE THAT
STUDENTS HAVE ACCESS TO ALL
APPROPRIATE EDUCATION PROGRAM.
EIGHTY FORTY ONE WOULD ENSURE
THAT AREAS WITH LITTLE ACCESS
TO NECESSARY BROADBAND ARE
PRIORITIZED AND ACCURATE AND UP
TO DATE MAPPING OF SERVICES. IN
AREAS IN THE STATE WILL ALLOW
FOCUS WE PLACE ON THOSE AREAS
WHERE SERVICES ARE NEEDED MOST.
INCLUDING CONDUIT IN HIGHWAY
CONSTRUCTION WILL FURTHER THE
EXPANSION OF BOTH MIDDLE MILE
AND LAST MILE PROJECT.
ESPECIALLY WHEN YOU CONSIDER
THE HIGH LEVEL OF HIGHWAY
CONSTRUCTION CURRENTLY BEING
UNDERTAKEN THROUGHOUT THE
STATE. HE AT THE AIRPORT
FINDING AND STREAMLINING
PROCESSES TO HELP ACCELERATE
BROADBAND DEPLOYMENT. IT'S
STILL EIGHT INSURING THAT STATE
AND FEDERAL BROADBAND FUNDING
WILL BENEFIT COMMUNITIES OF
NEED AS QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE FOR
THESE REASONS WE ARE DRIVE OUT.
ON EIGHTY FORTY ONE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISS HA- THAT
CONCLUDE OUR LEAD WITNESS IN
SUPPORT- MODERATOR DO YOU HAVE
ANY ELSE IN ON THE LINE WHO IS
IN SUPPORT OF AB FORTY ONE
PLEASE. AND THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF
AB FORTY ONE YOU MAY PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF AB FORTY ONE YOU
MAY PRESS ONE. AND THEN ZERO.
NINE FORTY ONE. YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES OKAY
THANK YOU- MEDICARE RYAN
SPENCER ON BEHALF OF THE OCEAN
IN SUPPORT. AND ONE MOMENT
WHILE WE GATHER THE OTHER LINE
NUMBERS. NINE SIXTY YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING STEPHANIE TALK TO HIM
AND HIS ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA FORWARD ACTION FUND
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU. AT NINE
FIFTY TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THE RIVER
WORLD CONGRESS OF THE
CALIFORNIA DEMOCRATIC PARTY WE
ARE IN SUPPORT. AND WE HAVE NO
FURTHER COMMENT IN QUEUE AT
THIS TIME OKAY THANK YOU
MODERATOR WILL TAKE IT TO THE
GALLERY ANYONE IN SUPPORT C.
NINE ROOM ONE TWELVE ANY OTHERS
IN SUPPORT. THE NINE- WILL NOW
TAKE IT TO THE OPPOSITION
THERE'S NO LEAD OPPOSITION AT
THIS TIME BUT IS THERE ANYONE
ON THE LINE IN OPPOSITION TO AB
FORTY ONE PLEASE. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR AND LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION OF AB FORTY ONE
YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF
EIGHTY FORTY ONE YOU MAY PRESS
ONE AND THEN THERE. WE HAVE NO
COMMENT THANK YOU AT THIS TIME
OKAY THANK YOU DO WE HAVE
ANYONE IN THE GALLERY IN
OPPOSITION TO AB FORTY ONE C.
NINE ROOM ONE TWELVE C. NINE.
WE'VE CONCLUDED BOTH SUPPORT
AND OPPOSITION WILL TAKE IT
BACK TO MEMBERS ANY QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS ON A. B. FORTY ONE.
SENATOR NEWMAN. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR AND ASSEMBLYMAN WOULD
THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THIS
LEGISLATION THAT YOU KNOW SHE
HAS TWO COMPONENTS WHAT ONE I
BELIEVE THIS IS CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT RIGHT NOW WE'RE
HAVING A CONVERSATION WITHIN
THE LEGISLATURE ABOUT BROADBAND
ACCESS MY BROADBAND EXPANSION-
BUT IT TAKES PLACE IN THE
ABSENCE OF THE KIND OF DATA.
THAT THE PROPOSED MAP WOULD
PROVIDE SO THAT GRATEFUL FOR
THAT LOOKING FORWARD TO ITS
IMPLEMENTATION CAN BE VERY
HELPFUL HAPPY TO MOVE THE BILL
WHEN IT'S APPROPRIATE THANK YOU
SENATOR NEWMAN AND- ASSEMBLY
MEMBER I JUST WANNA SAY THANK
YOU AS WELL FOR BEING COMMITTED
TO BROADBAND AS WE HAVE HERE IN
THE IN THE SENATE WE'VE BEEN
WORKING AS YOU MENTIONED BY
CAMBERLEY ON THURSDAY WE HAVE A
BIG DECISION TO MAKE TO ENSURE
THAT WE ENSURE THAT THAT THE
DOLLARS A SIX BILLION DOLLARS
GETS IMPLEMENTED AND THAT YOUR
BILL STUB YOU KNOW COMPLIMENTS
THAT. SO WITH THAT- WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE I JUST
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR RIVAL
THANK YOU- WE HAVE A MOTION BY
SENATOR NEWMAN MISTER CHIEF.
CONSULTANT CAN YOU PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL- I APOLOGIZE CAN I
JUST INSURE- ASSEMBLY MEMBER
THAT YOU ARE ACCEPTING. THE
AMENDMENTS THAT WERE AGREED TO
IN SENATE ENERGY. YES OKAY
THANK YOU. WONDERFUL THANK YOU
FOR ACCEPTING THE AMENDMENTS
AND NOW WE WILL CALL THE ROLL
PLEASE. THE MOTION IS DUE
PASSES AMENDED AND REFERRED TO
THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS. SENATORS
GONZALEZ HI DOLLARS HI BATES.
HELEN HELEN HI WHICH LETTER.
BECKER BECKER HI CORTESE
CORTESE HI BELLY- DELI HI DOT.
DADABHAI GLARE. LANDIS MAN MAN
HI NIMIN WHEN I BILL. BILL HI
SCAN SKINNER HI NUMBER NUMBER I
LIKE ASKING WHAT KASKY HIGH
BOOK. TWELVE ZERO. THANK YOU
THANK YOU SOMONE NUMBER WILL
LEAVE THE BILL ON CALL FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS PROCEEDED. ALL
RIGHT AS THE MEMBERS IF WE ARE
GOING TO BE LIFTING THE CALL
ON- OUR BILLS AT THIS TIME SO
IF YOU ARE NOT HERE PLEASE COME
TO THE FLOOR WE WILL BE LIFTING
CALLS AT THIS TIME. OKAY WILL
FIRST START WITH OUR- YOU HAVE
A ANOTHER MEMBER WHO'S ARRIVED
AND I THINK WE'RE WAITING ON
ONE MORE. AT THIS TIME. I THINK
HE'S GOING TO BE DOWN SHORTLY
SO LET'S START WITH. THE
CONSENT CALENDAR. AND WE HAVE
TO CONSENT CALENDARS- MISTER
CONSULTANT CAN YOU. WELL THE
FIRST CONSENT CALENDAR PLEASE.
CONSENT CALENDAR NUMBER ONE
WHICH IS S. C. R. THIRTY NINE.
CURRENT VICE CHAIR VOTING HI
HELEN. ELLEN HI ARCHULETA DOT.
HI WHERE. MELINDA'S LENDERS I
SCANNER I'M BURNT UMBER I WILL.
WELCOME BYE. OKAY LET'S CALL
THAT ONE MORE TIME WE HAVE OUR
FINAL MEMBER WHO'S ARRIVED
THANK YOU SENATOR MCGUIRE THIS
IS CONSENT CALENDAR NUMBER ONE
WHICH IS S. C. R. THIRTY NINE.
ARCH ALETTA. WHERE GAR HIGH
SKILL OKAY THE CONSENT NUMBER
ONE HAS BEEN ADOPTED AND
APPROVED CONSENT CALENDAR
NUMBER TWO CHIEF CONSULTANT.
CONSENT CALENDAR NUMBER TWO
WHICH IS A B. THREE FORTY NINE
AND A C. R. EIGHTY EIGHT THE
CHAIR AND THE VICE CHAIR OF.
FULL FLOATING HI. ALAN HELEN HI
ARCHULETA DOT DONNA HI GHAR
ENQUIRE HIGHLANDERS LENDERS I
MEN MAN HI IT'S GOING TO. HI
SKINNER HI AMBER. NUMBER HI
WILL. WELCOME SIXTY BUCKS OKAY
CONSENT CALENDAR NUMBER TWO IS
APPROVED- THE NEXT IS FILE ITEM
NUMBER TWO EIGHTY FORTY ONE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER WHAT. THE MOTION
IS TO PASS AS AMENDED AND
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS THE CHAIR VOTING
OUTSIDE THE VICE CHAIR NOT
VOTING. BAITS SUCH A LETTER.
WHAT ENQUIRE HIGH BLOOD THIS.
WELL. THIRTEEN ZERO OKAY THAT
BILL IS OUT THANK YOU FILE ITEM
NUMBER THREE A. B. FORTY THREE
BY FRIEDMAN. THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED AND REFERRED TO
THE COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
THE CHAIR AND THE VICE CHAIR
BOLD VOTING HI. ALAN ELLEN HI
ARCHULETA. ENQUIRE GLARE HI
SKINNER SKINNER HI NUMBER. WELL
WELCOME HI. FOURTEEN ONE OKAY
THAT BILL IS OUT- THE NEXT
WOULD BE FILE ITEM FIVE WHICH
IS ON HOLD OVER- SO WE ARE NOT
TAKING THAT UP TODAY FILE ITEM
SIX IS A B. SIX FORTY ONE BY
HOLDING. THE MOTION IS TO PASS
AS AMENDED AND REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS THE
CHAIR VOTING OUTSIDE THE VICE
CHAIR NOT PUTTING. BATES BATES
NO. ALAN HELEN HI ARCHULETA ALI
DOLLY NO DOT DOT HI WHERE WHERE
HIGH BLOOD THIS. MAN MAN I
SKINNER. SKINNER HI NUMBER HI
NUMBER I WILL. WE'LL TELL
LENDERS WAS ENOUGH. TWELVE FOUR
OKAY THAT BILL IS OUT THANK YOU
OUR FINAL ITEM NUMBER SEVEN
EIGHTY SEVEN TWENTY THREE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER LOW. THE MOTION
IS TO PASS AND REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS THE
CHAIR VOTING HI THE VICE CHAIR
VOTING NOW. ALAN HELEN HI WHICH
LETTER QUOTATION. CORTESE HI
DOLLY. SORRY BILL IS A BILL IS
NO FILE ITEM SEVEN. MCGUIRE.
MCGUIRE HI MIN. MAN HI RUBY
RUBIO HI SKINNER. SKINNER HI
NUMBER NUMBER HI BY CAL SKI
CASKEY HI WELL WELCOME HI.
THIRTEEN THREE THANK YOU THAT
BILL IS OUT FILE ITEM EIGHT A
B. SEVEN SEVENTY THREE MINUS
ARIAN. THE MOTION IS TO PASS
THE CHAIR VOTING IDEVICE YOU'RE
NOT VOTING. BATES ALAN ALAN HI
MUCH LATER CORTESE CORTESE HIGH
WHERE I WHERE I HE'S GONNA.
SKINNER HI HUMBERT NUMBER I
WILL. WELCOME HI. THIRTEEN TWO
THANK YOU THAT FILLS OUT A FILE
ITEM NINE AB SEVEN NINETY SIX
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER BERMAN. THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AND REFERRED
TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS THE CHAIR NOT
VOTING THE VICE CHAIR VOTING
NOW. GONZALEZ I CONSULT HI ALAN.
HELEN HI HO CHILLA BECKER
BECKER I PUT IT CORTESE HIGH
BUT WHERE THE GLARE HI
BELINDA'S LINDA IS NOW BEEN.
MAN I REVEAL. I WILL BE A LIVE
SCAN. SKINNER HI NUMBER. NUMBER
HI WELL- WILL NOW. TWELVE FOUR
THE BILL IS OUT THANK YOU OUR
FINAL ITEM NUMBER TEN EIGHTY
ELEVEN FORTY SEVEN BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER FRIEDMAN. THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AND REFERRED
TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS THE CHAIR VOTING
HIGH THE VICE CHAIR VOTING NO.
HELEN HELEN HI WATCH LED
CORTESE CORTESE HI WIRE WIRE HI
SKINNER. SKINNER HI NUMBER.
BOOK WE'LL KNOW. ELEVEN FOUR
THE BILL IS OUT THANK YOU FILE
ITEM ELEVEN A. B. THIRTEEN OH
TWO BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER QUIRK THE
MOTION IS DO PASS AND REFERRED
TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS THE CHAIR VOTING
HI THE VICE CHAIR NOT VOTING.
IT'S ALAN. MARCH ELEVENTH.
BECKER CORTESE DAISY HI. WHERE
THE CHOIR HI. RUBIO SKINNER
SKINNER HI NUMBER. WELL WELL HI.
THE MINUTE I. NINE TWO OKAY
THAT BILL IS OUT THANK YOU. OUR
FILE ITEM TWELVE EIGHTY
THIRTEEN EIGHTY NINE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER RADIUS. THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AND REFERRED
TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS THE CHAIR NOT
VOTING THE VICE CHAIR VOTING NO.
GONZALEZ FIVE DOLLARS HI HELEN
HELEN HI ARCHULETA BECKER. HI
CORTESE. CORTESE I. I'M GLAD
WHERE HIGH BLOOD THIS. MAN MAN
I RUBIO. RUBIO I SCANNER
SKINNER HI NUMBER NUMBER I WILL.
WELCOME BACK. THIRTEEN TWO OKAY
THANK YOU THAT FILLS OUT IN OUR
LAST AND FINAL BILL FILE ITEM
THIRTEEN AB FIFTEEN TWENTY FOUR
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER O'DONNELL THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AND BE
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS THE CHAIRMAN THE
VICE CHAIR BOTH NOT VOTING.
GONZALEZ FIVE DOLLARS HI BATES.
FACE NO SUCH A LETTER BECKER
RECORD HIGH. MCGUIRE GLARE HI
BLENDERS BLENDERS NO MAN. MAN
HI REVEAL. RUBIO HI NUMBER
NUMBER I LOOK LOOK NO. WELL FOR
THANK YOU MR CONSULTANT OKAY
THAT CONCLUDES OUR SENATE
TRANSPORTATION COMMITTEE THANK
YOU TO ALL THE INDIVIDUALS WHO
PARTICIPATED IN PUBLIC
TESTIMONY TODAY IF YOU WERE NOT
ABLE TO TESTIFY PLEASE SUBMIT
YOUR COMMENTS OR SUGGESTIONS IN
WRITING TO THE TRANSPORTATION
COMMITTEE OR VISIT OUR WEBSITE
YOUR COMMENTS AND SUGGESTIONS
ARE IMPORTANT TO US AND WE WANT
TO INCLUDE YOUR TESTIMONY IN
THE OFFICIAL HEARING RECORD
THANK YOU AND WE APPRECIATE
YOUR PARTICIPATION THIS
COMMITTEE HAS BEEN ADJOURNED.
NOBLE.